Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir haben auch Geschichten, da werden Spieler geholt, die sind dann drei Monate wieder weg, weil sie nicht richtig betreut worden sind. Die kommen da geführt aus 300 Kilometern Entfernung und sind dann wieder weg. Dann muss man die schon nehmen und sagen, okay, wir haben quasi einen Auftrag, wir holen diesen jungen Menschen, keinen Spieler, sondern als Mensch und wir haben den Ausbildungsauftrag. Das ist nicht die Aufgabe des Altsjugendtrainers, die eigenen Referenzen abzubilden, sondern jeden Spieler, der Talent hat, so gut zu entwickeln, wie es geht. Und das ist schon noch ein Problem.
Aber das gehört zu diesem Gesamtbild dazu. Ja, jetzt sind wir 2014 Weltmeister. Das sind unsere Spieler. Das ist unser NRZ-Jahrgang. Das stimmt nur zur Hälfte, wenn überhaupt.
Ich begrüße euch sehr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zu Tribünengespräch Nummer 50. Wir haben heute eine Dreierrunde hier, also drei Gäste plus mich. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.soschl. Viel wichtiger ist, wer hier sonst noch ist. Zum einen sind zwei junge Herren zugeschaltet aus Paderborn. Zum einen Marius von Cysewski, erst 23 Jahre alt, auch gebürtig aus Paderborn. Hallo Marius. Schön, dass du hier bist und uns auch in voller Lautstärke hören kannst. Und ebenfalls hier ist Alexander Schulte, 24 Jahre aus Ottendorf-Okrilla bei Dresden. Hallo Alex. Und dann noch eine bekannte Stimme des Rasenfunks, der Ed Knallgöwer auf Twitter. Stefan Rommel ist hier aus seinem dunklen Zuhause. Schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Über was wir genau sprechen wollen und so weiter, das werde ich gleich alles noch erklären. Vorher muss ich aber natürlich auch noch zwei, drei Worte zum Rasenfunk selber verlieren. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir tun, finanziert sich ausschließlich über eure Unterstützung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und so ein Tribünengespräch könnte hier auch ein Anlass sein, uns zu unterstützen. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club erfahrt ihr das. Und an dieser Stelle danke ich Jasper, Fabian Sauerland, Purple Passion, Marlis, Stories und Frank, den sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur, sondern haben sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Und dementsprechend konnte ich sie jetzt hier vorlesen. Und mit eurer Unterstützung finanzieren wir in dieser Saison auch noch etwas Besonderes. Wir schicken eine eigene Reporterin zur Frauen-WM nach Australien und Neuseeland. Also mindestens noch ein weiterer guter Grund, den Rasenfunk zu unterstützen. Jeder Betrag hilft. Bitte tut es. Und dann möchte ich euch noch kurz erklären, weil ich weiß, dass die Tribünengespräche auch noch Jahre später gehört werden. Was es sonst noch so im Rasenfunk gibt, ihr bekommt im Grunde inzwischen fast alles, was man so haben kann. Also wir machen Sendungen in der Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga der Frauen und der Männer. Wir machen Sendungen zum europäischen Männerfußball, das ist im Kurzpass der Fall, zur zweiten Männer Bundesliga und eben Tribünengespräche wie diese hier, in dem wir uns ein Thema ausführlich widmen wollen. Und genau das wollen wir jetzt tun. Wir finden uns hier zusammen anlässlich eines Buches, das herauskommt. Und zwar am 6. Mai erscheint die Jahrtausendtalente, wie zwei junge Fußballer ihren großen Traum lebten, die wahre Geschichte von zwei Jugend-Nationalspielern. Aufgeschrieben von Alex Rack, 240 Seiten, 18 Euro erschienen bei EGEL Sports. Und zwei Jahrtausendtalente sind jetzt auch hier in dieser Runde. Ihr müsst jetzt raten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wer es ist. Malius und Alex, ihr seid damit gemeint. Wie ist das überhaupt, wenn man als Jahrtausendtalent bezeichnet wird?
Ach ja, wir haben uns den Titel ja selber gegeben. Erst mal meinen aber natürlich nicht uns damit als Spieler, die wir waren, oder Persönlichkeiten, sondern meinen damit natürlich eine Zeit, über die wir schreiben, über die wir reden, wo im deutschen Jugendfußball sehr viel passiert ist, wo es mit den Nachwuchsleistungszentren einen großen Schritt gab. Und wir sind nun mal die Generation, die da sehr viel miterlebt hat und auch den Wandel miterlebt hat. Und da wir um die Jahrtausendwende weiter geboren sind, haben wir das als sehr passenden Titel empfunden. Das ist natürlich überspitzt ein bisschen, auch ein bisschen provokant vielleicht, dass jemand drüber nachdenkt. Weil das erste, das ich glaube, wenn man den Titel liest, da fallen eigentlich Messi ein oder Ronaldo, die Debatte gibt es ja auch immer. Mit denen stellen wir uns natürlich nicht auf eine Stufe. Da sind ja auch entsprechend keine Profis, aber es geht wirklich um die Zeit. Das wird ja dann auch relativ deutlich im Buch, dass es quasi eine Generation betrifft. Also mit den 2000ern, mit den 99ern, die wir erlebt haben, die quasi dann durch diese Stützpunktsachen, durch den DFB, die wir da aufgebaut haben, mit den NLZs, dass wir da durchgegangen sind, quasi als junge Generation einmal komplett im Weg dadurch.
Deswegen habe ich nämlich auch euer Alter bei der Begrüßung schon genannt, habe mir aber nicht die Frage gestellt, was Stefan und ich dann eigentlich werden. Also ich wäre ein 90er Talent, aber bei mir war nie Talent. Also ich wäre vielleicht so Spieler des Tages. Das wäre so maximal meine Reichweite gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, Stefan, was bei dir gewesen wäre.
Ach ja, auch ungefähr so. Vermutlich.
Mit der, die man dabei war.
Ja, wir wollen nämlich heute über Nachwuchsfußball sprechen, aber auch über Jugendfußball. Weil das eben eure Geschichte ist, auch Anlass des Buches und weil das auch ein wichtiges Thema ist, glaube ich. Ich glaube, ihr veröffentlicht da jetzt zu einem guten Zeitpunkt dieses Buch. Alles beginnt ja aber in der Jugend und da habe ich mich gefragt, also ich habe das Buch von euch gelesen, ich habe in der Vorbereitung auch noch der große Traum von Ronald Reng gelesen, mir Dokus angeguckt und so weiter. Und das Interessante war erstmal was ganz Persönliches, dass es bei mir wahnsinnig viele Flashbacks ausgelöst hat. Also, dass ich mich ganz oft an meine Zeit erinnert habe, obwohl ich in den Niedersten Ligen gespielt habe, nie auch nur irgendeine Chance hatte, mit dem Profifußball anders in Berühung zu kommen, als so wie ich es jetzt mache, nämlich auf dem Sofa, Ihnen anblickend und dennoch habe ich manchmal diese krasse Lust bekommen, Fußball zu spielen und ich fand das interessant, weil wir werden heute noch über viele negative Sachen auch sprechen und auch Dinge, die vielleicht nicht toll sind, aber dass dann doch dieses Gefühl noch so stark ist. Und ich hatte immer einen Geruch in der Nase und das war meine Fußballschuhe und meine Schiemannschuhe. Die waren immer in so einer Plastiktüte und die aufmachen und dann und dann manchmal sich auch daran erinnern, ach ja, es hat ja geregnet und ich hätte die vielleicht mal sauber machen sollen, habe ich natürlich nicht gemacht. Aber das ist für mich wirklich der Geruch von Fußball und den werde ich nie vergessen und ich liebe den. Habt ihr sowas auch, Marius, Alex?
Ich habe, bei mir ist es kein Geruch, was ich schon oft damit verbinde, sind so die, vor allem in der Jugend, als man klein war, diese Spiele samstags morgens, da wurde ja wirklich um 10 Uhr, 9 Uhr mit den Eltern gespielt auf diesen Mini-Plätzen. Die Eltern, alle ganz stolz drum herum. So diese Sommertage am Wochenende, wo dann gespielt wurde, das war, ist schon noch sehr präsent und das war immer mega schön. Das gab ja, es gab ja nichts besseres, als aufzustehen, wo du jetzt, da hast du direkt Schuhe anziehen und dann den Ball da hinterher rennen und kicken. Also für mich ist es kein Geruch, sondern diese Samstagsmorgende bei Sonnenschein- Fußballspielen ist traumhaft, immer traumhaft. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich auch ein Geruch. Also dann habe ich teilweise, wenn ich, okay auch mal im Straßenalter oder so, wenn man über die Straße läuft, hast du den nicht, aber viele der Profis haben ja so menthol Pfefferminz, Öl auf ein Trikot, damit sie eine freie Nase haben. Und damals war ich oft mit meinem Vater im Stadion und in meinen ersten Jahren bei Dynamo Dresden, da war ich fünf oder so und dann als Einlaufkind und dann hast du halt die ganzen Profis da, an die du hochguckst und die haben dieser ganze Duft, der von diesem Menthol da in der Luft war, den habe ich immer noch. Das war immer für mich so ein bisschen, okay das ist Fußball, das ist so ein bisschen da in dem Spielertunnel stehen, warten und mit Herzklopfen da stehen, den habe ich immer noch. Also den hatten wir dann später um 17 und 19, da hatte man das teilweise auch selber drauf gemacht, weil es einfach auch die Nase freigemacht hat. Aber da dachte ich auch, Mensch, jetzt bist du hier, den hast du mit 5 schon gerufen und der ist auf jeden Fall noch sehr sehr präsent.
Stark und du hast Joshua Kennedy, bei dem warst du Einlaufkind, das kam vor, da war das auch der Geruchssinn. Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte den Geruch vom Profi-Fußball nicht mit Menthol in Verbindung gebracht, ich hätte da was anderes gedacht oder am ehesten noch ein Snooze oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist ein ganz anderes Thema, was man vielleicht mal beleuchten müsste hier im Rasenfunk. Aber Stefan hat aufgehäucht beim Menthol. Ist es bei dir etwa eher oder sind es bei dir die Menthol-Zigaretten der Rentner am Rand?
Ich habe ja nie geraucht. Ne, also tatsächlich war das auch bei mir so. Es gab früher, das kennt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr, es gab früher diese kleinen Fläschchen, die waren so weiß mit einer orangenen Stift drauf, glaube ich. Sportler fit kann ja mit V geschrieben auf jeden Fall und das waren diese, das waren diese, vor allem ins Kalt war dann November, Dezember, Januar, gut Januar nicht, aber ab Februar waren wir dann ja wieder draußen, da hat man sich damit vorher eingeschmiert und das war wie so eine Wärme-Emotion und das gab es halt früher bei den Erwachsenen immer und das ist die eine Erinnerung an Kinderfußball und die andere ist halt einfach frisch gemähter Rasen. Frisch geschnittenes Gras, das ist einfach Fußball. Gerade eben ist er noch drüber gefahren mit seinem Aufsitzrasenmäher und jetzt durften wir dann drauf spielen am Freitagabend.
Was auch noch super ist, ist bei uns in Dresden hat man öfter auch mehr auf Kunstrasen gespielt, wenn du dann schön Samstags die Kunstrasen Schuhe ausziehst, weil sie so brennen, wenn du da wirklich den ganzen Vormittag über einen Kunstrasenplatz rennst. Das war mein Gefühl, kein Geruch.
Aber das sieht man schon aus welcher Generation ihr kommt. Kunstrasenplatz, das habe ich, wann habe ich zum ersten Mal auf Kunstrasen gespielt? Da war ich schon hier in München in irgendeiner Soccerhalle und das gab es bei mir nicht. Bei mir war es noch quasi der Ausweichplatz. Wir durften nie auf den richtigen Platz, nur für die Spiele. Und ansonsten waren wir immer am Ausweichplatz und da waren Mauerwurfshügel und alles Mögliche war. Also es war gar kein richtiger Platz und Stefan hat wahrscheinlich auf Asche gespielt, so ehrlich wie er ist.
Ich habe auch noch auf Asche gespielt. Ganz am Anfang habe ich noch auf Asche gespielt.
Bei euch bestimmt, bei uns gab es das ja nicht, weil ich bin ja vom bayerischen Dorf und da hatte jedes Kuhkaff einen Rasenplatz. So und wenn man dann in NRW guckt, da spielen die ja manchmal in der Landesliga noch auf Schlacke. Also heute wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, aber vor 20 Jahren noch auf Schlacke. Das gab es für uns gar nicht.
Ja, ich bin froh, dass ich nie auf Asche gespielt habe, weil das ist auch eine Erinnerung an meine Fußballzeit. Wir werden später noch über Verletzungen sprechen. Jetzt kommt quasi was, was ihr nicht mal als Verletzung wahrgenommen hättet, aber das war das Schlimmste, was mich erwischt hat. Ich hatte die gesamte Saison über permanenten aufgerissenen Oberschenkel von vielen Grätschen. Da sieht man auch ungefähr meine fußballerische Klasse. Die war dann doch sehr eingeschränkt und das ist quasi nie richtig verheilt, weil immer wenn ein bisschen scharf drauf war, dann war halt das nächste Training und dann war es wieder offen. Und dann dieses Gefühl der Bettdecke, die da dran klebt. Und dann in der Sommerpause, dann wurde es dann immer wieder ein bisschen besser und dann ging es ja wieder los. Also wenn ich auf Asche gespielt hätte, da hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich das Grätschen noch abgewöhnen müssen, vermute ich. Stefan, wie hast denn du angefangen, Fußball zu spielen? Auf dem bayerischen Dorf?
Ja, so wie es halt… Also bei uns in der Familie war es so, ich habe zwei größere Brüder, die beide beim Fußball waren und die mich dann… Mein Vater war auch jeden, jedes Wochenende beim Fußball, war auch Präsident vom ansässigen Fußballverein. Dann wächst man halt da voll mit rein. Und wie gesagt, meine Brüder, die sind noch ein bisschen älter als ich. Die haben mich dann immer mitgenommen und da war ich immer mit denen dabei. Der eine hat damals, glaube ich, schon in der C-Jugend gespielt, als ich so fünf war. Also mit fünf habe ich angefangen. Da gab es dann erst mal eine E-Jugend, die gab es früher gar nicht bei uns. Da muss man dann mit dem Nachbardorf zusammengehen und da hat man eine E-Jugend gemacht, damit alle, die jünger waren als zwölf, auch mal endlich richtig Fußball spielen können und nicht nur auf der Schulwiese. Und so ging es los. Ich war dann am Wochenende immer unterwegs, auch dann mit der Herrenmannschaft zu den Spielen gefahren. Und unter der Woche auf besagter Schulwiese, da standen zwei Tore, die uns der Verein dahingestellt hat und da war ich eigentlich jeden Tag. Also wirklich jeden Tag. Und so ging es los. Und dann hat man da halt so ein bisschen vor sich hin gespielt. Ich will jetzt noch nicht ins Thema einführen, aber die ersten Sichtungsmaßnahmen, wie es heute heißen würde, die gab es dann erst ab der D-Jugend. Also wenn man dann elf, zwölf war, davor war da eigentlich gar nichts. Da hat jeder so vor sich hingekickt. Und wenn man nicht beim großen Verein war, dann hat man halt ein bisschen Pech gehabt.
Oder vielleicht auch Glück, dann kommen wir je nachdem raus. Ja, das finde ich interessant, weil bei mir war es auch so, also bei mir gab es quasi gar keine E-Jugend. Die wurde extra gegründet dann für den Jahrgang der Freunde um mich herum, die ich hatte. Und ich weiß noch, dass unser erstes Training war mit Luftballons, weil wir hatten noch gar keine kleinen Bälle. Und die haben es dann kurz probiert mit den großen Bällen. Und die haben wir halt irgendwie keinen Meter weit gebracht. Aber das war halt auch tiefstes Dorf. Also irgendwo in Mittelfranken hatte auch nie irgendwie einen professionellen Anspruch. Und ehrlicherweise, das hat man an allen Ecken und Enden gemerkt. Deswegen war aber auch das Training – also ich habe, das ist mir auch noch mal beim Lesen des Buchs aufgefallen, ich glaube, ich habe nie wirklich Fußball trainiert. Weil ich halt immer irgendjemanden aus dem Dorf hatte, der es gemacht hat. Das waren ganz oft Leute, die auch aus einem Grund irgendwie dieses Training gemacht haben, weil da haben sich nicht die Eltern drum gerissen, das zu machen. Und da wurde auch wahnsinnig viel Kopfballtraining gemacht, wo man heute weiß, mit Kindern vielleicht nicht so die beste Idee überhaupt. Und da wurde auch wahnsinnig viel ohne Ball gelaufen. Das war das völlig normale Aufwärmen. Also du hast den Ball irgendwie erst nach einer halben, dreiviertel Stunde gesehen. Dabei waren wir alle so schlecht am Ball. Es hätte uns sehr, sehr gut getan, mal früher einen Ball zu haben. Und ich habe aber das Gefühl gehabt, und das könnte nämlich jetzt auch schon nicht nur ein Unterschied vom Wohnort sein. Klar, Stefan und ich, wir kommen vom Land. Ihr kommt aus der Stadt, oder ja doch, Ottendorf ist ja auch – nee, Moment, jetzt habe ich es falsch gesagt. Wo habe ich es mir hier aufgeschrieben? Ich finde es gerade nicht mal mehr.
Ich komme aus Ottendorf-Okrilla.
Ottendorf-Okrilla, so ist es richtig. Genau. 10.000 Einwohner habe ich raus. Also in meiner Welt ist das eine Stadt. Ich komme aus einem 600-Einwohner-Dorf.
Ein wirklich kleiner Dorf, ja.
Andere Dimension. Aber bei euch war das ja anders, als ihr quasi auch schon am Anfang Fußball gespielt habt. Also wie war es denn dann in Ottendorf-Ukrilla?
Ja, das Schöne ist, wenn man darüber spricht, wie man aufhört und wenn das Gespräch ja gleich noch in die Länge geht, ein bisschen, wie man aufhört, es ist immer gleich eigentlich egal, wo man startet. Also warum man startet, ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig, ist dieser Spaß daran, diese Faszination ein bisschen auch – man sagt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen böse – aber beim Ball hinterher rennen und das war bei mir, solange ich denken kann eigentlich, habe ich einen Ball in dem Wohnzimmer bei meinen Eltern hinterher gejagt und fand das toll. Dann habe ich die ersten Eindrücke gesammelt über meinen Vater, man durfte ein bisschen länger wach bleiben, wenn Bayern gespielt hat, hat man natürlich das auch mitverfolgt. Erste Stadionbesuche, dann auch relativ junge Wesen, fünf, hat man da schon gestanden, hat dann runtergeguckt und natürlich im Familienblog konnte man das alles sehen und dann einfach aus Spaß auf dem Bolz platzten. Das war noch Asche tatsächlich, also musste man fünf Minuten von uns zu Hause in Ottendorf dahingehen. Da habe ich auch nicht mit Großfreunden oder so, im nächsten Ort war der Kindergarten bei mir. Also auch schon in dem Alter eigentlich im Kindergarten ein bisschen mit dem Quetzling gespielt, aber sobald ich zu Hause war, den Ball rausgeholt und ich hatte relativ früh auch Hütchen bekommen. Zum Durchdribbeln habe ich das versucht ein bisschen, also da gibt es einfach aufnahmlich den Ball da hinterher. Auf dem Platz so ein bisschen, dann ein paar Übungen mache, einfach aufs Tor schießen, ein bisschen den Ball annehmen, Ball hin und her spielen und dann ging es relativ früh, weil ich damals ja da jetzt nicht das hatte, dass ich im Dorf irgendwo einen Verein hatte, also da kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern, dass da einer war und dann war es relativ naheliegend, glaube ich, wenn meine Eltern waren, dass ich da so begeistert Fußball gespielt habe, ob ich mal zum Verein möchte. Also ein bisschen in der Jugend ist das ja auch jetzt, war es ja bei mir der Unterschied vielleicht, dass es Dynamo Dresden am Anfang war, war ja dann Bambinis heißt das ja. Also da muss man jetzt nicht vorspielen oder so, das ist auch einfach nur ein lockeres Treffen, ja man ist dann Mitglied bei Dynamo Dresden eingetragen und eigentlich wird auch noch ein Ball hingelegt und man da laufen dann 20 kleine Jungs ein Ball hinterher, wie solche Ameisen. Das ist dann passiert, genau. Also da ich dann so viel Spaß am Fußball hatte, weil ich da einfach so begeistert von war, bin ich dann zum nächstgrößeren Verein gegangen. Das war dann letztendlich bei mir Dresden, weil ich so davon begeistert war. Wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen mit Joshua Kennedy, das war dann ein bisschen später. Also ich bin dann wirklich ganz fußballromantisch, wie man so schön sagt, über das Stadion das erste Mal den großen Verein sehen in der Stadt, darüber Fan geworden. Da war ja noch bei mir die Option, einen anderen, kleineren Verein zu nehmen oder dass ich da spiele. Aber dann weiß ich noch, ob ich meinen Papa im Ohr gehangen habe. Ich habe gesagt, wenn ich es mir aussuchen möchte, dann möchte ich natürlich für den Verein spielen, wo Joshua Kennedy spielt. Also das war dann natürlich den Amo Dresden.
Tausende Kinder haben das damals gesagt, wahrscheinlich.
Also für mich war der der Held mit seinen längeren Haaren, Stürmbanden, wie er die Dinger da reinköpft. Und dann ist es wieder ähnlich. Also dann noch jeden Tag später in der Grundschule, auf dem Bolzplatz vor der Schule, in jeder Pause, haben wir da Mini-WM gespielt und gefühlt, jeder hat einmal die Champions League gewonnen am Tag. Und so ist man dann halt einfach aus Spaß und Leidenschaft wirklich in Balder irgendwo ins Netz hauen.
Malius, ja, du kannst jetzt nicht einfach Ja sagen. Du warst da nicht in Dresden mit dabei.
Ich würde Alex erstmal zustimmen zu seiner Geschichte. Nein, bei mir war das natürlich erstmal geografisch. Meine Eltern wohnen immer noch, 200 Meter sind das vielleicht, von meinem Heimatverein, von dem Sportplatz entfernt. Also war ich ja eh schon mal quasi, habe auf dem Platz gelebt schon, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und bei mir war das auch so. Ich kann mich kaum, also ich kann mich nicht mehr so dran erinnern, wie ich da hingekommen bin und alles, das noch mir meine Eltern immer so ein bisschen nach erzählt. Aber was ich alles weiß, ist immer, wie ich da über einen Platz gejagt bin und dass ich das auch so geliebt habe, immer da auf dem Platz zu stehen. Es gibt so eine kleine Story, da habe ich meine Mutter mal fragt, Mama wann ist Training? Mama, wann ist Training? Und ich glaube, sie war ein bisschen genervt, gerade einen bisschen stressigen Tag gehabt und hat irgendwie gesagt, in acht Stunden oder so irgendwie und ich habe das irgendwie völlig falsch verstanden und habe irgendwie verstanden, es ist gleich schon. Habe ich meine Sachen genommen, bin zum Platz, weil Wache war ja auch um die Ecke und dann hat meine Mutter, habe ich den ganz parabor gesucht, weil die irgendwie nicht auf dem Schirm hatte, dass er das sich schon abhauen wollte und musste ganz parabor auf den Kopf stellen, weil der Sohn sich mal gedacht hat, der geht jetzt schon mal ein paar Stunden vor im Training auf den Platz und spielt schon mal und habe mich immer gewundert, ob es hier keiner, aber war ja auch egal. Ich war allein, ich hatte einen Ball, ich hatte ein Tor, wer braucht es ja nicht. Da konnte ich mich ja als Kind oder kennen wir ja alle, konnte man sich auch echt gut selber beschäftigen, nach Latten schießen, irgendwie versuchen, dem Ball genau auf die Linie zu passen, immer in die linke Ecke, immer ins rechte Ecke schießen. Dann hatten wir noch so einen Zaun drumherum, da kann man natürlich immer schön doppelt was mit dem Zaun spielen und solche Sachen und mal gucken, ob da nicht, wenn man da richtig gegenpüllt, der auch so zurückkommt, dass es eine Flanke ist und den dann mit einem Kontakt reinmachen. Solche Sachen und das war auch diese spielerische, einfach Spaß daran zu haben, sich zu verbessern und irgendwie so alles zu vergessen. Fußball war ja auch immer, da konntest du echt alles ablegen. Das war damals, glaube ich, schon so. Als Kind bekommt man das zwar nicht mit so richtig, aber das war immer ja total befreiend, wenn man auf dem Platz stand. Und so bin ich dann dazu gekommen, dass ich dann auch einfach durch den Heimatverein eine mega coole Zeit hatte. Einmal geografisch und auch so war es echt richtig, richtig schön da.
Also der SV Heide-Paderborn ist das. Ich habe auch immer alleine gespielt. Das liegt an der Dorfsituation. Also viel habe ich alleine gespielt, also viel. Bei mir war es immer nicht – also ich hätte nie so passen wollen, dass er auf der Linie liegen bleibt. Das fand ich total langweilig. Ich wollte immer den Schlänzer in den rechten oberen Winkel. Und irgendwann konnte ich auch genau diesen einen Schuss, aber halt sonst sehr, sehr wenig. Stefan, du wirst wahrscheinlich auch viel Zeit auch alleine verbracht haben, weil Fußball ist ja gar nicht immer in der Gemeinschaft, so ist es im Training und im Verein. Aber man kann ja eben viel auch. Ich habe auch viel gegen die Kirchentür. Das war quasi mein Zaun, wo ich dann quasi die Pässe geübt habe. Das hat die Mesnerin nicht so toll gefunden.
Also wenn man ausnahmsweise – es war aber echt selten, wenn man keiner von den Kumpels Zeit hatte, weil zu zweit hat es dann schon gereicht, da war dann einer am Tor, der andere hat gegen sich selber gespielt und ein bisschen so vor sich hin kommentiert, wie so ein Fußballkommentator, was jetzt gerade so passiert. Wenn das mal tatsächlich nicht der Fall war, dann hatten wir früher noch so eine alte Wäschestange im Garten und auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite war die Garagenwand und da habe ich dagegen geschossen und dann konnte man aufs Tor schießen, also quasi an die Wand schießen, den Schuss üben und dann, wenn er zurückprallt, natürlich dann gleich einen aufs Tor machen. Das hat dann auch gereicht für die nächsten Stunden. Meine Mutter musste sich nicht um mich kümmern, sondern hat mir den Ball denen geschmissen und dann ging es los.
Habt ihr Erinnerungen an irgendwelche Spiele aus eurer Kindheit? Also bei mir, dadurch, dass wir die Abteilung damals gegründet hatten, war es ein harter Weg in den Fußball. Also das erste Spiel war 0 zu 31, bei dem wir fünf verschiedene Torhüter hatten. Ja, ich mag Emskirchen bis heute nicht den Ort, weil wir damals gegen die verloren haben. Unter anderem war ich auch im Tor. Ich war damals ganz stolz, dass sie gesagt haben, ich soll raus, weil ich wäre zwar der beste Torhüter, aber ich wäre auch der Einzige, der schießen könnte. Ich sage ja, der Schuss in den rechten Bändchen war das einzige, was ich konnte. Aber tatsächlich lagen wir in unserem zweiten Spiel 0 zu 16 zurück. Und dann habe ich das 1 zu 16 erzielt. Und ich weiß noch, bis heute – also ich weiß alles von diesem Tor. Ich weiß noch, dass der ganze Sportplatz ausgeflippt ist, weil es war das erste Heimspiel. Und da waren dann auch alle Eltern da. Und ich weiß auch noch, wie die Gegner völlig fassungslos waren, dass die sich so freuen, weil es aber halt das erste Tor war. Und ich weiß auch noch, dass ich das danach noch in jeder Einzelheit erzählen konnte. Das ist so eine Erinnerung, die wird nie weggehen. Und davon habt ihr doch bestimmt auch welche, Marius.
Ja, ich kann dir eine Geschichte erzählen von unserem ersten Kopfballtor damals als Mannschaft. Wir hatten zum Glück wirklich eine Mannschaft. Wir waren immer alle sehr, immer die Gleichreiche dabei über mehrere Jahre. Und dann hatten wir auch einen Kollegen von uns, der war damals auch immer schon sehr groß. Und konnte halt dementsprechend auch schon damals relativ weit und hart schießen. Und als kleines Kind auch auf dem kleinen Platz den Ball von der Eckfahne überhaupt in die Mitte zu bekommen und dann noch hoch. Das war ja damals schon nicht so einfach. Und der war der Größte, der auch der Einzige, der den Ball da bis hoch in die Mitte schießen konnte. Und dann hat der, glaube ich, mir das Ding quasi im Eichsternkopf geschossen. Und ich habe unser erstes Kopfballtor für die Mannschaft gemacht. Und das war sie noch ziemlich genau. Und das war mega cool, weil wir das so gefeiert haben, als ob wir da auch gerade die Champions League gewonnen hätten. Weil so ein normales Tor und alles, ja klar, das passiert mir, aber ein Kopfballtor in dem Alter, das war schon besonders. Und da kann ich mich noch sehr gut dran erinnern. Das war sehr schön. Und das war damals auch noch auf Asche. Das war tatsächlich noch auf Asche.
Da köpft man dann auch ein bisschen lieber.
Ja, danach wurde der Ascheplatz aber dann weggemacht und dann habe ich auch keine Kopfballtore mehr gemacht.
Und dann war das vorbei.
Ja, du bist halt wie so ein Tennisspieler, die es halt nur auf Sand können. Also du bist quasi Raphael Nadal. Alex, hast du auch so eine Erinnerung?
Du, ich muss gerade überlegen, aber ziemlich lange schon. Bei mir sind es, ich kann dir jetzt nicht so was, eher so Schnappschüsse kann ich dir wiedergeben. So ein Bild, so ein Gefühl, was ich damals hatte. Oft, also ich hatte jetzt nicht wirklich ein Spiel, wo ich sag, also aus der Jugend, wo wir ziemlich jung waren, klar, wenn wir später mal ein paar Spiele hatten, da natürlich kann ich jedes Detail erzählen. Aber von damals, was ich nicht, vor allem was ich auch nie vergessen werde, ist auch das, was Marius sagt, war bei mir auch ganz toll. Das erste Training bei den Bambinis, beziehungsweise wo ich das erste Mal darauf ließen, das war auf diesem Tatan-Boden. Einfach so ein kleiner Court war das so. Da war auch Basketballkörbe oben dann über den Tor angeschraubt. Da hatte ich die Bambinis. Da konnte ich hin, wenn du laufen konntest, gefühlt. Da konnte ich dich beim Training anschließen. Und bei den Jungs, die, weiß ich ganz genau, wie wir da alle zusammen standen, mit denen habe ich ich glaube sechs oder sieben Jungs habe ich bis zum Ende zusammengespielt. Also das war ein cooler Haufen einfach, was so auch, sagst du, dass man länger zusammengeblieben ist. Und das mal nicht mit diesen Schnappschüssen. Ich weiß, wo wir zusammen mal in der Stadtmeisterschaft gespielt haben, dann später auf Kunstrasen, wo wir alle zusammen waren. Die ersten Turniere. Wir sind teilweise auch weit gefahren bis nach Rülm, da die Hallenturniere in der Hallensaison zusammen da in dem Bulli sitzen. Acht Sitzer sitzen da hinten drin und man redet den ganzen Tag mit den Jungs. So war es. Das daran kann ich mich noch erinnern. Und die Namen werde ich mich auch immer erinnern können. Also das war dann wirklich ein eingeschwornes Auffen. Die sind sogar bis zur U19 zusammengeblieben. Manche spielen natürlich noch ein bisschen Fußball in der Vierteliga. Die sind noch eingeschworn. Das ist wie eine Familie. Die sind immer noch total befreundet. Ich bin da mit 15, 14 Jahren raus. Aber das war, woran ich mich super erinnern kann. So an dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl.
Geil. Und Tartanboden. Im Sommer, wenn der so warm ist, dann die Hand drauf und an der Hand riechen. Also das ist für mich, aber das ist auch ein bisschen mit Schuhzeit gekoppelt. Da sind es ja nicht nur positive Erinnerungen. Stefan, wie ist es bei dir? Du hast ja wahrscheinlich jetzt schon zweierlei Erinnerungen. Weil einmal deine eigene Kindheit und dann bist du ja auch als Trainer immer mal wieder unterwegs.
Ja, also das kann ich jetzt gar nicht mit anfangen mit der eigenen Kinder, weil ich wirklich gefühlt alles noch weiß. So Zeug vergesse ich einfach nicht. Ich kann mich da auch gar nicht dagegen wehren. Was tatsächlich wirklich komisch war, war, ich habe in der EU mal von einem Opa, von einem Mitspieler von mir, der hat mir nach dem Spiel zwei Mark gegeben, weil ich so gut gespielt habe. Das war natürlich pädagogisch nicht besonders wertvoll, weil er seinen eigenen Enkel damit gespielt hat, aber das war eine komische Veranstaltung. Aber wie gesagt, ich weiß alles noch, die ganzen Sichtungs-Sachen später noch und wie es dann auseinander ging, wie die Mannschaften, wir sind auch zusammengeblieben, von der E-Jugend bis hoch zur A-Jugend, hat sich nicht wirklich viel getan, außer dass der eine oder andere mal weggegangen ist, aber im Grunde war es dann auch schon, wenn ich das jetzt so vergleiche mit dem, was momentan so passiert, oder wie jetzt der Jugend-Kinderfußball eingeteilt ist, was da alles drum herum passiert und so weiter, das ist wirklich wie Tag und Nacht. Also das kann man sich heute nur noch schwer vorstellen, so wie das alles versucht wird, durchzutacken und dass man ja kein Talent übersieht und so weiter. Ja, das war früher nochmal, also es gab eine Sichtungsmaßnahme, wenn du da krank warst oder einen schlechten Tag hattest oder so was, dann hat sich kein Mensch mehr für dich interessiert. Auch in den Jahrgängen danach war es dann quasi vorbei und man mag sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie viel wirklich große Talente da, also durch dieses riesen Netz durchgeflutscht sind einfach. Und jetzt ist es natürlich besser organisiert, allein durch die Förderstrukturen und auch die Örtlichkeiten, die eingerichtet wurden mit den Stützpunkten und so weiter, das gab es da früher in der Art alles gar nicht. Aber ich bin trotzdem immer noch so, ich bin da hin und her gerissen, ich weiß, dass wirklich viel auch gesichtet und auch gesehen wird, aber ich stelle mir die These in den Raum, dass es ganz viele Talente noch auch in Deutschland gibt, die einfach so durchrutschen, die irgendwann mal draußen raus sind aus diesem System und dann auch quasi nicht mehr wirklich reinkommen. Und ja, dass so diese, ich meine, ich wohne jetzt hier auch, ich wohne ganz im Nordwesten der Republik, da kommt danach nicht mehr viel und 50 Meter nach Westen ist die Grenze zur Niederlande. Und ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass Leute, die ja ein bisschen weg, also Kinder, die ein bisschen weg sind vom Schuss, wo jetzt nicht unbedingt ein großes oder überhaupt ein NRZ in der Nähe ist, dass es für die dann schon schwieriger wird, da auch Fuß zu fassen. Es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass einer aus Zwiesel oder aus Aurich, dass es da keine großen Fußballtalente geben kann, die es auch wirklich noch so schaffen, dass sie in diese Fördersysteme kommen. Die sind oft genug mit dabei. Man sieht das jetzt auch, was auch bei uns jetzt der nächste wirklich große Verein ist dann Werder Bremen. Das ist so 100 Kilometer weg von hier. Was die dann auf die Beine stellen, das ist alles super, aber da gibt es so viele Sachen, die aus meiner Sicht dann immer noch nicht gut oder schief laufen, dass man manchmal so gar nicht weiß, wo man anfangen soll.
Das erste, was wir mal denken, weil wir gerade über den Titel gesprochen haben, der Tausendtalente. Das ist ja das, wo wir das Glück hatten, weil genau da dieses Scouting-Netz angefangen hat, wo man gesagt hat zu den 2000ern, 2002, 2003, wo man die These in den Raum auch bestellt hat, uns geht kein Talent mehr durch die Lappen quasi. Das wir wenigstens jeden einmal gesehen haben, das war ja so das Ziel. Soviel das jetzt gerade rausgehört hab, Stefan, dass das, wo es jetzt nicht so NRW-Dichte an Vereinen beispielsweise gibt, dass es da schwieriger ist, wenn man auf dem Land unterwegs ist, dass da die Sichtung vielleicht nicht ganz so gut ist, aber es ist definitiv ordentlich unsere Meinung. Also das haben wir mitbekommen, du bist ein Paderborn, jetzt ich in Dresden. Der Schritt, den man damals gemacht hat, der war richtig gut, weil auch mit diesen Stützpunkten, man kann das natürlich noch weiter ausarbeiten, noch intensiver machen, noch engmaschiger machen dieses Letz. Aber allein dieser Grundgedanke von diesen Stützpunkten, das war ja das Schöne, das weiß ich auch noch bis heute. In Dresden war ich dann beim Stützpunkt-Training, da ist man dann ja hingegangen, wo man ja eigentlich sagt, okay, höher als Dresden geht es jetzt zwar nicht, aber man musste da quasi hin oder man durfte dahin, weil man ausgewählt worden ist. Und da waren ganz, ganz viele Spieler aus dem Kreis bei uns. Also wirklich die Namen über die ganzen Dörfer hinweg, wirklich kleine Vereine, wo die Jungs, die da am besten gekickt haben, durften dann zum Stützpunkt gehen. Und da hat man zusammen trainiert. Und dann wurde auch nochmal geguckt, halten die mit und so weiter. Also das war wirklich ein richtiger Schritt, dass man das engmaschiger machen kann und auf jeden Fall auch in den abgelegeneren Orten, wenn man mal so sagen möchte, dass auch da die Scouts bzw. die Sichtung durchgeht. Auch über einen längeren Zeitpunkt, Stefan, genau wie du sagst, wenn es nur an einem Tag die Leistung zählt, das ist natürlich nicht Sinn der Sache. Es gibt ganz viele Jungs, die auch spät zünden. Lass es die Pubertät sein, lass es was anderes sein, wo die auch einfach ein bisschen später ihre Leistung abrufen können. Und dass man die dann sieht, dass man das nicht an einem Tag, sondern wirklich ihre Perspektive sieht. Ich glaube, die ist ganz gut, kann aber auf jeden Fall besser sein. Die ist, glaube ich, auch noch ein bisschen anders, wie das ausgibt, weil in Dresden du hast ja Schlitzpunkt gespielt, als du bei Dresden. In Paderborn ging das aber gar nicht. In Paderborn war es so, wenn man bei Paderborn gespielt hat, durfte man nicht im Stützpunkt spielen. Letztes Jahr die Frage ist, kann das jeder Kreis machen via Bockart oder gibt es da ein System, eigentlich von ganz oben, wo man sagt, okay, weil ich finde den Gedanken im Prinzip gar nicht verkehrt, dass man sagt, die spielen jetzt hier in Paderborn schon bei einem NLZ, dann lass uns mal die anderen, die vielleicht noch bei den bisschen kleineren Vereinen spielen, dann lass die mal zum Stützpunkt gehen und sich da entwickeln, weil dann hast du ja wirklich ein relativ großes Netz, die du abgrast. Dann hast du einmal das NLZ, wo die Spieler ja definitiv auf dem Radar sind und dann nochmal den Stützpunkt, wo du halt nochmal deutlich mehr Spieler in die Chance gibst, weil sonst ist in Paderborn wahrscheinlich so. Du kannst ganz Paderborn sich zum Training beim Stützpunkt treffen und du kriegst nochmal zwei, drei andere, vielleicht die noch ein bisschen zocken können dazu, hast aber im Prinzip die gleichen 20 Spieler da rumlaufen. Deswegen ist das halt dann, ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt ist, aber als bei mir damals so war, weil ich auch nie bei Paderborn war und deswegen im Stützpunkt war, weiß ich, dass es so war. Und das ist halt die Frage, ob das dann richtig ausgeliebt wird oder was überhaupt der richtige Ansatz wäre. Nur das sollte ja eigentlich auch einheitlich sein, damit man da, wie du das gesagt hast, Stefan möglichst viele sieht und dauerhaft sieht und nicht immer dann nur die gleichen 20 ist.
Ich glaube, man muss sich klar darüber werden und das sind sie eigentlich auch beim DFB, was genau ist die Funktion oder der Stützpunkt ist. Es gibt irgendwie 366 oder um die Drehung, glaube ich, ist die Zahl.
Kannst du das einmal ganz kurz erklären, Stefan, damit wir quasi alle hören und auf demselben Stand haben. Also wir sprechen jetzt quasi über das, was quasi eingeführt wurde rund um die Jahrtausendwende, deswegen Jahrtausendtalente. Es wird immer verbunden mit der furchtbaren EM 2000, aber es wurde ja schon, ich glaube, ab 98 langsam in die Wege geleitet und nur um so ein ganz grobes Bild zu zeichnen. Damals war es noch so, dass sowas wie die Freiburger Fußballschule, das war damals quasi die Vorlage für ein in Deutschland fast nirgendwo sonst gesehenes System. Daran hat man sich orientiert und dann und seitdem haben wir so ein duales System, würde ich es jetzt nennen, eben aus Stützpunkten und aus Nachwuchsleistungszentren, also den NLZ. Kannst du kurz erklären, in ein paar Worten, wie funktioniert denn seitdem das Scouting oder das Talentefinden, die Nachwuchsförderung?
Genau, also es geht los, also ich kann es jetzt, ich sage es jetzt, wie es hier in Niedersachsen ist, es geht los in der E-Jugend, dass Kreisauswahlen gebildet werden, so wie es früher, als es zu meiner Zeit auch noch war. Da gab es der Kreisauswahl und dann hat man gegen andere Kreisauswahlen gespielt und wenn man gut genug war, durfte man in der Schwaben-Auswahl spielen, wenn man da gut genug war, durfte man in der Bayern-Auswahl spielen. So, jetzt ist es so, dass Kreisauswahlen gebildet werden, da schicken alle Freine ihre, in Anführungszeichen, talentiertesten Spieler hin und dann guckt man sich die an und dann wählt man die aus im Alter von, also wenn die die E-Jugend kommen, zehn Jahre ungefähr. Dann spielen die zwei Jahre in der Kreisauswahl, haben immer so Vergleichsspieltage mit den anderen Kreisauswahlen in dieser Region um und dann wird schon so ein bisschen vorsortiert und geguckt, okay, da sind die und die Spieler dabei und jetzt geht es nach diesen zwei Jahren, wenn die dann in die D-Jugend kommen, dann gibt es einen, in Niedersachsen heißt das Sparkassen Cup, das wird von der Sparkasse gesponsert. Das ist wie so ein Sichtungstag, da spielen ganz normale Clubmannschaften gegeneinander. Da sind dann die Sichtungstrainer mit da, das sind die Kreisauswahltrainer mit da, die auch schon so ein bisschen gesagt haben, ja die und die Spieler können man sich vielleicht mal genauer anschauen und aus diesem Sichtungstag werden dann die, ich glaube 12 plus 3 sind es oder 13 plus 2, also 15 Spieler pro Stützpunkt rekrutiert, wenn man das so hart sagen darf. Und die werden dann von da ab in diesem Stützpunkt einmal wöchentlich anderthalb Stunden noch zusätzlich zu ihrem Vereinstraining ausgebildet. Das ist die Funktion, wenn man von unten her geht, des Stützpunkts. Aus meiner Sicht gibt es eine zweite Funktion auch noch für ihren Stützpunkt und das ist dann bei Talenten, die wie Marius gesagt hat, aus dem NLZ vielleicht mal rausfallen, weil es ja jedes halbe Jahr einen Cut gibt, dass man denen dann sagen muss, du, beleid, Marius, reicht das nicht mehr. Damit die nicht jetzt quasi so ein bisschen ins Bodenlose fallen oder weder in ihren Dorfclub zurück müssen oder wo auch immer sie herkommen, dass man denen diesen zweiten Bildungsweg bietet oder mit dem Stützpunkt. Also, dass die quasi immer noch ein sehr gehobenes – und das Training da ist wirklich gut – ein sehr gehobenes Kleingruppenmannschaftstraining, je nachdem, wie man das jetzt definieren mag, da bekommen. Also, es gibt quasi – der Stützpunkt ist aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen zwischen diesem Vereinsleben, Vereinsfußball und diesem aber sehr in sich abgekoppelten NLZ-Fußball. So würde ich das jetzt definieren. Und von diesen Stützpunkten gibt es, wie gesagt, über Deutschland verteilt. Ich meine, 366 sind es, und hier in Niedersachsen sind es 54. Also, es ist schon echt relativ engmaschig, wie Alex vorhin schon gesagt hat. Das stimmt, definitiv.
Ich kann nur sagen, bei mir war das so – in Sachsen gibt es auch die Sportschulen, in Chemnitz, Leipzig und Dresden. Und das war mein – ich kann mich so erinnern – der Grund, warum wir noch beim Stützpunkt dabei waren, weil man dabei sein musste, um dann quasi mit zur fünften Klasse und siebten Klasse quasi zur Aufnahmeprüfung für dieses Sportgymnasium, Sport-Realschule quasi qualifiziert. Deswegen waren wir mit dabei. Ich kenne es nämlich auch so, dass das eigentlich abgekoppelt ist. Also, es ist ja eigentlich überflüssig, wenn man schon mal bei Paderborn spielt, dass man noch zusätzlich zum Stützpunkttraining geht.
Genau. Aber sonst – Genau, also so weiß ich das – sorry. So weiß ich das aus Bremen noch, als ich da noch gewohnt habe, vor ein paar Jahren, da war das definitiv so. Stützpunkt Bremen Mitte waren nur Spieler von diesem ganzen Stadtteilverein. Da war von Werder im Prinzip keiner mit dabei. Weil es einfach klare Ansage war, das so zu machen.
Und dazu ergänzen eben dann die NLZs, die Nachwuchsleistungszentren, die ja dann auch irgendwann eine Lizenzauflage wurden, für die es auch einen gewissen Standard gibt. Was mich eben jetzt nur einfach wundert, ist, auf der einen Seite hört sich das ja nach einem auch regional gedachten Netz an. Und das ist halt unterschiedlich stark. Da gibt es schon Regionen, die sind eben weniger gut versorgt als andere. Bekommt man aber vielleicht auch einfach nur schwierig weg im Land wie Deutschland. Und auf der anderen Seite sagst du aber Stefan, dass da auch sehr viele SpielerInnen, also wir sprechen ja auch über Mädchen, da durchrutschen können. Also auf der einen Seite gutes Netz, auf der anderen Seite sieht man aber vielleicht manchen Akteur, manche Akteurin da nur einmal als Sichter.
Ja, also es gibt immer im besten System, auch so wie es sich hier darstellt, gibt es halt auch immer einen bunten Punkt und dieser Flaschenhals, das ist halt ganz oft der oder die Trainer. Und wenn der Trainer oder die Trainer aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen ein Talent, also man muss erst mal definieren, was ist ein Talent, was ist der Talentbegriff, der eine Trainer sieht in einem Spieler, der halt das Glück hat, zum Beispiel am Anfang des Jahres, geboren zu sein und in seinem Jahrgang einfach körperlich schon so weit zu sein, sieht er halt was anderes, weil er einfach andere Schablonen anlegt. Ein Vereinstrainer schlägt andere Schablonen an, der muss halt Spiele gewinnen am Wochenende, damit er sein, ich sag's jetzt mal echt überspitzt schon, auch wenn wir jetzt schon zu tief einsteigen, sein Job auch in gewisser Weise sichern kann. Und der andere Trainer sieht aber in einem Spieler, der körperlich noch nicht so weit ist, der vielleicht in seinem biologischen Alter noch ein bisschen hinterherhinkt oder das auf dieser Ebene ausgleichen könnte, sieht er was ganz anderes, weil er zwei, drei Sachen kann, die alle anderen nicht können. Und der sieht vielleicht, dass dieser Spieler in zwei oder drei Jahren, wenn der dann in der Pubertät noch einen Schuss nach oben macht, körperlich stärker wird und so weiter, sieht er ein anderes Potenzial als in den 14, 15 anderen Spieler in diesem kleinen Kreis. Und so ist diese Sichtweise halt immer so sehr subjektiv und auch ein bisschen, ja, auch getrieben von bestimmten Parametern, dass man da immer wieder, dass da immer wieder Fehler passieren. Fehler ist ein Scheißwort, aber dass da immer wieder Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die jetzt vielleicht für Spieler A, B und C jetzt nicht so besonders glücklich waren, weil der, wenn der jetzt noch weiter so gefördert würde wie die letzten Jahre, dass der in ein paar Jahren besser ist als alle anderen. Aber das ist immer so eine Wette auf die Zukunft. Man wird dann im Nachhinein nie mehr sagen können, hat man es doch mal anders gemacht. Es wird keinen geben, der sagen kann, ja, das war jetzt falsch oder das war jetzt richtig. Und du kannst dann nur vermuten, dass der eine Typ, der dann jetzt irgendwo in der Kreisliga versandet, dass der eigentlich der geilere Kicker ist als irgendeiner, der jetzt momentan in der dritten Liga rumspringt. Das wirst du immer haben. Und das ist halt ein Problem, das lässt sich schwer lösen, aber dann gibt es vielleicht ein paar Schrauben, wo man drehen könnte, um das besser zu machen. Und das versucht der DFB jetzt auch, muss man dazu sagen.
Total interessant, Schiffran, dass du das schon ansprichst, weil da kommen wir ja später noch dazu. Aber man kann ja schonmal sagen, diese Entscheidung hängt von ziemlich wenigen Leuten ab. Auf allen Ebenen, sei das natürlich, ob man jetzt jeden Spieltag spielt, das hängt dann von einem Trainer. Später mal, wenn man ein Trainerteam hat, von denen ab wird man gesichtet, hängt dann von einigen ab. Und vielleicht ganz interessant zu wissen, als ich quasi mit dem Stützpunkt durch war, als ich da aufgehört habe, mein Vater war ja zwischendurch auch Trainer, der C-Lizenz, B-Lizenz gemacht war, war auch Stützpunkt-Trainer gewesen in Dresden. Und der hat auch öfter mal mir erzählt, dass genau das, was du gerade gesagt hast, Stefan, oft der Fall war. Er fährt dann mit seinen Stützpunkt-Trainer-Kollegen die Spieler durch, die Plätze durch, guckt sie Spiele an. Und selbst da, die haben sich ja gut verstanden, dann sagt mein Vater dann, ey, hier Nummer 8, der kann ganz gut kicken. Dann sagt der andere Stützpunkt-Trainer, ey, sehe ich gar nicht. Ja, also ich, was siehst du da? Und selbst da hat man schon gemerkt teilweise, dass Trainer was anderes gesehen haben in den Spielern als vielleicht andere. Weil wir denken immer, ja toll, man hat so super Talente. Wenn man den Spielen sieht, jo, der kann kicken, der räumt alles ab. Aber da sind ja auch wenige. Vielmehr gibt es Spieler, wo man vielleicht nochmal hingucken muss. Ist der jetzt so schlecht, dass wir den aussortieren müssen, wo man wirklich gucken muss? Zündet der vielleicht nochmal genau das, was du gesagt hast, Stefan? Ist das mit der Pubertät? Vielleicht hat er irgendwann doch die Veranlagung, die er dann abrufen kann. Und selbst da beim Schützpunkt habe ich das mal so im Haushalt mitbekommen, als ich dann nichts mehr damit zu tun hatte, dass selbst da auch genau das, was du sagst, stattgefunden hat. Dass teilweise dann auch Spieler gesichtet worden sind, wo die keiner auf dem Schirm hatte. Ja, und mein Vater hat dann einen aus Rieser geholt, einen Torhüter, den hat keiner richtig wahrgenommen. Der ist dann bei Dresden Profi, Profi-Torhüter geworden. Der ist dann nach Dynamo gekommen, zu Dynamo Dresden von Rieser und ist Profi-Torhüter geworden. Der wäre ja auch eigentlich auf Messerschneider wäre er auch vielleicht gar nicht quasi in dieses System reingerutscht. Genau wie du sagst, Stefan, wäre der in Rieser geblieben, an einem Vorort von Dresden. Ein bisschen weiter weg. Aber genau das ist es dann. Das entscheidet sich dann ja subjektiv mit diesen Einstellungen, Parametern, die du euch gesagt hast. Es gibt halt wahrscheinlich zu wenig klare Parameter in den jungen Jahren, an denen man festmachen könnte, ob man jetzt einen Spieler wirklich entwickeln kann. Oder wie ihr gesagt habt, der hängt körperlich noch ein bisschen nach. Das ist ja dann wirklich, wenn ein Trainer vielleicht schlecht geschlafen hat, nacht davor und generell. Und dann hat er gerade ein Spiel gesehen von den Profis und steht dann in dem Moment gerade auf Spielertypen und denkt sich dann in irgendwelche Leute rein, die er sehen möchte. Und lässt dann die, die er persönlich vielleicht gar nicht so gut findet, dann vom Spielertyp einfach mal ein bisschen außen vor. Vielleicht auch ungewollt dann, aber das passiert. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, sollte es da nicht vielleicht klare Parameter geben, an denen man dann festlegt, okay, guck mal, der ist körperlich nicht so weit, aber der ist im Gegensatz zu einem anderen z.B. mit beiden Füßen unterwegs oder der probiert es zumindest. Und das ist vielleicht das kleines Problem, was es noch gibt, dass da so einzelne Leute, was ja auch normal ist, einen Spielertypen sehen, denen er persönlich gefällt, aber das vielleicht gar nicht oder das ist nicht die Aufgabe des Trainers, als Jugendtrainer die eigenen Präferenzen abzubilden, sondern jeden Spieler, der Talent hat, so gut zu entwickeln, wie es geht. Und das ist schon noch ein Problem, definitiv. Gerade in dem Alter. Also wir sprechen jetzt hier nicht über U17, U19, wo wir dann wirklich sagen, okay, da trennt sich so ein bisschen die Spreu von weit, so man sagt, jetzt sieht man auf jeden Fall, geht es Richtung Junioren, Bundesliga, geht es da in Richtung Auswahl und Rufi, aber wir sprechen hier gerade im Stützpunkt-Training über so ein Alter, wo es ja vor allem um Entwicklung und Spaß immer noch geht, also 10 bis 15. Also, dass man da Leute aussortiert, wo man vielleicht sagen kann, muss eigentlich noch nicht sein, lasst sie noch mit dabei sein in dem Pool. Die Aussortierung und dass es dann mal wirklich um Leistung geht, kommt eh früh genug. Wir besprochen die Themen mit den Parametern.
Ja, aber das wäre nämlich genau mein Punkt gewesen. Wir reden hier darüber, als ob das Einzige, was wichtig wäre, der Profifußball wäre und so wichtig der ist. Und dass die NLZs das als Maßgabe haben, völlig klar. Aber zum Beispiel der DFB, der ja rein theoretisch nicht in seiner Satzung drin steht, wir müssen jetzt Weltmeister werden, sondern da steht drin, wir sind ein gemeinnütziger Verein, wenn wir nicht gerade irgendwelche Steuergeschichten falsch machen und uns die Gemeinnützigkeit entzogen wird. Also gerade der DFB müsste ja so nicht denken. Und da könnte man ja vielleicht auch sagen, also wir werden über sortieren und aussortieren noch sprechen und vor allem über das Aussortieren. Warum muss überhaupt im Alter von 10 bis 15 schon sortiert werden? Also geht es nicht in dem Zeitpunkt, wo man sowieso eigentlich nicht erkennen kann, wie sich ein Spieler entwickelt, geht es da eigentlich nicht vor allem darum zu fördern, dass die Kinder, die dann ja noch Kinder sind, würde ich sagen, dass die die Freude am Fußball behalten, dass die ein Wissen über Fußball und über Training vielleicht sich aneignen, nicht mit dem Ziel, dass sie mal später alle selber Trainer werden, aber weil das halt was Gutes ist, wenn man sich bewegt, wenn man aktiv ist und so weiter. Und das ist die Frage, die ich mir stelle, auch eben vor dem Hintergrund und da können wir dann vielleicht so ein bisschen in eure Biografien wieder reingehen, wenn ich überlege, wie sich auch das verändert, wenn man in Berührung mit diesem System kommt. Denn, also, Marius, du kannst ja vielleicht mal erzählen, wie es bei dir abgelaufen ist, aber relativ schnell, so hatte ich zumindest den Eindruck, ist es nämlich so, ich habe damals am Wochenende gespielt und das war auch immer wie so ein kleines Abenteuer, weil man hat die Nachbar-Dörfer alle kennengelernt, die hatte man ja keinen Grund, die zu besuchen. Kirchweih war ja noch nicht interessant als Kind und so weiter. Aber ich hatte das Gefühl, bei euch zwei, und ihr seid ja da stellvertretend für eine Generation, waren es ja dann auch sehr früh sehr viele Spiele, eigentlich sehr wenige Pausen, ständig irgendein Turnier, irgendwas. Hier noch, hier noch ein Lehrgang, hier noch eine Maßnahme. Und das macht zwar alles Spaß, aber ist ja auch die Frage, wie verändert das eigentlich den eigenen Bezug zum Fußball? Ich habe immer nur einmal am Wochenende gekickt, aber fand es mega geil. Hab auch Training geliebt ohne Ende, außer der Trainer hatte schlechte Laune. Dann war es die Hölle. Leider hatte er oft schlechte Laune. Gerade mein erster Trainer. Wie war das denn bei dir, Marius?
Also am Anfang natürlich war das erstmal ziemlich cool. Ich habe dann auch relativ schnell, ich bin ja schon zur Kreisauswahl, was wir eben gesprochen haben, zwei Jahrgänge vor meinem Jahrgang eingeladen worden, also bei den 98ern das erste Mal. Und da haben meine Eltern aber gesagt, du spielst jetzt in dem Alter definitiv nicht mit zwei Jahre älteren in der Kreisauswahl mit. Das reicht, wenn du nächstes Jahr zu den 99ern, die nie älter sind, mitgehst. Und natürlich wird das dann da schon mehr. Man trainiert im Verein, dann trainiert man einmal mit der Kreisauswahl. Wir hatten einen mega coolen Kreisauswahl-Trainer, der hat aber auch jeden Sonntag noch ein Turnier angesetzt. Also da war Samstags Spiel mit dem Heimatverein, mit Heide, und am Sonntag war dann irgendwo ein Turnier mit der Kreisauswahl. Das ist dann auch dazugekommen, und nach der Kreisauswahl eigentlich das Gleiche dann mit dem Stützpunkt. Und das hat sich dann bei mir schon verändert, weil ich habe ja dann so ein bisschen auf drei Hauptzeiten getanzt. Da war einmal der Heimatverein, das war Heide, dann kam der Stützpunkt dazu mit einmal Training und auch Turnieren. Und ich war dann zu der Zeit ja auch relativ schnell, sag ich mal, in diesem Perspektiv-Trainingsprogramm bei Dortmund mit drin und hatte dann da auch noch mit trainiert. Und das ist natürlich dann schon viel. Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so gewesen, dass es keinen Spaß gemacht hätte. Das war ja eigentlich der Traum, über den wir am Anfang gesprochen hatten. Ich konnte die ganze Woche Fußball spielen, das war ja an sich erstmal ziemlich cool. Natürlich ist es nur so, dass sich der Blickwinkel schon verändert. Ich sag mal, so mit Dortmund, da bin ich ja dann auch hingekommen, weil ich ja auch wirklich dabei sein wollte und noch besser werden wollte. Das war dann nicht mehr dieses reine, ja, jetzt kicken wir einfach mal nur und gucken mal, wie es läuft. Da hat der Stützpunkt natürlich einen so ein bisschen darauf vorbereitet, aber das ist dann natürlich bei Dortmund nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer gewesen. Ich finde auch, nochmal um einen Punkt zurückzukommen mit dem DFB und dem Verein, eigentlich schießt der DFB sich eigentlich ein Eigentor, weil dieses Fördern generell und auch in den jungen Jahren würde ja im Endeffekt auch zu besseren Ergebnissen und besseren Spielern führen, wenn man da wirklich alle mal einbezieht und mal guckt, ob da nicht doch vielleicht einer noch irgendwo rumläuft, der ziemlich gut kicken kann, aber einfach gerade noch ein bisschen hinterher hängt, weil er körperlich nicht so weit ist oder noch andere Punkte nicht stimmen. Von daher ändert sich das dann schon, auch bei mir hat sich das geändert, weil es relativ viel war. Es war aber in dem Alter wirklich noch so, dass es einfach nur Spaß gemacht hat. Prost und Ganzen. Das war ja immer der Traum und deswegen kann ich da jetzt nicht sagen, das war total dramatisch, dass ich da bei Heide, bei Dortmund und bei Stützpunkt trainieren und spielen musste. Das war immer noch ein dürfen und ich habe es total gerne gemacht. Es war alles andere als schlimm oder dramatisch oder so. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Alex, bei dir?
Ich muss schmunzeln, weil wir gerade ja darüber gesprochen haben, wie wir zum Fußball kamen und dieses auf den Platz gehen und wenn man Spaß hat. Und ja, dieses, sagen wir mal, man sagt ja schneller zu Straßenkick. Ein bisschen einfach ein Ball in die Hand ab zum nächsten Platz, wo es irgendwie geht, wenn man keinen Platz hat. Dann stellt man sich irgendwie ein paar Hütchen hin. Und da sind wir ganz schnell wieder bei so Grundsatzfragen. Nur um das anzusprechen mit enger Taktung. Was ist mit Lösungen suchen im 1 gegen 1? Zum Beispiel lernt man das in so einem Taktiktraining oder macht man das lieber, wenn man bis zum gewissen Alter einfach mit seinen Jungs jeden Tag Mini-WM spielt und so weiter. Das ist ja wirklich, wo man wirklich darüber diskutieren kann. Weil ich bin ja das extreme Gegenbeispiel dazu, wenn ich mal überlege. Fünfte Klasse, elf Jahre alt, ist man elf oder zwölf? Aber ich habe, wie wir gesprochen haben, mit dem Stützpunkt-Training habe ich es geschafft. Weil ich mich auch wahnsinnig darüber gefreut habe, habe ich mich ja für das Sportgymnasium in Dresden entschieden. Wirklich eine tolle Einrichtung, muss man sagen. Gerade für andere Sportarten, die ich mir angucke, leichter ledig. Short-Track heißt das, glaube ich. Wahnsinnig tolle Talente, die da wirklich mal Strukturen haben, wie sie auch im Fußball derzeit sind. Es ist ja wirklich wenig andere Sportarten außer Fußball, die gefördert werden können. Da trifft sich dann alles. Das war wirklich cool. Das hieß aber gleichzeitig für mich, 5. Klasse, 7.15 Uhr zweimal die Woche auf dem Platz stehen, anstatt in der Schule zu sitzen. Dann hast du einfach mal mit 11, eine Woche, mit achtmal Training, dann dazu nach der Schule schnell in den Zug, dann war nämlich der Stützpunkt ein bisschen weiter außerhalb, da noch mit dem Zug hinfahren, mit der Sporttasche, mit dem Schuhranzen. Aber dann war man schon viel auf Achse. Dann gab es eigentlich einen Tag, einen Nachmittag, natürlich frei, aber der Rest war durchgetaktet. Das ist eine Grundsatzfrage, weil ich habe es wirklich genossen, dieses Training auch, und ich bleibe auch dabei, dass dieses Frühtraining morgens ganz, ganz toll war. Meine Trainer damals aus dem Verein waren auch an der Schule angestellt dafür, waren da Sportlehrer quasi, und haben uns trainiert. Dann waren noch mal aus unserem Verein, aus meinem Jahrgang vier Jungs, wir vier waren noch mal im Einzeltraining morgens. Dann geht es auch genau darum, Passtraining, wie macht man Sachen. Ich hatte wirklich viel Techniktraining, wie passt man, wie stellt man sich zum Ball, Torschusstraining usw. Und das wirklich ganz intensiv in Vierergruppen, früh morgens zweimal die Woche, aber durchgetaktet. Es gab bei mir dann definitiv nicht mehr auch die Kraft, und allein die Zeit war nicht da, den Ball unter die Hand zu nehmen und sagen, Jungs, ich bin mit euch mal wieder auf dem Sportplatz oder so unterwegs. Also es war dann wirklich Fußball nur noch in Trainingsanreiten. Da ist man dann ganz schnell, dann war es ja quasi, ich bin zu Dortmund gewechselt mit 15 und hatte wieder weniger Training. Also es war dann schon so, dass das in Dresden zu der Zeit wirklich, wirklich viel war. Aber warum spielt man Fußball? Also ich hab's gelebt, auch diese harten Sachen morgens. Im Platz steht im Winter um 7.50 Uhr, okay, da war man ein bisschen in der Halle, aber auch schon mal kalt.
Darf ich da kurz noch was zwischenfragen? Ich bin ja aus südlichem Bayern und ich kenne dieses Prinzip der Skischulen aus Österreich. Also wirklich Skigymnasium zum Beispiel, wo die da, so wie es jetzt offensichtlich bei dir war, wo die die Alpinen und die Langlauftalente dann gefördert haben und die Kinder dann dementsprechend da bringen gegangen sind. Ist das, weil es in Dresden ist, ist das ein Überbleibsel aus einer DDR-Struktur noch?
Genau, die DDR-Strukturen sind das noch, die drei. Es gibt drei Hauptstützpunkte, das ist Leipzig, Chemnitz und Dresden. Da gibt es diese Sportschulzentren und dann wirklich, wir hatten selbst Schach war bei uns als Sport betitelt, mit einer wirklich tollen Botschaft gespielt. Ja, ich sage ja nur, aber wurde da auch toll gefördert. Ich will jetzt nicht die Diskussion starten auf Schaffenssport. Ich will damit sagen, dass selbst Schachtalente an diese Schule kamen, um gefördert zu werden. Und das ist wirklich, viele sagen jetzt vielleicht, oh Gott, da ist mit jungen Jahren schon viel Förderung. Aber das war wirklich, wie wir auch mal oft sagen, dann war die Schule ab und zu ein bisschen das Problem, das zeitlich unterzukriegen. Ich bin total ein Fan davon gewesen, von dieser Schule. Erstmal war die Top-Modern. Und da geht es vor allem, wenn man Richtung 10. 11. Klasse geht. In Dresden wurde das Strecken genannt. Man konnte sein Abitur strecken. Und dann war man wirklich in kleinen Klassen von zehn Leuten, man hat zusammen sein Abitur gemacht. Aber dann waren das Talente, die hatten dann, weiß ich noch, eine Turmspringerin zum Beispiel oder auch eine Tischtennisspielerin. Die sind dann halt auch mal drei Monate in Asien unterwegs und machen da ihre Trainingseinheiten. Die sind dann bei der Jugend-Olympiade und so dabei. Und kriegen dann trotzdem quasi die Schule stellt sich hinten an. Und das ist wirklich ganz toll, ganz eng getaktet da, auch mit Internatsplätzen zum Schlafen. Also wo kriegt man, wenn man leichter Athlet, dann am Ende Stabhochspringer ist, vielleicht wo kriegt man Internatsplätze und kann sich da wirklich vollkommen auf diese Ausbildung konzentrieren. Und das ist da gegeben. Also das ist wirklich, wirklich hoh ab. Ja, war ganz lustig auch mit der modernen, der Klassenräume. Und da bin ich nach Dortmund gekommen und ganz herzlich direkt an der Schule und der hat ganz stolz präsentiert, dass die Stufe einen Overhead-Projektor hat. So ein Tageslichtschreiber, wie man den noch kennt, den man so aufklappen kann. Ich so, ey, komm ich nicht da. Was ich an der Schule in Dresden hatte, war echt, also das war wirklich toll. Das kennt man, die Förderung kennt man vom Fußball, ja, die ist auch in den anderen NLZ sehr gut. Aber die war für die anderen Sportler.
Ja, aber ich finde, ich fand das damals immer so beneidenswert, weil ich war ja oft in Österreich beim Skifahren und habe mir immer gedacht, ich würde töten, wenn es so etwas mit Fußball in Deutschland gäbe. Und ich habe schon nie verstanden, warum es das nicht gibt. Ich habe das wirklich nie verstanden. Und jetzt, genau, und so nach und nach haben wir jetzt, das bist du ja selber besser als ich, kamen ja dann auch diese Elite-Schulen in den Start vom DFB, wo man das so versucht hat, ein bisschen, zumindest ein bisschen miteinander zu verknüpfen.
Also wir sind jetzt auch schon fünf Jahre raus, weiß ja jetzt nicht, wie es jetzt ist. Wir waren der Start, das war definitiv ausbefugt. Ich würde sagen, man hat auch gesehen, dass wir der Start waren quasi. Also das war weit weg, das muss man ja wirklich sagen, das war weit weg, zu dem Zeitpunkt zumindest. Und das hat da wirklich, wie gesagt, mit diesen Vierer-Truppen, man wusste, welche Trainer da sind, diese Taktung war da, man wusste, man kann da morgens was anderes trainieren als vielleicht am Abend im Mannschaftstraining. Und das war schon, also das muss man erstmal woanders finden. Also das war, klar, jetzt ist wieder die Grundsatzfrage, ob diese Förderung so eng getaktet sein soll, aber wenn sie so eng getaktet ist, findet man es, glaube ich, wenig besser, weil das war unfassbar gut.
Ja, ich habe da noch einen anderen Gedanken dazu. Also so Sportschulen, Vereine haben das zum Teil auch schon, also der FC Bayern und 1860 zum Beispiel hatten hier in München schon sehr früh mit einem Gymnasium auch eine Kooperation. Und jetzt inzwischen ist es dann auch irgendwie halbwegs offiziell eine Sportschule, aber ich finde gerade den Unterschied von euch beiden sehr interessant, weil das eine findet an einer Schule statt, in einer Struktur, in der im Grunde jeder das halbwegs umgesetzt bekommt. Und ich habe den Eindruck bei dir, Marius, mit deinen drei Hochzeiten, auf denen du da getanzt hast, Heide, Kreisauswahl plus BVB, schließt das nicht dann schon Kinder und Jugendliche aus, wo zum Beispiel die Eltern nicht in der Lage sind, die Fahrerei und den ganzen Alltag zu organisieren. Es gibt ja da doch einen Unterschied, finde ich, in der Organisation dieser beiden.
Ja, absolut. Ich hatte da total Glück mit meinen Eltern, weil mein Vater selbstständig, der konnte dann das sowieso machen, wie er wollte. Und meine Mutate da auch dann Zeit dafür und für meine Geschwister auch. Definitiv, das war schon, die haben mich schon immer überall natürlich dann hingefahren und dann mit meinen beiden Geschwistern waren wir auch zu dritt. Zwei Elternteile, drei Kinder. Auch schwierig dann teilweise. Vor allem, wenn es so viel war, das schließt bestimmt einige aus. Ganz sicher, das habe ich zum Glück nicht erleiden müssen. Die Tatsache, dass Heide direkt nebenan war, war auch ganz gut. Da war zum Beispiel kein Fahrtweg für beide da. Da konnte ich selber rübergehen. Aber ja, klar, selbst wenn ich mal so ein bisschen vorgreife in der Zeit, wo ich dann aus Paderborn nach Dortmund gependelt bin. Zwei Jahre, da hat mich Dortmund ja auch abgeholt. Aber auch, sage ich mal, hier ist die Straße heißt Frankfurter Weg. Die ist so ein ganz bisschen außerhalb, ganz bisschen vom Stadtkern von Paderborn. Da mussten meine Mutter mich ja auch immer hinfahren nach der Schule, damit ich Dortmund nicht von da mitnehmen kann. Und mein Vater musste mich abends immer um 4.30 Uhr abholen, dass ich nach Hause komme, was essen kann und das wieder am nächsten Tag machen kann. Also definitiv, ohne ganz viel Einsatz der Eltern, ist das trotz aller Hilfe vom Verein gar nicht zu schaffen.
Geht gar nicht.
Weil sonst, ich hätte gar nicht mitfahren können. Hätte ich irgendwie, hätte meine Mutter oder mein Vater mich nicht nach der Schule zum Treffpunkt fahren können. Ich hatte da bis 20 vor vier Viertel vor vier Schule. Um vier, kurz nach vier war Abfahrt nach Dortmund. Ich hätte da ja gar nicht hinkommen können, so schnell. Also wäre schon allein deswegen unmöglich geworden. Und das ist definitiv, die Vereine versuchen ja wirklich viel mit Zügen, mit Fahrdiensten vom Bahnhof und so weg, auch mit dem Abholen. Aber das schließt definitiv einige aus, die nicht diese Möglichkeit haben, dass die Eltern oder sonst irgendwer aus der Familie da so hintersteht und das mal eben so machen kann. Ja, keine Frage. Auf jeden Fall. Bei mir war die Extremphase dieser, gibt den ganz berühmten Dienstag, wenn ich auch nicht vergesse, war fünfte Klasse der Dienstag, 7.15 Uhr auf dem Platz stehen, dann 11.40 Uhr Unterricht, bis 17.30 Uhr, 18.30 Uhr wieder Training und dann bis 21 Uhr gehst du wieder durch die Zimmertür in dein Zimmer rein. Also dann geht es quasi 6.30 Uhr, geht es außer Haus. Und da hatte ich auch ganz tolle Eltern. Meine Schwester war auch gar nicht so untalentiert im Wasser. Also die war auch dann an der Sportschule Schwimmerin und dann Spieler-Triathletin, die war dann für mein Glück quasi auch auf dem Internat. Deswegen konnten meine Eltern sich ein bisschen auch auf mich da fokussieren, was die Fahrerei angeht. Aber die sah dann so aus, morgens dann zu diesem Frühtraining hingefahren, zwischen der Schule und dem Training nochmal kurz nach Hause was essen, weil das ging einfach nicht so gut. Und dann natürlich abends wieder abholen. Also das war, wie Marius sagt, es ist möglich. Es geht ja darum, die Talente auch dazu fördern in dem Sinne. Die Nachwuchsleistungszentren schaffen das auch ganz gut, die geben sich da super Mühe. Aber es fängt ja auch damit an, was auf dem Frühstückstisch zu haben, abgeholt zu werden vielleicht, abends was Gutes zu essen kriegen. Wenn man das nicht hat, wenn die Eltern vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Nachtschicht haben oder so, wenn die solche Jobs haben, das macht es auf jeden Fall schwerer. Und da hatten wir auch das große Glück, dass meine Eltern auch selbstständig gewesen sind. Sie sind immer noch zu der Zeit, dass man da Unterstützung hatte, einfach auch zeitlich, also allein mit Fahr, mit einem Bus oder so, wäre das bei mir auch alles zeitlich ganz viel schwerer geworden.
Geld, also Armut ist immer noch der größte diskriminierende Faktor in Deutschland und nur kleines Gedankenexperiment. Wie viele Profi-Fußballerinnen kennt ihr die von Alleinerziehenden Mütter zum Beispiel großgezogen wurden? Das ist ja eine riesige Bevölkerungsschicht, die es gibt. Man muss das auch nicht problematisieren, weil ich persönlich finde, es muss nicht immer alles in den Leistungssport hineinführen. Das ist eigentlich so eine Grundthese, die ich habe. Aber man sollte eben auch nicht den Fehler machen, zu behaupten, jetzt würde schon jeder gleich gefördert. Das ist nicht so. Es gibt unterschiedliche Startvoraussetzungen. Für manche Menschen wäre ein solcher Alltag völlig undenkbar, einfach nicht umsetzbar. Und ich finde, der zweite Aspekt, der da noch mit drauf kommt, ist, wir werden heute, glaube ich, noch direkt und indirekt viel über Druck sprechen, der auch in diesem System ist, auf allen Akteuren, auf den Eltern, auf den Trainern, auf den SpielerInnen. Und auch solche Alltagsgestaltungen führen da Druck zu. Also zum einen, weil es extrem schwierig ist, neben all dem Ganzen noch eine schulische Ausbildung zu Ende zu bringen. Ich meine, du hast da gesagt, gerade der berühmte Dienstag, da hast du die Hausaufgaben gar nicht erwähnt. Ich vermute aber, du wirst auch Hausaufgaben gehabt haben.
Weniger hat es so gekriegt, die Schule. Da konnte man hingehen, mit Unterschriften usw. sagen, der Lehrgang ist da und da. Ich bin da nicht da. Dann wurde auch nicht irgendwie Druck gemacht, dass man mal einen Fehltag hat oder so. Sondern dann wurde geguckt, wie kriegt man dich mit Hausaufgaben gut gefüllt in der Zeit. Da wird auch mal gleichzeitig in den Auge zugedrückt, wenn man mal die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hat. Aber es gab echt. Ich hatte in Paderborn schon ein akutes Hausaufgabe. Ich bin morgens früh raus, bin zur Schule, dann, wie ich eben gesagt habe, 20 vor 4, Viertel vor 4 aus der Schule fertig. Meine Mutter hat mich abgeholt, irgendwie ganz schnell zum Frankfurter Weg, dann nach Dortmund. Ich habe weder auf der Fahrt nach Dortmund Hausaufgaben gemacht, noch abends, als ich dann um halb 10, 10 Uhr mit Essen und einem fertig war, habe ich mich auch nicht mehr hingesetzt. Das war natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger alles da, weil ich sage mal, das war ein ganz normales Gymnasium. Und da war jetzt nicht so das Verständnis so riesig, für Sachen, die dann da so abgehen. Und irgendwie habe ich mich da auch durchgemogelt, immer, das hat schon funktioniert. Aber ich sage mal, wenn man sich jetzt, wenn man wirklich ambitioniert seine Hausaufgaben in dem Alter hätte machen wollen, wäre das dann nochmal nach 22 Uhr dran gewesen. Hätte das, wäre der Deal gewesen, wenn man das hätte machen wollen.
Und es wäre ja aber vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, Hausaufgaben zu machen, weil wir schaffen ja nur wenige Prozent in den Profifußball.
Definitiv. Es wird ja mal salopp gesagt, der Plan B. Aber man sagt immer, ja, es gibt den Plan B, machen wir den Plan B, ein bisschen Schule. Wir nutzen mal die Plattform, die wir haben, nehmt den Plan B bitte nicht, einfach nur so locker.
Es will bloß einer zugeben, dass es der Plan A ist.
Also man sagt immer, man will, man hat die Scheuklappen auf und sagt, ich bin der eine oder ich bin das eine Bruder, ich gehöre zu den ein Prozent, die Profis werden. Wir haben ganz viele Geschichten, wo es auch mal am letzten Punkt auch nicht zur Karriere gereicht hat, auf Verletzungen zum Beispiel zurückzuführen. Das ist ganz gut, wenn man die Schule, was in der Tasche hat, was gut ist.
Und jetzt auch, ohne jetzt ein großes Fass aufmachen zu wollen, aber alles, was wir jetzt die letzten 10 Minuten gehört haben, weist ja schon darauf hin, was es für große Probleme geben kann. Und jetzt stellen wir es sich mal vor, Kinder, die heute 10, 11, 12 sind, die überlegen, ob sie vielleicht so einen Schritt gehen sollen, ob sie diese ganzen Entbehrungen auf sich nehmen sollen, die Eltern mit dazu und so weiter. Das sind aber alles Kinder, die jetzt 2 bis 2, 5 Jahre quasi kaum oder nur teilweise Schule hatten wegen Corona. Und jetzt kommt es noch on top, gerade Kinder, die jetzt in der fünften Klasse zum Beispiel sind, die in diesem Übergang sind auf eine weiterführende Schule, die 2 Jahre lang – ich sage das mal überspitzt – nichts gelernt haben in der Schule. Die sollen jetzt auf einer anderen Schule sich zurechtfinden, die sollen den Verein wechseln, die sollen vielleicht sogar in ein Leistungszentrum gehen. Sorry, das kann niemals funktionieren, tut mir leid.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz, ganz schwieriger Punkt für die.
Definitiv.
Wir haben es ja nicht erlebt, aber wir mussten es zum Glück nicht so erleben. Wir waren als Corona-Beiher eigentlich schon über 18. Wir haben das ja nicht erleiden müssen, so extrem. Aber für die muss ich mir auch ganz, ganz, ganz hart vorstellen, so einen großen Schritt. Vor 2, 5 Jahren konnte es nichts richtig machen, da hast du deine Mitschüler nie gesehen. Manche haben ihre Mitschüler mit Maske kennengelernt und haben die wahrscheinlich vor einem Jahr das erste Mal richtig mit Gesicht gesehen und dann kommen noch solche. Oder wenn man dann so einen Schritt wagen möchte, definitiv noch mal ein ganz, ganz großes Handicap, was die haben, hast du komplett recht.
Und dann haben wir ja auch die Situation, dass man ja dennoch alles, also man möchte es ja genauso haben. Man hat diesen großen Traum, man, man, und das ist ja auch schön. Man möchte ja auch Kindern jetzt nicht sagen, also es gibt bestimmt genügend Eltern, die ihren Kindern das verbieten und sagen, nein, es tut mir leid, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, das kann für dich kein Weg sein. Aber natürlich gibt es auch die Eltern, eure Eltern ja auch, die das unterstützt haben und die selbst, wenn sie selber zurückhaltend sind und das vielleicht auch realistisch sehen, es schaffen nur ein Prozent aller Menschen in den Profifußball, davon leben zu können und vielleicht auch so, dass man ausgesorgt hat am Ende der Karriere, wenn der Körper kaputt ist, das können noch weniger als nur ein Prozent. Das weiß man alles und dennoch lässt man sich dann auf diesen Alltag ein. Man möchte ja auch sein Kind fördern, man sieht, dass das Kind Spaß daran hat oder der Jugendliche dann. Und dann wird man aber, glaube ich, selbst Teil dieses Systems in dem Sinne, dass diese ganz harte Selektion, die es gibt, die betrifft, glaube ich, die Eltern genauso wie die Kinder und führt ja auch zu unheimlich viel Reizpunkten in diesem System. Ich habe mal einen O-Ton mitgebracht von Prof. Dr. Arne Güllich von der rheinland-pfälzischen TU Kaiserslautern Landau. Der war zu Gast in einem Beitrag von Sport Insight über Jugendfußball und der hat mal Studien zitiert, was die Fluktuation jetzt dann in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren angeht, aber das gibt einen ganz guten Eindruck. Ich spiele das mal kurz ein.
Die Nachwuchsleistungszentren oder international dann Centers of Excellence oder Youth Academies haben eine jährliche Auffrischungsrate von 29%. Was heißt das? In jedem Kader sind in einer folgenden Saison 29% der vorigen Saison nicht mehr dabei, sondern werden durch andere ausgetauscht.
Und das wollte ich eben nochmal hier einspielen. Ist sowieso eine empfehlenswerte Doku. Da wird auch nochmal ein bisschen anderer Fokus gelegt als hier im Tribünengespräch, um einfach nur zu verdeutlichen. Bei all dem, was man da auf sich nimmt und was man da an Stress und so weiter hat, ist es dennoch so, dass nach drei Jahren kennt sich keiner mehr im Kader, denn es wurde einmal ausgetauscht. Wie habt ihr denn das wahrgenommen, dass ihr ab einem gewissen Punkt – wahrscheinlich müsst ihr jetzt sagen, wann das so anfängt, vielleicht so 14, 15, 16 – da hat man ja auch dann das Gefühl, okay, ich kann es vielleicht schaffen. Und dann nimmt man das ja noch viel, viel extremer wahr. Es kann auch in jedem Frühjahr Schluss sein. Also Thomas Hitzesberger hat später mal gesagt – und über den haben damals die Leute gesagt, dass der immer herausragend war in seiner Generation – der hat gesagt, dass er in jedem Frühling das Gefühl hatte, jetzt ist für mich Schluss, ich werde aussortiert. Wie habt ihr das erlebt und ab wann hat das begonnen?
Also ich habe – oder bei mir war der Cut ja mit vom, sag ich mal, Dorfein Heide, dann zu U14 nach Dortmund, das war ja ein Riesensprung erstmal. Und für mich ist da ja auch wirklich die Reise losgegangen. Ich hatte dann das große Glück, dass ich in meinem ersten U14-Jahr direkt nach ein paar Monaten einen Vierjahresvertrag angeboten bekommen habe von Dortmund. Das heißt, ich wusste, ok, den habe ich unterschrieben, da war ich schon mal einigermaßen fest im Satte. Erstmal, weil die Leistung auch gut war, war das zu dem Zeitpunkt erstmal alles gut. Aber dieser Wechsel an Spielern, den habe ich schon vor allem auch in der U14 und U15 als relativ extrem wahrgenommen, weil da echt nochmal, worüber wir eben gesprochen haben, so da ist einer körperlich auf einmal in seinem zweiten Jahr dann in der U15 nochmal einen richtigen Schritt gemacht. Und plötzlich war der genauso auf dem Level von allen anderen, konnte aber schon besser Fußball spielen vorher und war dann dabei. Und da sind einige, die vielleicht vorher schon ein bisschen besser waren, körperlich ein bisschen besser waren, sondern rausgefallen zu U16. Und dann habe ich, so wie ich das im Kopf habe, U16, U17, U19, gab es immer einen Kern der Mannschaft, der ist definitiv geblieben. Und weil wir halt bei Dortmund waren, wurde sehr viel dazu gekauft. Also ich hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass da mega viele weggebrochen sind, sondern der Kader wurde einfach größer. Die haben einfach – ist natürlich mal ein, zwei weg oder mal gewechselt. Aber im Prinzip war der Kern der Mannschaft da und zum Beispiel wir hatten das in meinem U16-Jahr. Haben die zwei aus Freiburg geholt, einen aus Frankfurt, einen aus Hamburg, Düsseldorf, Essen. Guck mal, das habe ich sogar aus dem Stil gegriffen. Die auf jeden Fall. Also einmal in Deutschland hier zu U16, 7, 8 Mann dazu gepackt. So und dann aber aus unserem U15-Jahrgang sind dann gar nicht mehr so viele abgehauen. Zu U17 haben sie dann noch einen aus Kaiserslautern geholt und zu U19 haben sie dann auch noch in England und so eingekauft. Also der Kader ist einfach immer größer geworden. Aber jetzt nicht, weil viele weggegangen sind, sondern einfach, weil es schön dazu gekauft wurde. Und die haben gesagt, dass ja, solange wir guter auf dem Platz haben und wir gewinnen, war das ja in Ordnung. Das habe ich so wahrgenommen, dass einfach der Kader immer größer wurde. Das Schwunzeln, wo du sagst, nach der U15 zur U16 habt ihr so viel eingekauft. Wir haben damals als U16 gegen euch gespielt, in der U15. Und da hatten wir als U16 quasi gesagt, oh die U15, wir haben euch gegen euch gewonnen. Und wir haben halt so gesagt, so spielerisch. Und ich glaube, den Verantwortlichen bei Dortmund ist auch aufgefallen, wir müssen vielleicht mal ein bisschen die Schrauben anziehen bei diesem Jahrgang. Wir müssen mal ein bisschen aufstoppen. Und das hat man ja gesehen. Dann haben wir nämlich nochmal gegen die gespielt, als U17 gegen die U16. Und da war das ein ganz anderes Gesicht. Natürlich auch mit denen neu zu gingen. Wenn du natürlich da 7, 8 Spieler quasi deutschlandweit dazuholst, war das ganz lustig anzusehen. Weil da haben wir dann auf jeden Fall an Qualität dazugeholt.
Gleichzeitig ist das ja aber ein Aussortieren durch die Hintertür, Stefan. Wenn der Kader immer größer wird, bedeutet es ja weniger Spielzeit.
Naja, also hier treffen aus meiner Sicht zwei Welten aufeinander. Wir wollen gute Spieler zu sehr guten Spieler zu tollen Spieler zu Profi-Spielern machen. Also wir heißen es in dem Fall jedes NLZ. Jeder Verein hat für sich diese Vision, das so zu machen. Und dann muss ich dem Ganzen aber einen gewissen Ausbildungskarakter überstücken, der immer zählen muss. Aus meiner Sicht. Der muss immer zählen. Für jeden Spieler muss der zählen. Jede Saison. Und wir haben jetzt aber bei euren beiden Ausführungen immer wieder gehört, muss man Spiele gewinnen, muss man besser werden, holt man Spieler dazu. Dann wird es gibt diesen Deutschland-NLZ-Kreislauf. Marius hat jetzt irgendwie zehn Spieler aufgeführt, die aus anderen NLZ nach Dortmund kommen. Und ich verstehe dann einfach nicht, also ich verstehe das schon. Warum? Weil die eben diesen gewinnsportlichen Anreiz diesen permanent hinterherjagen. Aber der Ausbildungskarakter rückt da immer wieder in den Hintergrund. Immer wieder. Und was denkt sich so ein Spieler wie Marius, der dann in der U17 ist, und der sieht dann, ach, beim ersten Training nach der Sommerpause, da sind jetzt schon wieder sechs, sieben neue dabei. Nachher sind sogar welche aus Frankreich dabei und aus Dänemark und aus England. Und aus Kanada. Weiß der Geier woher? Ja, was heißt das denn jetzt für mich? Bin ich jetzt nicht mehr gut genug? Oder warum sind die jetzt hier? Was soll das? Warum spielt das einer aus Freiburg? Okay, der soll dann Freiburg spielen. Also wo ist da der Punkt? Dieses Hin- und Hergeschiebe von Talenten, von einem NLZ zum anderen. Dieses Hopping, das ist für mich nicht immer nachvollziehbar. Vor zwei Wochen war das, war der Hermann Hummels im Blickpunkt Sport in Bayern 3. Und hat dann erzählt, wie er für sich selber, also wie es von einem Sinn ist, bei sich selbst. Früher war das für ihn auch noch völlig normal, so vor 15, 20 Jahren, sowas zu machen, sowas zu verfolgen in seiner Funktion beim FC Bayern. Mittlerweile sagt er halt auch so. Also eigentlich ist das totaler Bullshit. Wenn einer aus dem NLZ in Fürth nach Unterhagen geht und von Unterhagen zu 60, um das 60 zum FC Heidenheim, dann hat er viel NLZ gesehen, da ist er 17 Jahre alt. Was soll das?
Ich glaube, du wolltest anschließen. Ich hätte noch eine kleine Anekdote zu Hermann Hummels. Hermann Hummels war nämlich da ja auch Berater ja. Und der hat auch in der U14 dann bei meinem Vater angerufen und hat mal nachgefragt, wie es aussieht. Und mit Hermann Hummels daßen wir auf der Rückreise als Familie in München im Hotel, nachdem Deutschland Weltmeister geworden ist. Und er hat uns ein paar nette Geschichten über die Rio-Nacht erzählt, der Weltmeister von 2014. Das war sehr interessant. Wollte ich mal nur kurz hier einwerfen zu Hermann Hummels. Ich hätte bei dem anderen, was du gerade gesagt hast, direkt angeschlossen, Stefan, mit dem Hopping quasi. Aus Spielersicht – und das schließt ja vielleicht auch nochmal in die Frage von Max am Anfang mit diesem Aussieben, wie das aus Sicht der Spieler ist. Da kann ich ja nur von mir persönlich sprechen. Ich habe es relativ früh gemerkt, Kicken macht dir Spaß, aber du schießt auch gut Tore. Du bist ganz gut dabei. Du kriegst in den Turnieren, ganz oft, den ich dabei war, bester Torschütze, bester Spieler. Und man ist ja immer, man guckt, okay, man ist ja auch dann, man hat diesen Ehrgeiz, man will besser werden. Und man kommt auch nicht auf ein Niveau Junior im Bundesliga, wenn die Selbstmotivation nicht da ist. Also man will besser werden, man muss es selber wollen. Dann ist das ja bei uns immer so gewesen, wie weit dieser Gedanke, wie weit schafft man es? Also wo ist meine Grenze? Weil wir haben gerade gesagt oder darüber gesprochen, wir haben alle einen gemeinsamen Anfang. Jeder kennt, wie er zum Fußball angeschossen hat. Aber gleichzeitig weiß jeder Einzelne, der mal Fußball gespielt hat, wie er aufgehört hat. Also ich glaube, Max, du bist das beste Beispiel. Das sind ganz, ganz viele, die so schnell merken, das hört im Hobbyverein bei sich im Dorf schon auf. Das macht man so aus Spaß. Dann kennt man vielleicht einen, der zunächst größeren Dorf, zunächst größeren Ort wechselt. Mal gucken, wie weit der kommt. Und so ist das ja bei uns auch gewesen. Und wir hatten das Glück, dass wir immer die waren, die wie gesagt haben, wie hoch kommen wir quasi. Das war ja dann auch eine Herausforderung. Und das war dann schön. Ich habe gerade darüber gesprochen, die Kreisauswahl. Hey, du kriegst eine Einladung zur Kreisauswahl. Man freut sich, man gibt da Folge, dass man hat da Bock zu spielen. Komm zur Landesauswahl und so weiter. Und dann steigt man ja dann immer auf. Man weiß natürlich, dass man wegfallen kann, aber das war für uns ja quasi lange Zeit, das gehört ja dazu. Und es hat uns ja auch nicht betroffen in dem Sinne. Unser Ziel war ja dann, hat man uns mit sechs gefragt, wir wollen Fußballprofis werden, hat man uns mit zwölf gefragt, wir wollen Fußballprofis werden, und dann wurde das ja der Traum verfolgt. Und um das abschließend hier mit dem Hopping, da muss ich zum Beispiel sagen, ich finde das okay, dass das so ist, weil wir dürfen auch nicht, dass wir nicht, dass wir nicht, dass wir nicht vergessen, dass das Geschäft ist einfach so, dass da mit harten Bandagen gespielt wird, untereinander von den Vereinen. Und zum Beispiel, es, also ich verstehe zum Beispiel Dortmund hat den Anspruch, die besten Jugendspieler zu haben, und dadurch dann halt, wie zum Beispiel ein Sancho, wie man sie alle kennen, Brun Larsen, Pullisic, die dann aus der U19 hoch in den Profikader, und die schlagen dann meistens ein wie eine Bombe, beziehungsweise werden dann gut verkauft.
Die aber ja auch alle extern eingekauft wurden, oder?
Alle extern eingekauft, und da hat ja Dortmund auch den Anspruch, zum Beispiel jetzt mit dem Beispiel aus U16, dass sie sich dann die besten Spieler holen, ja. Zum Beispiel aus Kaiserslautern, aus Hamburg. Das gehört dazu, so ist die Realität. So ist es nun mal, wenn man dann Richtung Profi geht, man weiß, es ist dieser 1%, man weiß, dass der Verein die holt, aber dann schließt sich gleichzeitig an, was Stefan sagt, und da bin ich absolut bei dir, Stefan. Dann steht ja immer noch in der Jugend komischerweise der Erfolg im Vordergrund, also Meisterschaften gewinnen, Siege holen, darüber haben wir gesprochen, aber dann finde ich es paradox, genau da muss eigentlich, Naubisch, Stefan gesagt hat, immer noch die Ausbildung im Vordergrund stehen. Also es ist ja okay, wenn er den aus Hamburg holt, wenn man sich dazu entschließt, einen Spieler zu holen, sei es aus dem NLZ von Hamburg, weil er einfach so gut ist, weil Dortmund ihn unbedingt haben will, dann kann er den holen, aber dann muss er ihn auch besser machen wollen und nicht einfach mal so eben holen, das hat mir auch oft das Gefühl, dass Spieler einfach geholt worden sind und diese Ausbildung gar nicht so im Vordergrund stammt, sondern dass dann das Gewinn im Vordergrund steht und nicht den Spieler besser zu. Es spricht ja theoretisch nichts dagegen, wenn diese Spieler holen und Dortmund einen richtigen Plan mit denen hat, die richtig entwickeln will und von diesen sechs wird einer, zwei, richtig entwickelt sich richtig gut und wird Profi. So und da ist oft so der Verschleiß, würde ich es nennen, ziemlich hoch an Spielern, die geholt werden, die auch dann natürlich auf der anderen Seite ab und zu den Verein verlassen. Da schließe ich mich an, Stefan, dass ich dann eher so, also ich finde es gar nicht so schlimm, das ist nun mal so, dass die besten Vereine dann untereinander sich die Spieler holen. Wenn man aber die Verantwortung weiterhin hat auf die Spieler und weiß, man hat gerade jemanden aus Hamburg geholt und wir haben auch Geschichten, da werden Spieler geholt, die sind dann nach drei Monaten wieder weg, weil sie nicht richtig betreut worden sind, die kommen da gefühlt aus 300 Kilometern Entfernung und sind dann wieder weg, dann muss man die schon nehmen und sagen, okay, wir haben quasi einen Auftrag, wir holen diesen jungen Menschen, keinen Spieler, sondern als Mensch, und wir haben den Ausbildungsauftrag und da sind wir, drehen wir uns wieder, kriegen quasi den Kreis geschlossen und sagen, eigentlich macht es Sinn, die Ausbildung wieder in Vordergrund zu stellen, mündige Spieler rauszubringen, mündige Jugendliche, die mit 18 oder mit 17 das Internat oder das NLZ verlassen und einfach besser ausgebildete Spieler, da muss man nicht den Verschleiß so hoch haben. Aber Stefan, du hast ja eigentlich schon die Kernfrage gerade gestellt, das müssen die Vereine und das muss er auf der DFB sich entscheiden. Und diese Diskussion gibt es ja im Moment sehr extrem. Warum haben wir hier plötzlich nicht mehr so viele gute Spieler? Da ist ja wirklich die Frage in der Jugend, ist das Ziel, Meisterschaften zu gewinnen, Pokalsiege zu holen, der Beste zu sein, weil das, was Dortmund ja macht, mit diesen Jugend so gut zu gestalten, mit Spielern von extern, das funktioniert ja auch wirtschaftlich für die. Wir haben ja mit Sancho das erlebt, wie Alex gesagt hat, Pulisic, das hat ja funktioniert. Dortmund hat den Spieler ja nicht ausgebildet. Die haben den als Supertalent gekauft, der hat hier noch ein bisschen in der U19 gespielt und ist dann hoch. Für mich ist das keine Ausbildung. Das ist ein schlauer Transfer, aber das hat nichts mit Ausbildung zu tun. Und da ist in Summa die Frage, will der DFB, dass man wirklich sagt, ok, es ist wichtiger für uns in der Jugend, die Spieler auszubilden? Man soll ja jetzt nicht einfach sagen, wir spielen als C-Sieger egal, wir spielen nicht mehr Meisterschaften, weil es gibt keine Punkte mehr. Das ist ja auch Quatsch, man soll ja auch diese Siegermentalität entwickeln. Aber es ist halt, wie du gesagt hast, und da sehe ich auch so, es geht zu viel in der Jugend um die Meisterschaften, um den Erfolg des Vereins. Und zu wenig, um eigentlich die Spieler auszubilden. Und aus meiner Sicht ist das ein großes Problem, was wir haben.
Ich stelle mir noch eine Gegenfrage, wenn es gestartet ist. Ich verstehe das alles und ich verstehe die wirtschaftlichen Zwänge und dass man damit wahnsinnig viel Geld dann auch verdienen kann. Ich habe dir die Beispiele jetzt gerade schon genannt. Du kannst auch von C. Davis nehmen bei Bayern oder Musiala. Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe. Aber welche Daseinsberechtigung hat dann eine NLZ-Ausbildung unterhalb der U16 bei so einem Verein? Warum gehen die Vereine dann nicht einfach her und sagen, wir lassen sie einfach irgendwo in ihren Vereinen spielen. Die sind dann gut oder halt auch nicht gut genug. Wir kaufen ja so und so ab, wenn die 16, 15, die Grenze ist ja schwimmend, die gefühlt immer noch weiter nach unten, kaufen wir uns ja den Kader so und so zusammen. Es ist völlig wurscht, was da vorher passiert.
Absolut. Das ist der Punkt. Das habe ich ja versucht, so ein bisschen zu beantworten mit diesem Man muss. Es klingt dann immer ein bisschen verweichlicht. Man muss diesen bereit sein oder dieses Bewusstsein haben als Verein. Ich hole halt diese Person, ich hole den nicht als Spieler. Ich finde es auch im Nachhinein nicht schlimm, mit 14 zu Dortmund gewechselt zu sein. Aber es muss dem Verein bewusst sein, wenn wir diesen Schritt holen, den ich mit dem Vierjahresvertrag beispielsweise ausstatten, dass da auch wirklich der Plan ist, diese Vierjahre diesen Spieler weiter auszubilden und nicht mal diesen Vierjahresvertrag geben, um den quasi vier Jahre zu parken. Wo soll er schon hingehen? Er kickt gut oder wir schmeißen ihn nach vier Jahren raus. Da muss dann sein, wenn du die Spieler holst, unter der U16 beispielsweise, warum dann nicht wirklich dieses Projekt diesen Spieler über lange Sicht – ich habe mich entschieden, den zu holen – den auch wirklich auszubilden, auf allen Ebenen. Und dann sind wir wieder bei der Frage, wo sind unsere Spielertypen? Dann geht es genau darum, lasst die Leute sich dann entwickeln. Dann muss aber auch der Plan da sein und nicht einfach so die Jungs holen und dann so mal eben machen lassen. Weil dann ist genau der Punkt, Stefan, den du gesagt hast. Weil dann kann man eigentlich die Frage stellen, warum investiert ihr so viel in die U9 bis U16? Wie steht doch eigentlich da, wenn BVB anklopft bei der U17 von einem Spieler, der kommt? Dann bastelt euch eure U17 und U19 erst dann zurecht oder euer NLZ eigentlich.
Also es gibt ja valide Gründe dafür, das so zu machen. Aber ich sehe das ja jetzt selber hier bei Kindern, die 11, 12 sind, bei meinem Sohn zum Beispiel, der wie gesagt ein bisschen weg vom Schuss ist. Aber das finde ich nicht gut. Das muss ich ganz klar so sagen, wenn die dann Anfang mit 10 Jahren schon so in Richtung Leistungszentrum geschubst zu werden. Und ich sage aber, er lasst ihn doch jetzt hier bis er 12, 13 ist, bis er in der Schule angekommen ist, weiß, was das heißt, nicht drei, vier in der Schule zu haben, sondern zehn. Zweite Fremdsprache, das wisst ihr ja selber alles. Wenn er das alles schon mal mitgemacht hat und weiß, was auf ihn zukommt, dann kann er sich immer noch dafür entscheiden. Das sehe ich halt, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Da verstehe ich auch die NLZ nicht oder viele NLZ nicht, die da wirklich so so viel abgreifen und früh die Kinder schon holen, wo sie doch genau wissen, es wird im Regelfall so und so nicht so funktionieren, dass wir den jetzt hier neun Jahre lang begleiten und er dann einen Profivertrag unterschreibt und Zeit nur in der Regionalliga macht.
Das ist vielleicht noch mal ein guter Punkt, das zu sagen. Auch mit dem Buch, was wir geschrieben haben und mit den Sachen, die wir aufzeigen, wir kritisieren ja gar nicht, dass der Zustand, wie er jetzt ist, dass die Spieler holen, das ist BVB zum Beispiel, das ist ein AG, alles gut, die sind darauf aus, Geld zu verdienen und das ist auch vollkommen okay. Es ist auch vollkommen okay, dass nach wie vor ein Prozent der Spieler Profis werden. Das ist nun mal so. Wir sehen aber zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, wie man die Ausbildung verbessern könnte, du könntest viel besser, also viel mehr Spieler auch dann quasi hervorbringen, also auch dann verkaufen beispielsweise. Wir sagen ja gar nicht, oh Gott, holt die armen Spieler nicht und verkauft sie am besten nicht und so weiter. Wir stellen das alles ja nicht in Frage. Sondern warum verbessert man diese Struktur nicht? Weil dann profitieren alle. Dann profitiert der deutsche Fußball, dann profitiert der DFB, dann profitiert selbst der eigene Verein. Also wenn man mal guckt, wo BVB herkommt seit 2012, die kamen nur darüber, dass auf einmal junge Spieler quasi für geringes Geld eingekauft worden sind, dann unter Kloppen natürlich super aufgeblüht sind. Jeder profitiert davon. Manche Vereine wie Freiburg waren auch darüber angewiesen, lange Jahre sind sie jetzt immer wahrscheinlich noch, weil sie es einfach beibehalten. Gute Jugendarbeit und darüber zu kommen. Also es kann ja alles beibehalten werden, so wie es ist. Es ist auch so, wie es ist, auch okay. Die besten sollen dann auch schließlich nach oben kommen. Soll ja nicht jeder hier die Siegerurkunde bekommen und Profi werden. Nein, ist natürlich nicht so. Aber man könnte das einfach verbessern. Diese Umstände, die wir gerade angesprochen haben, diese Fragen gut beantworten, die du gerade gestellt hast, Stefan. Und dann kommen mehr und bessere Spieler in der 3. Liga an, 2. Liga, 1. Liga. Also da kann man den Schuh ja noch weiter umdrehen, wenn wir dann wieder dabei sind, wo wir sagen, ja, Frankreich zum Beispiel, wenn wir auf DFB-Ebene gucken, Frankreich freut sich, ja. Quasi dieses Sprungbrett, U19 Bundesliga ist ja extrem. Oder England, ja, das merkt man ja mittlerweile. Die Talente kommen rüber, werden hier dann zu Profis, ja, und werden dann, kommen sie entweder zurück in die Premier League, aber die spielen mindestens in der englischen Nationalmannschaft. Die freuen sich darüber. So und wo man dann auch auf lange Sicht denkt, haben wir auch uns geguckt, ja, die deutsche Meisterschaft ist jetzt wieder ganz ETPT-Off-Sky wird übertragen. Und jeder sagt, wow, es ist auch toll, dass so ein Fokus auf der Jugend liegt. Also bei mir war das noch nicht. Bei mir hat es gerade angefangen mit Sport 1 damals. Ist toll, dass sich die breite Bevölkerung viel darüber interessiert. Aber die U19 DFB hat sich nicht für die EM qualifiziert. Das vergisst man dann nebenbei. Da läuft dann schon viel schief, wo jeder sagt, das ist ein Aushängelschild des deutschen Fußballs, hier in Mainz gegen Dortmund zu gucken. Es ist auch. Aber vergesst nicht, dass man da vielleicht auch auf der Gesamtsicht nicht so gut dasteht. Dass man das eigentlich verbessern kann und dass man da auch eigentlich Nachholpotenzial hat. Und nicht dieses, ja das haben wir immer schon so gemacht. Das läuft auch so. Wir sind ja 2014 Weltmeister geworden. Das ist zehn Jahre her bald. Ja, also da muss man vielleicht mal ein bisschen einfach mal Sachen hinterfragen, vielleicht optimieren. Und dann kann man die Sachen, die Strukturen, die ja schon gut da sind, einfach verbessern.
Jetzt explodiert mein Kopf bei dir, weil ich tausend Sachen dazu sagen könnte. Aber das wird jetzt echt den Rahmen sprengen. Aber du sprichst echt eine wichtige Sache. 2014 war halt wieder mal so ein Kipppunkt, wo der DFB, wie er es vorher schon gemacht hat, in der Stunde des großen Erfolgs die Scheuklappen zugemacht hat und dann gar nichts mehr mitbekommen hat. Und es war schon vor der WM 2018 dann in Russland, war schon für Leute, die sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen, ersichtlich, dass es schwierig werden die nächsten Jahre, weil links und rechts sind andere Verbände an Deutschland vorbeigezogen in der Nachwuchsausbildung. Und mein Indikator ist immer, wenn so ein kleines Land wie Belgien oder die Niederlande, wenn die auf einmal wieder ihre U-Mannschaften in die Endturniere bringen und Deutschland nicht, ich glaube, bei U19 ist es glaube ich von den letzten siebenmal, fünfmal gescheitert in der Quali, so eine Drehung, dann läuft etwas ganz gehörig schief, weil diese kleinen Verbände, die haben einfach nicht die Ressourcen, die wir haben, und die haben auch nicht das Geld, das der DFB damals zumindest noch hatte, also müssen sie andere kreative Lösungen finden. Und das können die viel besser als dieser riesen Tanker DFB, und da haben die einfach wahnsinnig geschlafen. Und jetzt gibt es Leute – und jetzt mache ich das fast doch auf – die wollen wirklich was verändern, die wollen reformieren, die wollen Sachen anders machen, auf verschiedensten Ebenen, beim Spieler, beim Trainer, bei der Wettbewerbsstruktur usw. Und dann gibt es aber 21 Landesverbände und 21 Landesverbandfürsten, von denen einige da einfach nicht mitziehen und die diese Dinge dann blockieren. Und das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig großes Problem für uns. Wahnsinnig groß. Deswegen dauert das immer. Wenn überhaupt mal was passiert, dauert es eeeewig, bis das Ingang gesetzt wird, bis es zurückgeht, bis es verabschiedet wird und dann, bis man sich so eindruggelt und nimmt nur das Thema Furninjo jetzt bei den Kleinsten bis zu 10 Jahren. Was das für ein Aufschrei ist, weil die jetzt Furninjo spielen, sollen zusätzlich – also es wird nichts gekillt und was anderes wird dafür platziert – sondern es sind zusätzliche Angebote, wo die – und die sind da. Das hat wirklich Hand und Fuß, das so zu machen, dass man das sowohl den klassischen Fußball mit 6 plus 1 gegen 6 plus 1 spielt auf dem E-Jugend-Feld, mit E-Jugend-Toren, mit dem Torwart usw. und als Paralleluniversum dazu Furninjo einführt, wo die Kinder einfach 70 Ballkontakte haben in einer Viertelstunde und nicht in der Gegend rumstehen und die Gänseblümien aus dem Rasen rausblicken. Ja, das verstehen wir auch.
Was ja Spanien auch schon seit über 20 Jahren macht, glaube ich, Furninjo. Also es ist ja nicht mal neu.
Marius hat das immer ganz toll gesagt.
Marius hat das immer ganz toll gesagt. Dann muss sich jemand überschwungseln, wenn du genauso mit Belgien ansprichst. Der Spruch ist einfach immer, wir haben es mal ein bisschen mathematischer aus. Einfach, wenn man mal wirklich dieses rationale Denken hat. Nehmen wir das Land Belgien, ja, einfach Einwohner zahlenmäßig. Ja, wie kriegen, es kann doch nicht sein, dass man, dass so ein kleines Land, dass man, wie du sagst, einen Stein wirft, über der Grenze ist und auf einmal können die besser kicken als wir. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass hier das Talent weniger ist. Also einfach von dem, was man in die Wiege gelegt bekommt. Oder in Portugal, die sind einwohnerzahltechnisch, ressourcentechnisch genau das, was du sagst. Stefan ist da nicht vorhanden wie in Deutschland. Aber auf einmal, wie du immer so schon sagst, gibt es in Deutschland keinen, keinen Dribbler? Gibt es nur Siala beispielsweise nur einmal? So das glauben wir nicht. Es liegt einfach daran, wie geht man mit den Ressourcen um, die man hat? Und die machen das ganz anders. Und es ist schön, dass Stefan das nämlich gesagt hat, weil ich glaube, 2014 hat man die Früchte ernten können, die man da bis dahin gut gemacht hat. Das sind ja dann die Schweinsteiger gewesen, Lahm, Neuer und wie sie alle heißen, die dann wirklich da auf ihrem Peak vielleicht waren. Aber spätestens da hat man wieder gesagt, okay, jetzt läuft's, wir ändern nichts mehr. So und die sind wirklich die anderen Länder. Gerade wenn man so in den unnationalen Mannschaften guckt, was Zolland macht, Portugal vor allem, Spanien sowieso, Frankreich, was die für Nationalmannschaften da umlaufen haben, die haben nicht aufgeholt, die haben überholt, muss man ganz klar sagen. Das wünschten wir uns eigentlich, dass man da einfach mal wieder ein bisschen die Scheuklappen öffnet und mal einfach Sachen hinterfragt, mal wieder diskutiert. Genau das mit diesen, wie man in den kleinen unteren Jugendmannschaften, ob man da was ändert mit dem Ballkontakt. Es geht ja in die richtige Richtung. Aber das fehlt dann definitiv, dass man da mal guckt, weil also einwohnerzahltechnisch von den Ressourcen, die wir haben, von den Jungs und Mädels, die kicken wollen, ist alles da. Man muss dann vielleicht einfach mal sich ein bisschen was abgucken, mal ein bisschen Ideen sammeln, weil die machen – also ich bin Fan von Portugal, muss man ganz klar sagen, wie die Fußball spielen in Lissabon und so, wenn man das sieht. Die müssen ja irgendwas anders machen dann. Und das mal dann mal… Da hast du jetzt echt ein Fass aufgemacht, Stefan, weil da fällt mir auch immer eine Sache ein. Das war die Außenverteidiger-Diskussion in Deutschland, als Philipp Lahm seine Karriere beendet hat. Und das haben wir ja auch mitbekommen. Da waren wir ja so 16 oder 17, Alter. Und das ist für mich das Paradebeispiel, was in Deutschland manchmal einfach falsch läuft. Da haben alle gesagt, ey, Scheiße, wir haben ja gar keinen Außenverteidiger mehr in diesem Land. Und dann war das wirklich so gefühlt, jeder, der gerade auslaufen konnte, sollte auf einmal Rechtsverteidiger spielen oder Linksverteidiger. Weil wir dann auf einmal gemerkt haben, so eine Kurzschlussreaktion, ey, die haben gerade keinen und wir brauchen jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz schnell wieder ein. Gleiches Thema mit der Stürmer-Diskussion gab es auch ganz lange. Haben alle gesagt, wir haben gar keinen richtigen Stürmer mehr. Keiner der groß ist, der mal ein Kopfballtor machen kann, Weihfess machen kann. Und plötzlich alle, die groß waren, auf einmal Stürmer. Und da habe ich mir gesagt, das könnt ihr nicht ernst meinen, weil ihr jetzt hier aus so einer Kurzschlussreaktion irgendeinen Spieler hervorbringen wollt, den es aber gerade nun mal nicht gibt, weil wir einfach vielleicht gerade drei haben, die richtig gute Sechser sind, aber nun mal kein Außenverteidiger und auch kein Stürmer. Das ist so, da wird immer so ein Schnellschuss, wird so ein Schnellschuss gehandelt, ohne da wirklich groß drüber nachzudenken. Und das funktioniert natürlich nicht. Das ist, Max hat gesagt, die Spanier, ich bin 10 von den Spaniern, die haben immer, die sind jetzt auch beim großen Turnier klar die Nationalmannschaft früh rausgeflogen, aber die haben immer in der Jugend gute, richtig gut ausgebildete Spieler. Da gehen richtig viele immer hoch, da werden viele Profis, weil die einfach ihr System haben, aber ihr System ja immer erneuern. Die verbessern sich ja.
Also wir sind schon sehr tief in einem, eigentlich dachte ich, sehr viel späteren Segment dieser Sendung, aber da will ich jetzt auch drin bleiben, denn das ist ja auch das, was dann immer, das ist quasi die populistische Spitze der Diskussion. Wo sind die Mittelstürmer? Warum sind die so schlecht ausgebildet? Hatte Mehmet Scholl recht, als er gesagt hat, jeder Nachwuchsleistungszentrum Spieler kann 4-3-3 und alle taktischen Systeme rückwärts furzen, aber kann nicht mehr ordentlich tribünn und so weiter. Das ist quasi die Speerspitze der Diskussion, die wir haben. Und wenn ich jetzt aber hier schon drei Experten sitzen habe, würde ich erstmal die Frage stellen, was machen denn andere Länder anders? Vielleicht, Stefan, kannst du mal vorlegen, weil wir jetzt schon öfter gesagt haben, man müsste mal Showklappen öffnen, andere Dinge angucken. Was sind denn da die Unterschiede zum Beispiel?
Also, nehmen wir mal Frankreich. So gefühlt jeder 17- 18-Jährige, der jetzt bei irgendeiner Mannschaft irgendwo in Europa spielt. Wenn ich danach gucke, habe ich bei der Hälfte sehe ich der Nationalität Frankreich. Oh, schon wieder ein Franzose. Komisch. Frankreich war ja auch das Vorbild für Deutschland mit Claire Fontaine. Also, die haben diese zentrale Ausbildungsstelle für die Nationalmannschaft geschaffen. Ich glaube, 1984 ging es los und so wirklich zur Heim-WM98 dann damals, haben die das sehr groß aufgezogen, das Ding. Und da werden die Spieler zum Beispiel aus ihren Klubs, ab der U14 war das, immer zusammengezogen, unter der Woche. Und da werden die in dieser zentralen Einrichtung in der Nähe von Paris, ist das, werden die dann unter der Woche ausgebildet zusammen. Die besten Spieler des Landes. Und am Wochenende gehen die wieder nach Hause in ihre Klubs und spielen da ganz normal in ihren Ligen. Ganz normales Turnierwochenende, Spielwochenende. Ausbildungskonzept natürlich schon etwas anders und gehobener, als es in Deutschland ist. Und dann kommt natürlich auch noch dazu, das darf man nicht vergessen, diese Spieler, die kommen jetzt mittlerweile oft genug aus sozialen Verhältnissen, die wir in Deutschland in der Regel so stark gar nicht kennen. Beim WM-Finale jetzt vor ein paar Monaten waren am Schluss, wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht, bis auf den Torhüter waren nur noch dunkelhäutige Spieler bei den Franzosen auf dem Platz, also Spieler mit Migrationshintergrund und viele von denen kommen aus diesen sozialen Brennpunkten, wie man ja so schön sagt. Die haben eine andere Sozialisation als hier in Deutschland. Also diese, die haben diesen noch mehr diesen Drang, sich durchsetzen zu müssen. Genau, dann schaffen die das eher nicht über die Schule, sondern die müssen sich im Käfig behaupten und dann kommen die da weiter. Und das ist so eine Mischung in Frankreich. Und dann haben die natürlich auch wahnsinnig viel. Allein Paris hat, glaube ich, 12 Millionen Einwohner mit den ganzen Peripherie. Das ist einfach ein Schmelz-Tegel an wahnsinnig viel Fußballtalent, wie es in Europa so vergleichsweise eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt. England zum Beispiel hat immer nach Deutschland geguckt. Was machen die Deutschen? Wie machen die das? Warum können die uns 2010 4 zu 1 im Achtelfinale schlagen? Mit dem Thomas Müller, der zwei Tore macht mit irgendwelchen Jugendspielern, die keinen Mensch kennt. Damals. Und dann haben die aber angefangen. Die hatten ja immer dieses Premier League Problem. Also wahnsinnig viele Spieler. Nach Osmann haben wir eingekauft für die beste Liga der Welt. Absolut spektakulär, aber englische Spieler interessiert mich nicht. Wohl ich mir lieber noch einen Franzosen, einen Deutschen, einen Italiener und so weiter. Und dann haben die aber angefangen, die FA, die Vereine zu verpflichten, Abgaben zu machen. Für die FA, für die Ausbildung von Spielern und von Trainern. Das ist ganz wichtig in dem Zusammenhang. Aus meiner Sicht zumindest. Weil in England war es so, dass die Trainerscheine wahnsinnig viel Zeit beansprucht haben und wahnsinnig teuer waren. Und das haben die einfach nach unten gedrückt. Unter anderem durch die Gelder aus der Premier League. Also aus diesem riesen Milliardengeschäft haben die sich da ein bisschen Geld abgezogen und haben alle Strukturen überdacht und neu aufgestellt. Und wie von Geisterhand kommt, seit gefühlt fünf, sechs, sieben Jahren, gibt es auf einmal englische Spieler, die wirklich richtige Toptalente sind. Nicht nur gut genug für die zweite Liga, oder für die Premiership-Baddies, sondern wirklich für die Premier League. Ihr habt das vorhin schon gesagt, Jaden Central. Das sind alles Produkte aus diesem neuen englischen Weg. Die gab es früher einfach nicht. Die waren nicht da. Spanien ist aus meiner Sicht sehr speziell, weil die viele Sachen auch schon immer anders machen. Allein schon die Herangehensweise, wie die Trainer mit den Spielern arbeiten, was die für Strukturen da haben, dass die solche Enklaven immer noch haben, wie Athletic Bilbao oder Real Sociedad, wo es einfach eine andere Kultur herrscht in diesem ganzen Verein, die sich abkapseln, also die völlig gegen diese ganze Fußball-Globalisierung dem Ganzen entgegentreten sozusagen und sagen, ja hier, 100 Kilometer, einfach mal als Zahl genannt, ich weiß nicht, ob es 100 sind, vielleicht sind es auch nur 50 oder 150 Kilometer umkreist, das ist unser Bereich, da kommen unsere Spieler her, Ende der Geschichte. Es gibt verschiedenste Ansätze, und das hat der DFB ja auch versucht, aufzugreifen, die haben ihre Trainer nach England geschickt, nach Spanien geschickt, nach Portugal, nach Belgien, nach Holland, nach Kroatien, ganz wichtig, um zu gucken, wie funktionieren diese Ausbildungskonzepte in diesen Ländern und dann das Beste zusammenzutragen, zu bündeln und dann hier wieder neue Konzepte draus zu stricken. Das ist auch ein richtiger Ansatz aus meiner Sicht, aber da wiederhole ich mich jetzt, es dauert halt ehlendig lang, bis es dann umgesetzt wird. Das ist vielleicht auch eine Mentalitätsfrage, das ist nicht Föderalismus, Deutschland, Föderalismus, Frage mit diesen ganzen Landesverbänden, dass man da schwieriger auf einen Trichter kommt, aber es ist aus meiner Sicht auch echt eine Mentalitätsfrage, weil wir in Deutschland müssen immer irgendwas eine Idee haben, dann wird was beschlossen, dann wird ein Gesetz gemacht, dann wird es vielleicht irgendwann umgesetzt. Wenn der Niederländer irgendwas, da ist eine Straße, geht geradeaus und dann geht die nach links. Und der Niederländer läuft aber diagonal über diese Wiese drüber. Und wenn er dann sieht, dass das funktioniert, dann sagt er danach, lass uns doch eine Straße diagonal drüber machen, ist doch viel einfacher für alle. Wir laufen nicht geradeaus und nach links. Und dieses Denken fehlt bei uns. Und das macht es dann jetzt auch gerade für die Reformen mit dem DFB aus meiner Sicht wahnsinnig schwierig, das alles umzusetzen. Und diese guten Sachen, die man von draußen holt, wenn man jetzt schon ein bisschen abgehängt ist, und das ist definitiv der Fall, jetzt muss Deutschland halt wieder aufholen. Aber das dauert zu lang.
Und vielleicht war da auch der WM-Erfolg 2014 und das Narrativ, was darum gestickt wurde, kontraproduktiv. Denn wir alle wissen, wie es zu diesem WM-Titel kam. Also zum einen mit vier Innenverteidigern zum Beispiel in der Abwehrkette. Könnte man ja auch mal hinterfragen. Und es war halt einfach, es gehört sau viel Glück zu einem Turniererfolg. Gegen Algerien kannst du rausgehen, gegen Frankreich hast du im Grunde nur eine Chance nach Ecke. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Brasilien-Ausreißer, der aber auch von brasilianischer Seite her eigentlich relativ gut begründbar ist, warum die da so völlig überrollt wurden. Und dann Finale, was du eigentlich nicht gewinnen darfst. Also das war jetzt, ich habe es jetzt ein bisschen zu negativ gemacht, aber so kann man auf diese WM auch blicken. Und wir haben halt logischerweise, weil es gewonnen wurde und weil ja auch die Geschichten der Sieger schön sind, wurde es eben so gedreht, dass es eben nicht nur ein Erfolg jetzt im Jetzt ist, sondern ein Erfolg der Vergangenheit. Das ist eben das Ergebnis dieser Entwicklung war. Und da kann man sagen, komplett falsch ist das natürlich nicht, denn man muss sich nur EM 2000-Spiele angucken oder auch noch WM 2002 und so weiter umzusehen, was sich im technischen und taktischen verbessert hat im Fußball. Der deutsche Fußball in den 90ern war nicht zum Anschauen. Es war nicht innovativ. Die Spieler waren nicht gut geschult. Und Berti Vogts versucht irgendwie noch vor der WM 98, die Viererkette einzuführen, die WM 98, die Viererkette einzuführen, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98. Ich habe ein Zitat von einem Scout des FC Bayern, der gesagt hat – ich sage jetzt einfach mal nicht in welchem Jahr, aber solange ist es nicht her – der hat gesagt, ich kenne jeden Nationalspieler bis runter zu U15, da ist kein einziger Spieler mit dabei, der mal beim FC Bayern landen wird. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Also spricht die Expertinnen und Experten, die sehen das schon lange, und ihr habt das ja auch, dadurch, dass ihr involviert war, ja auch von innen gesehen. Was sind eure Gedanken dazu, wenn eben der Stefan uns hier ja sehr schön erklärt, was andere Nationen anders machen, und ihr ja auch quasi hier so ein bisschen in der Mission unterwegs seid. Wir müssen mal den Nachwuchsfußball neu überdenken.
Ja, also erstmal ist natürlich für uns aus der Perspektive des Spielers, haben wir natürlich jetzt aktiv erst seit ein, zwei, drei Jahren drauf geguckt, was ist da passiert. Als man selber, als wir selber teil dabei waren und uns mal mit den Besten da auch gemessen haben, finde ich, bekommt man das gar nicht mit so richtig. Sind wir jetzt gerade gut insgesamt oder sind wir eher schlecht oder auf was für einem Leistungsniveau befinden wir uns hier gerade? Das ist natürlich als Aktiver ganz, ganz schwierig überhaupt zu bewerten. Jetzt so im Nachhinein, muss ich sagen, und das hat Stefan ja wirklich sehr gut erklärt, was andere Länder gemacht haben oder was da für Innovationen bei denen gab, habe ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, was Stefan gerade schon mehrmals angesprochen hat, eine Umsetzung von einer Idee und es gibt ja sicherlich Ideen in diesem Land, ist ja nicht so, dass wir komplett planlos werden, aber dass eine Umsetzung immer so lange und so träge ist, dass wenn wir was beschlossen haben und das dann so machen, die anderen schon wieder drei gute Ideen hatten, aber die alle schon umgesetzt haben und dann schon wieder einen Schritt weiter weg sind und es wäre halt einfach mal, es gibt ja auch genug kompetente Leute in diesem Land fußballerisch, die sicherlich viel wissen und auch eine gute Idee haben, wie man das machen könnte. Man müsste es halt nur dann mal auf die Straße bringen und das relativ zügig und relativ schnell, damit wir da weiter dran bleiben, weil ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaube, es war Rudi Völler, der jetzt auch letztens noch mal gesagt hat, gerade haben wir noch mit Kai Havertz und so, haben wir noch ein paar Spieler, die wirklich gut sind, aber in fünf, sechs, sieben Jahren, wie du das auch schon angedeutet hast, Max, da haben wir ein richtiges Spielerproblem und dann wird es ganz problematisch und dann sind wir nicht nur ein Stück hinterher, sondern ganz weit hinterher. Um das dann wieder alles aufzuholen, das ist dann noch noch ein größerer Prozess und noch ein größerer Schritt. Deswegen müsste, wenn es jetzt Ideen gibt und die gibt es ja mit Sicherheit, das einfach mal gemacht werden. Das müsste einfach dann mal umgesetzt werden, weil sonst können wir uns ja hier alle in einem Kreis reden und sagen, ja es wäre ja schön, wenn wir das so hätten und guck mal, die Sparer machen es so und die Engländer machen es so und wir sagen alle, ja, ist es richtig oder passiert halt nichts. Und wenn man nichts ändert, kann man nicht erwarten, dass es besser wird. Wenn man immer das Gleiche macht, kann man nicht erwarten, dass es besser wird und Stillstand ist nun mal auch Rückschritt und das ist ja gerade so ein bisschen der Fall. Ich würde auch alles unterschreiben, was Stefan und Marius jetzt vor allem gesagt haben. Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen raus seit ein paar Jahren, aber da kann man so ein bisschen überspitzt sagen, genau das war es, was Stefan sagt. Tolle Ideen, genau das ist der Punkt, wie Leute, dass man schaut, was andere Länder machen. Viel mitbekomme man davon nicht, dass Deutschland rübergeguckt hat mal, also was die Trainer zum Beispiel angeht und so weiter, ja. Da ist einfach zum einen das Umsetzen. Ein Punkt, den ich noch anbringen möchte, ist zum Beispiel immer noch, dass man dann, ich glaube, es ist dieses einfache Denken und das bequeme Denken, dass man sagt, wenn man erfolgreich ist, dann ist man gleichzeitig auch gut, so nach dem Motto. Also das habe ich ja versucht, mit diesen Meisterschaften zum Beispiel zu sagen. Ja, also es ist toll, dass das professionell wird. Ich gönne jedem Jugendspieler dieses, hatten wir auch, Mannschaftsbus zu sitzen, Fans laufen hinterher und das Stadion füllt sich. Man spielt im Stadion vor 33.000, habe ich es ja geschafft, mit meinen Jungs am Meister zu werden. Das ist toll, dass das so auch diese Struktur mittlerweile hat, aber irgendwie hat das für unsere, vor allem auch für meine Sicht, so ein bisschen dieses Gewinnkost ist, was es wolle, so nach dem Motto. Und ich erinnere mich, ich habe mal ein kurzes Interviewausschnitt gesehen von von Lagelsmann. Das fand ich ganz interessant, der hat nämlich gesagt immer, warum muss man sagen, Ausbildung ist nicht gleich erfolgreich. Wenn ich Leute gut ausbilde, wenn ich jeden besser mache, wenn ich das Team besser mache, dann inkludiere ich das Erfolgreichsein eigentlich mit ein. Und bei uns ist so ein bisschen das Gefühl gewesen, ja, okay, wir haben jetzt nicht drei Spieler rausgebracht, wir haben jetzt nicht nur Profis genommen, wir sind Deutscher Meister geworden. Ja, also das ist so oft dieses Gefühl, ja, also mal ganz überspitzt wieder zu sagen, ich wäre lieber kein Deutscher Meister, wenn ich jetzt Profi wäre. Also wir sind jetzt auch Junioren, Deutsche Meister, aber schlichtweg davon kaufen, dass wir jetzt davon Profis gewonnen sind, ist jetzt nicht der Fall. Ja und dass man da vielleicht sagt, ja, diese Meisterschaften sind auch toll, auch wie sie zelebriert werden, aber sie müssten aus dem, von der Ausbildungseite kommen, dass wirklich toller Fußball gespielt wird, dass dann wirklich die Mannschaften, die dann wirklich die besten sind, wo ich da jedes Mal habe ich gesagt, okay, jetzt spielen gerade die zwei besten Mannschaften Deutschlands gegeneinander, aber DFB ist nicht bei der EM dabei. Also wo ich mir dann auch denke, so diese, es ist einfach zu sagen, ja, okay, jetzt haben wir einen deutschen Meister gefunden, das müssen die Top-Talente sein, das muss der beste Fußball sein, den Deutschland gerade spielt, das ist ein bisschen einfach gedacht finden, weil dann kann man einfach sagen, ja, schön, ihr habt die besten Deutschlands gefunden, aber im Vergleich zu den anderen laufen die immer noch gerade davon. Und das ist immer, dass man vielleicht sagt, ja, warum spielt man Fußball, ja, wer gewinnt, hat Recht, sagt man so oft. Das stimmt, ja, aber ich sage mal so, was wollte ich gerade sagen, in der Jugend auch, dass man diesen Sieges will, das wird ja oft, man kann schnell die Keune schwingen und sagen, ja, ihr habt so Wunschdenken und alle machen Luftbläschen und was weiß ich und alle klatschen sich in die Hände. Das ist ja nicht der Fall, den wir ansprechen wollen. Also es geht auch darum, zum Beispiel in unserem Fall, ich kenne einige Spieler, die dann bei Gladbach waren, zum Beispiel, die auch aussortiert worden sind, dann bei Oberhausen gespielt haben, die dann Profis geworden sind. Ja, das ist dann erfolgreich, wenn Leute den Sprung in den Profibereich schaffen und nicht, dass man sich auf die Fahne sagt, hier wir sind jetzt drei Mal im Finale gewesen. Ja, es kommt immer darauf an, da hat zum Beispiel, nehmen wir jetzt mal als Beispiel Gladbach, wenn die Sechster geworden sind und es geschafft haben, fünf Spieler rauszubringen, irgendwie Zweite Liga, Dritte Liga oder auch Erste in die eigene Mannschaft, die haben eine erfolgreiche Saison gespielt, als die Mannschaft die Deutsche Meister geworden ist, wenn sie weniger Spieler rausbringen. Das ist immer noch der Sinn einer Jugendabteilung, dass man Spieler rausbringt, dass man den Verein besser macht, dass man den DFB besser macht mit jungen Talenten. Genau wie Stefan gesagt hat, mit der Premier League. Wenn die sich wundern, da spielt kein Englander mehr. Mittlerweile kommen die alle hinterher, die jungen Spieler. Es kommen immer mehr Engländer auch in die Premier League, die da durchkommen. Bellingham zum Beispiel. Er wird definitiv Premier League-reif sein. Guck mal, bei der Invexer. Aber die haben mittlerweile die Spielerqualität da. Und das ist irgendwie ein bisschen paradox. Dieses Urgesetz, das man wirklich Ideen umsetzt, die auch da mal ein bisschen was ändern. Und gleichzeitig dieses, ja, dieses, wie ich gerade sagte, dieses Denken, Erfolg gibt Recht. Was ja stimmt, aber ein bisschen differenziert. Ein bisschen über den Tellerrand drüber gucken, wo dieser Erfolg herkommt. Also nur weil ich jetzt drei Spieler einkaufe, die zum Beispiel schon Bundesliga-reif sind, aus Frankreich, aus England. Klar wirst du dann Deutscher Meister. Ja, aber die werden dann halt Profis, aber der Rest halt nicht. Das ist dann, finde ich, finden wir ein bisschen zu einfach gedacht. Ja, auch einfach nicht erfolgreich gedacht. Wie Stefan gesagt hat, kann man ja auch eigentlich wirklich sagen, fangen wir alle zusammen ab der U17 an, kaufen uns die Leute zusammen, bringen die raus. Das ist nicht der Sinn einer Jugendarbeit.
Das sollte es auf jeden Fall nicht sein. Aber ich muss jetzt einfach aufgreifen, Max, du, eine Sache ist wirklich wichtig, glaube ich, auch wenn man dieses, so ein bisschen diese, man vernebelt sich selbst die Sicht auf die Dinge begreifen will. Dieser 2014er WM-Titel, der wird überall bis heute, das ist jetzt neun Jahre her, wird der verkauft als der große NLZ-Titel Deutschlands. Das ist die Generation, die aus dem NLZ kommt. Das ist unsere, das ist die Frucht unserer Ideen. Wenn man aber mal genau hinschaut, dann sind da bei der, beim, beim, bei der Final, beim Final Line-up, also bei der Aufstellung der deutschen Mannschaft im Finale, sind zwei Spieler dabei, die ich nach meiner Definition NLZ-Spieler nennen würde. Thomas Müller und Toni Kroos bei der Final-Aufstellung. Dann ist da der Klose dabei, den kann man rausrechnen. Der war damals schon, weiß nicht, 34 oder sowas. So, dann Neuer im Tor. Der hat seinen Bundesliga-Debüt, ich glaube 2006, spätestens 2007 gegeben. Schweini, Jahrgang 84, Lahm, Jahrgang 84. Das sind Spieler, die haben 2002, 2003 in der Bundesliga gespielt. Die haben dieses NLZ, diese normale NLZ-Ausbildung, haben die gar nicht genossen, da waren die schon zu alt. Und dann sind die ganzen 2009er Europa U21-Europameister dabei. Kedira war verletzt im Finale, der gehört aber eigentlich auch dazu. Hummels, Rüvedes, Boateng, Gürcérum Boateng, genau. Diese vier und die sind gerade so an der Schwelle. Sami Kedira hat schon 2005 beim VfB in der Bundesliga gespielt. Offiziellerweise geht dieses NLZ-Denken 2000-2001 los, so ungefähr. Die ersten zwei, drei Jahre waren aber faktisch ganz normale Ausbildungen, wie es schon die 10, 15, 20 Jahre davor war. Das hieß nur anders, das ist dann auf einmal NLZ. Aber die Inhalte waren immer noch dieselben. So richtig los ging es mit NLZ-Inhalten und Fußball erst ab 2004. Und da waren diese Spieler die 16, 17, also das sind keine klassischen NLZ-Spieler, das wird nur immer gerne so erzählt. Aber das gehört zu diesem Gesamtbild dazu. Ja, jetzt sind wir 2014 Weltmeister, das sind unsere Spieler, das ist unser NLZ-Jahrgang, das stimmt nur zur Hälfte, wenn überhaupt.
Ja, sehr guter und wichtiger Punkt. Und gleichzeitig ist ja auch das, was Marius und Alex gesagt haben, das ist ja so logisch, dass es kracht. Niemand würde widersprechen, dass die Erfolgsmessung schief läuft, dass der Erfolg nicht gemessen werden kann in Juniorenmeistertiteln, sondern dass der Erfolg wessen werden müsste in wie viele Spieler haben wir in den Profifußball bekommen. Vielleicht auch, ganz verrückter Gedanke, wie viele Spieler bei uns haben eine berufliche Ausbildung direkt im Anschluss an ihre gescheiterte Profifußballkarriere angefangen. Vielleicht sollte das ja auch nochmal mitgemessen werden, dass man eben den Plan A im Blick behält und nicht nur den fälschlichen Plan B verfolgt. Warum ist das so? Stefan, kannst du mir das erklären? Müssen wir da jetzt vielleicht über die Trainer sprechen? Das ist noch so ein Thema, über das haben wir uns so ein bisschen herumgewunden. Dabei spielen die ja eine ganz entscheidende Rolle zum Beispiel auch. Oder würdest du da jetzt erstmal woanders ansetzen, wenn es um diese Messung des Erfolgs geht?
Naja, also was ist die konkrete Frage jetzt?
Naja, es ist doch eigentlich völlig logisch, den Erfolg einer Jugendarbeit nicht daran zu messen, habe ich einen Titel gewonnen, sondern fünf Jahre später zu gucken auf das Werk eines Trainers und dann zu sagen, okay, wie viele deine Spieler sind im Profifußball gelandet, wie viele haben eine schulische Ausbildung abgeschlossen und so weiter. Warum wird das nicht gemacht?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Es wird ja teilweise gemacht. Es gibt ja immer mal wieder Statistiken, die dann europaweit erhoben werden, wie viele Nachwuchsspieler von Verein A, B und C spielen jetzt Profifußball. Da wäre zum Beispiel der VfB Stuttgart jedes Jahr Deutscher Meister, weil es gefühlt, ich weiß die genaue Zahl jetzt nicht mehr, aber die haben, glaube ich, über 50 Spieler in den ersten drei Ligen in Deutschland, die irgendwann mindestens, glaube ich, zwei Jahre ist, das ist der Parameter. Die müssen zwei Jahre zwischen der U15, U19 oder drei Jahre in diesem Verein gespielt haben. So und dann guckt man, okay, wer ist da jetzt vorne mit dabei und da gibt es in den unter den besten 30 Clubs Europas gibt es immer nur zwei oder drei deutsche Mannschaften, da ist der VfB dabei, mittlerweile vermutlich Schalke und dann noch sowas wie Hertha, ich habe es jetzt leider nicht mehr. Aber das ist, es gibt schon so ein paar, also so eine Kennzeichnungspflicht, wenn man das so nennen mag, aber du sprichst halt einen wichtigen Punkt an, die Dropout-Quote allein aus dem NLZ raus, ist ja schon so exorbitant hoch, so Systemimmanent, dass man einfach zwingend schauen muss, dass man diese Spieler nicht nur als Spieler ausbildet, sondern auch als Menschen und Persönlichkeiten. Und das fällt halt immer wieder, erfahrungsgemäß fällt das immer wieder unter den Tisch. Und da gibt es verschiedenste Faktoren dafür. Aus meiner Sicht der größte oder einer der größten ist definitiv der Trainer. Weil je älter die Spieler sind, je höher die Jahrgänge sind ab der U15, wenn es in diese Leistungsklassen geht, dann ist es auch so, dass die Trainer eine entsprechende Motivation, zusätzliche Motivation noch haben. Die gucken dann, können die vielleicht von der U16 in die U17 aufsteigen, können die von der U17 in die U19 aufsteigen. Ach, guck mal den Kohfeldt an in Bremen, der war mal U19-Trainer, dann war er U23-Trainer, zack, Bundesliga, das kann ich doch auch. Und dann wird es schwierig, weil da treffen so viele Interessenfelder aufeinander, dass die dann einfach, nicht einfach, aber dass die am Schluss im Zweifel, vielleicht sind die festangestellt und haben eine Familie zu Hause, die sie ernähren müssen und müssen dann schauen, dass sie in diesem Job bleiben. Und wenn dann ihr Vorgesetzter sagt, ja so und so musst du das jetzt machen, dann sagen die natürlich im Zweifel eher, ja genau, so machen wir das jetzt. So wie du das sagst, so machen wir das. Ihr hättet aber vielleicht für sich selber eine ganz andere Idee, das zu machen. Es wird quasi den Leuten nach dem Mund geredet und dann, dann fangen die Probleme an bzw. dann ist man schon mitten drin und dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Also es sind zu viele, da zern zu viele Leute an zu vielen Interessen, die sie entweder selber verfolgen oder die, die, die in aufoktoriiert werden, dass das am Schluss, und das ist der zentrale Punkt, es muss immer um den Spieler gehen. Es muss immer um den Spieler gehen und das wird, je höher die oder je älter die Spieler werden, je höhere Spielklassen sind, wird es immer weniger aus meiner Sicht, weil es dann, weil da zu viel dran hängt und dann kommt Berater und dann kommt die Eltern und dann kommen Freunde und dann kommt, gibt es Probleme in der Schule und so weiter. Und deswegen sollte man, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, wirklich gucken, was ist jetzt wirklich mein Plan A und was ist vielleicht noch mein Plan B.
Das was du gerade gesagt hast, Stefan, das ist eigentlich ja leider die klassische Definition für die perfekte eines Zielkonfliktes, was da in der Jugend passiert. Ein Trainer, der auch aufsteigen will, der aber eigentlich als Aufgabe hat, die Spieler seine Jungs zu verbessern. So und wenn ich natürlich an einem Seil ziehe und ziehe die beiden in die falsche Richtung, dann ist das ganz schwierig und das ist leider ist das ein perfekter Zielkonflikt, der da eigentlich herrscht. Weil der Aufgabe des Jugendtrainers, und das ist ja, müsste man ja auch mal sagen, ist ein sehr schwieriger Job, ein guter Jugendtrainer zu sein. Das ist extrem schwierig. Du musst menschlich top sein, du musst mit den Jungs umgehen können, du sollst den Fach, du sollst dem Wissen vermitteln. Das ist eine außergewöhnliche Basics, du solltest aber trotzdem deren Freiraum lassen, das ist ja extrem schwierig, das gut umzusetzen. Aber das ist nun mal leider echt ein Problem, dass da viele Trainer auch ambitioniert sind, wie du es gesagt hast, mit dem Gedanken, ach guck mal, für mich selber könnte ich ja mit einer Meisterschaft auch mal ins Rampenlicht gerückt werden oder mit sonstigen Erfolgen, um dann auch auf die nächste Stufe zu kommen. Und dann sind die Spieler und die Ausbildung der Spieler leider nicht mehr Priorität Nummer eins, was sie aber nun mal sein sollten.
Und warum, glaubt ihr, gibt es so viele Trainer, die gerade in den U19-Mannschaften, U23-Mannschaften, wenn es sie noch gibt, eben letztlich immer das Ziel Profi-Fußball haben? Ist das öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit? Geht es da vielleicht auch um Geld? Denn man kann ja auch als Jugendtrainer sich einen Ruf verarbeiten. Es dauert halt nur sehr viel länger, weil ja logischerweise erst über die Jahre hinweg dann sichtbar wird. Ach guck mal, immer dieser Trainer, also Norbert Elgert ist da ja ein super Beispiel, natürlich auch das Beispiel in Deutschland, aber da gibt es ja auch noch andere. Und wir hatten hier zum Beispiel Nico Willig schon häufiger vom VfB Stuttgart, der auch, also sowohl Elgert als auch Willig haben beide bewusst die Entscheidung getroffen, im Jugendbereich zu bleiben. Willig war mal Interimstrainer, lief auch nicht so gut, also er wäre jetzt nicht Cheftrainer geworden. Er hat aber auch sehr glaubhaft von Anfang an schon gesagt, möchte ich gar nicht, ich möchte weiter bei der U19 bleiben, ich möchte einzelne Spieler in den Profifußball bekommen. Also liegt es dann vielleicht auch daran, dass die zu schlecht bezahlt werden und dass die eben sehen, sie stehen ja quasi genauso wie die Spieler an der Schwelle zu richtig viel Geld. Also von Juniorenbereich bis hin zu Profifußball, da ist der große Unterschied. Da sind quasi die großen Töpfe und die viel, viel kleineren Töpfe. Was denkt ihr, Marius und Alex?
Auf jeden Fall ist das der Punkt. Also Stefan, du hast das super gesagt, dieser Interessenkonfig. Genau da ist er nämlich. Und lustigerweise war der erste Gedanke immer bei mir, den ich mir jetzt, wo ich quasi abgeschlossen habe, mal so ein bisschen von außen auf dieses Konstrukt aufgucke, habe ich mir immer die Frage gestellt. Eigentlich muss den Verein bewusst sein, dass der U17-Posten und der U19-Posten der wichtigste Posten ist. Also normalerweise muss da, da muss alles hieb- und stichfest passen eigentlich. Und es ist ja vollkommen okay und das ist auch menschlich, dass wir ganz viel erlebt haben, auch Jugendtrainer, die ihre eigene Karriere haben wollen. Ja, also die, die das, wenn man es mal so sagen will, Sprungbrett sehen. Ja, genau das, wenn ich hier Erfolgefeier an U19, irgendwann kommt der, mache ich meine Karriere auch als Trainer. So ein Wunschdenken, glaube ich, wäre ein Trainer, der sich quasi nichts mehr beweisen muss. Ja, also der, der wirklich das Ziel hat, er, oder er profiliert sich darüber, wie seine Spieler den Anschluss an die, an die, an die Profi-Abteilung schaffen. Und was so am nächsten drankommt, das ist aber meine persönliche Meinung zum Beispiel, wo ich gesehen habe, dass so von auch auf Plätzen, wo ich gegen die gespielt habe, wo das am nächsten rankommt, waren das vor allem bei Real Madrid, ehemalige Profis beispielsweise, das übernommen hatten, die dann den Trainerweg eingegangen sind, wo man auch sagt, die haben sich dann auf die, auf die Trainerbank gesessen, ich bin immer Fan von Trainern, die ein bisschen beobachten, die dann wirklich konstruktive Inputs im Spiel geben und nicht einfach nur brüllen und am besten den Joystick hinten am Platz haben und alle Spieler lenken wollen. Und solche Leute, die müssen eigentlich niemandem was beweisen, die kommen dann auch nicht, die hatten die große Karriere, vielleicht wollen dann ein paar natürlich ihre eigene Karriere pushen, aber das wäre eigentlich das beste Denken, wo man sagt, da ist keiner dabei, der seine eigene Karriere, der auch vielleicht nicht, dass klar spielt Geld noch, da muss man einfach ehrlich sein, da muss man nicht alles schönreden, die vielleicht auch Geld im Blick haben, die natürlich dann einen Vertrag wittern und was natürlich, da kommen so viele Sachen rein, was wir auch hatten mit, oft kommt der Spruch, ja der muss guter Trainer sein, aber auch ein super Sozialpädagoge. Haben wir jetzt persönlich, das ist ja auch im Buch, vielleicht nicht ganz so gut mitbekommen, wir haben auch andere Fälle mitbekommen, wo das nicht so ganz ist, wo man sagt, das ist pädagogisch super, aber so einen braucht man da eigentlich. Und jetzt habe ich viel erzählt und man merkt, da sind viele Punkte, die ein sehr guter 19-Trainer erfüllen muss oder ein Jugendtrainer, sowohl sich selber ein bisschen zurückstellen, dass es um den Spieler geht, dass es darum geht, sie rauszubringen und sich nicht vielleicht um sich selber rauszubringen, dass man auch Zwischenmenschliches gut handelt, neben dem Platz, wie Stefan der Toll gesagt hat, es geht um den Spieler. Es gibt auch mal Probleme neben dem Platz, die man handeln muss, dass man die auf Position hält, es ist immer noch Pubertät, es ist immer noch Jugend, dass man die quasi dann nicht nur als Maschinen sieht, dass man sie taktisch weiterführt. In Deutschland wundert man sich, wo sind die Deutschen mit ihren Charakterzügen, wo ist so ein Schweinsteiger, wo sind Leute, die ihr Mund auf dem Platz aufmachen. Das gehört dazu, dass man den Spieler auch sich entwickeln lässt, dass man ihn sein lässt, so wie er ist, auch mal dreimal gegen die Wand laufen lässt, ihm dann mal vielleicht ein paar Tipps gibt und nicht sich da irgendwie profilieren muss. Also wir haben da so viele Geschichten noch außerhalb, wo man mal auch in Dresden habe ich das erlebt, wo Trainer sich so ein bisschen selber profilieren wollen, die so ihre eigenen Stars sein wollen. Man sieht ja auch Julian Nagelsmann zum Beispiel, so als tollen Trainer, wo vielleicht manche Trainer sagen, das könnte ich auch sein, ja in so einem jungen Alter, sehr moderner Trainer, ich könnte auch so einen Weg gehen vielleicht. Ja, es sind ja auch viele talentierte junge Trainer unterwegs, aber ich glaube, das ist schwierig als Trainer. Man muss, es ist schwerer als Trainer, glaube ich, mal den Mund zu halten und einen Schritt zurückzugehen und ein bisschen die Züge locker zu lassen, als wie man es halt kennt, alles kontrollieren zu wollen. Man hat einen Spielplan, man hat einen Plan im Training, aber mal so ein bisschen zurücktreten und die Spieler mal wirklich, ja sich entwickeln lassen und eigentlich so wie es jetzt auch, die Stimmen ja ein bisschen lauter werden, so als Beobachter da sind. Ja, also den Mut haben, die Spieler mal machen zu lassen, die richtigen Inputs zu geben, an den richtigen Stellen, wenn sie merken, die kommen vom Weg ein bisschen gerade ab, vom Ziel, den man im Auge hat. Und das ist wesentlich schwerer, sich hinzusetzen, ich bin der Trainer, ihr hört mir zu, ich habe meinen Plan und mach ihr meine Karriere ein bisschen. Also ich habe auch, ich glaube du auch, ich kann einige Trainer, gibt es schon überall auf jedem Weg, wo ich sage, die hätten uns sofort stehen und liegen lassen, wenn sie wüssten, die könnten jetzt bei Stuttgart, was weiß ich, oder bei irgendeinem Profi-Fall oder der nächste 19 Trainer werden, die hätten uns stehen und liegen lassen. Das war auch gefühlsmäßig manchmal klar, dass wenn ein Angebot reinfliegt, dass er sofort weg wäre. Die sind leider dann nun mal Teil des ganzen Systems. Das System Profi fängt auch für die Trainer, einige mittlerweile in der U17, in der U19 an. Vor allem weil wir bei Dortmund waren, wir haben das ja wirklich mitbekommen. Die waren alle fest angestellt und die werden auch da ein schlechtes Geld verdient haben. Aber die ganzen Summen, die ja dann schon für die Spiele ausgegeben wurden, da muss man ja alles sehen. Dortmund, für Jugendspieler geben die schon relativ viel Geld aus. Und die wissen, weil deren Plan ist, ich möchte die hochbringen. Das heißt, der Trainer kriegt Druck und dem wird gesagt, ey, wir stellen die hier so gute Spieler hin. Sieh zu, dass du mit denen Meister wirst, damit die hochkommen. Und dann sind die auch Teil des Systems. Und sich da als Trainer so stark zu sein, sich dagegen zu stellen und zu sagen, ja, ich möchte aber auch hier gucken, dass ich Jungs gut ausbilde. Das ist schon extrem schwierig oder vielleicht auch manchmal dann unmöglich. Weil das System nun mal gerade so ist, wie es ist. Und dadurch, dass dann die Trainer da auch gar nicht so viel Entscheidungsgewalt haben, vielleicht, sondern einfach nur darauf getrimmt werden, du musst jetzt hier gewinnen, sonst ist das alles schlecht. Und dann hat er, wie Stefan auch gesagt hat, vielleicht auch Angst um seinen Job. Ich glaube, ein fest angestellter Jugendtrainer bei Dortmund in der U17 oder 19, der möchte ungern seinen Job verlieren. Der wird einen neuen wiederfinden. Aber ich glaube, die wissen auch ganz genau, was das erst mal für eine gute Position ist in Deutschland. Da können wir jetzt mal die großen Vereine in Deutschland aufmachen, die wahrscheinlich finanziell und von der Stahlkraft in Deutschland so das Niveau von Borussia Dortmund haben. Da würde ich Bayern München und RB Leipzig vielleicht noch nennen. Und dann fallen die meisten, glaube ich, aber schon ab. Den Job finanziell, vor allem auch finanziell, genau. Und den Job möchte man, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt verlieren. Wir haben es ja ab und zu erlebt, wo man mal quasi nicht auf Meisterschaftskurs war, wo man vielleicht mal nach zwei, drei Spielen unentschieden mal auf Platz vier oder Platz fünf gerutscht ist. Also dann hat der Busch aber gebrannt bei uns in Dortmund. Ja, dann waren das auch sehr, wie man es sich aus dem Profibereich wahrscheinlich kennt, wir haben es ja nicht kennengelernt, aber dann ging es wirklich darum, um jeden Preis wieder auf Kurs zu kommen, zu gewinnen. Ja, wo man ja auch mal sagt, Teil des Systems sind, muss man sich erstmal gegenstellen und sagen, Leute, wir sind zwar Fünfter geworden, haben aber so und so viele Spieler rausgemacht. Die Jungs wurden besser, das wäre nicht so gut, dann glaube ich, dass sie da rausgekommen sind. Nur um zu zeigen, was da für ein Druck auf dem Kessel ist. Wir hatten das Alex in seinem letzten und 19. Jahr, ich in meinem ersten, in dem Jahr, wo wir zusammen gespielt haben, hatten wir generell eine ganz schlechte Saison für Dortmunder verhältnisse von der Platzierung und dann hatten wir auch wieder, glaube ich, zwei Spiele unentschieden und dann noch eins verloren, also drei Spiele oder so, die unigepunktet wurden. Da haben wir samstags gespielt, da war aber am nächsten Sonntagmorgen um 8 Uhr Videoanalyse, alle Mann und die ging bis 15 Uhr nachmittags. Da haben wir wirklich 90 Minuten Fußball bei uns reingezogen nochmal, unser ganzes Spiel, alles. Jede Sekunde. Jede Sekunde, da wurde uns vorgerechnet, wie viele Punkte wir jetzt noch holen müssen, damit wir da, damit wir noch zur deutschen Meisterschaft da reinziehen können. Dann sind wir danach noch auf den Platz gegangen und haben noch Sachen gemacht. Also da haben wir wirklich von 8 Uhr morgens bis nachmittags 15, 16 Uhr uns das Spiel von Samstag angeguckt, was wir da verloren haben. Und da sieht man ja auch, was da für ein Druck dann ist. Ein Druck auf dem Kessel. Das waren schon die Dimensionen, wo wir uns da bewegt haben. Für alle Beteiligten. Jetzt muss er auch mal sagen, genau das, was man ist, auch auf den Trainer. Jetzt im Nachhinein selbstverständlich. Also der, der da gewinnen möchte, gewinnen muss, je nachdem, wie man sagen will.
Ja, kann ich mir nur zu gut, zu gut vorstellen, wie das dann da abgeht. Ich habe nur eine Kleinigkeit, auch wenn das jetzt eine Herspalterei ist, aber ihr und ich, ihr sprecht immer vom Trainer. Und vielleicht geht es damit schon los, auch wenn es echt nur eine Marginalie ist, aber vielleicht muss man sagen, es gibt Bundesligatrainer, das sind Trainer mit erwachsenen Menschen, die in der Regel erwachsenen Menschen, die Profifußball machen, da geht es um wahnsinnig viel Geld. Und vielleicht müsste man diese Angestellten bei diesen U-Mannschaften, egal ob im NLZ oder woanders, nicht Trainer nennen, sondern Coach nennen. Also nur eine Kleinigkeit. Aber aus meiner Sicht ist das, da gibt es noch einen Unterschied dazwischen. Weil es zählen in Ausbildungs-Jugendbereich, zählen noch andere Faktoren als nachher im Profibereich. Und es wird aber immer von oben nach unten gedacht. Es wird immer vom Profi auf die Ausbildung gedacht. Dieses klassische Trickle-Down ist da so krass wie sonst nirgendwo ausgeprägt. Und da könnte man vielleicht so ein bisschen versuchen, das ein etwas abzuschwächen.
Das Wort schließe mich an, Stefan. Das ist vielleicht Harschballerei, aber der Sinn dahinter überhaupt nicht. Also wirklich gar nicht. Wir haben das gemerkt, wir sind jetzt 23 bis 24, wir haben das teilweise schon währenddessen als Jugendspieler gemerkt, wo man sagt, klar, bei den Profis wird das so gemacht, also muss das bei der Jugendmannschaft genauso laufen. Ja und dann teilweise jetzt im Nachhinein auch, wenn ich es ehrlich sage, ein bisschen albern, was teilweise für Maßnahmen von Trainer ergriffen worden sind, gegen als Mitte 30- 40- 50-Jährige, gegen 16-Jährige, irgendwelche, ja okay, dann gehen wir jetzt mal laufen und bis ihr kotzt, bis hin zum Licht aus gegen gegen irgendeinen Tabellenletzten und Motivationssprachen und Flaschen werden geschmissen und lauft, lauft, lauft. Dann weiß ich, wo man denkt, ja klar, bei den Profis, da geht es um viel Geld, da geht es um Gewinn, da wird es, da wirst du daran gemessen, dass du sie geholtest. So musst du jetzt vielleicht nicht als gestandener Erwachsener mit dem 15-Jährigen, 16-Jährigen, 17-Jährigen umgehen und genau wie du sagst, dieses gleiche, diesen gleichen Maßstab in der Jugend ansetzt. Ja, und dann teilweise irgendwelche, welche Maßnahmen ergreifen, wo man sagt, hey, also die sind vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen übertrieben. Also die Härte soll ja da sein, ist ja auch ein wieder ein schmaler Gerät. Die Professionellität und so soll ja da sein und das ist ja dann auch der, der Sprung sollte ja nicht so groß sein, so den Profis. Aber man darf nicht vergessen, genau das, was Stefan sagt, ist kein Bundesliga-Trainer. Er hat da keine gestandenen Profis, die da ihre Millionen verdienen und das als wirklich als Beruf ausüben, wo man auch mal sagen kann, du nächste Woche spielst nicht mehr in Berlin, da spielst du in Stuttgart oder so. Guck, wie du rüberkommst. Dafür wird dir auch gut entlohnt. Das ist dafür sein Job. Letztendlich sind wir immer noch Jugendspieler, die quasi Schüler sind. Ja, da musst du nicht den gleichen Maßstab hinter setzen und so draufhören. Also oft genau das, was das ist jetzt auch abschließend, was Stefan sagt, man oft bei Relegen gesehen, dass die Trainer in der Jugend oft so versuchen, das Gleiche zu machen wie Trainer in der Bundesliga und dann irgendwelche Motivationssachen, wo man dröht, irgendwie Drakonische, warum man Pass falsch spielt, wo man sagt, ey, 16 Jahre, der da, wo man Fehlpass spielt, der da, wo man schlechte Spiele haben oder so oder da ist zu Hause mal irgendein Auslegen. Schiefeltern haben sich gestritten, weiß ich. Ja, dass man da mal ein bisschen einfach differenzierter sieht und sich, genau wie deswegen sage ich, Haarspalterei ist das Wort, ob sie jetzt Coach nennen oder was weiß ich, aber der Sinn ist, ist definitiv keine Haarspalterei, dass man da kein Bundesliga-Trainer ist. Man ist da kein Trainer. Man sollte vielleicht, wenn es auch ein bisschen blöder klingt, man ist eher Sozialpädagoge als Trainer. Genau, weil Marius hat das ja auch angesprochen, diese fußballerische Ausbildung ist möglich. Ja, also ich kann mich jetzt hinsetzen und ein halbes Jahr die Taktik lernen und die Trainingsform lernen. Dann kann man besser werden als taktischer Trainer, das kann man lernen, finde ich. Also sich angucken, wie sind Formationen, wie kann man gute, effektive Trainingsmethoden schaffen. Das ist das eine. Aber die Qualität zu haben, sich hinzustellen und ein guter Mensch, ein guter Pädagoge, gute soziale Beziehungen aufzubauen zu spielen, das kann man nicht lernen, aber das ist viel wichtiger. Der beste Spruch, den ich immer, um das in Worte zu fassen, ist, ein Spieler hat einen Trainer, aber ein Trainer hat 23 Spieler. Also du musst dieses Ungleichgewicht lösen können als Trainer, dass du, oder als Coach wieder sagen, du musst dir bewusst sein, dass du zu allen richtig die anpacken musst. Ja, und das ist schwer, wie wir gerade eben gesagt haben, aber das ist nötig. Wir haben wirklich tolle Beispiele auch als Trainer, wo die Autorität klar war, wer hier der Chef ist als Coach, der mit dir sprechen konnte, wo die Kommunikation gestimmt hat, wo das teilweise auf Orgenhöhe war, wo man sich auch getraut hat, was zu sagen, wo die Entwicklungen vordergrund standen, wo ich da auch sein sollte als Pädagoge beispielsweise, die auch menschlich zu fördern, als Typen zu fördern, die auch Entscheidungen treffen können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir es auch ganz oft gemerkt, quasi dieses Korsett und einmal alles absägen, was nicht da reinpasst, wenn der Mund aufgemacht wird, wenn keine Kommunikation stattfindet, wenn es eher darum geht, durch brüllende Autorität auszustrahlen, immer beweisen zu müssen, wer gerade Chef ist. Und das ist der klackende Punkt, dass man da sagt, ja eigentlich ist es mehr Pädagogik. Und das kann man halt schwer lernen, dass man sagen muss, ok, Marius ist eher so ein Typ, den würde ich jetzt vor dem Spiel nicht motivierend anbrüllen, das kriegt er selber hin. Aber es gibt auch Spielertypen, die haben wir auch kennengelernt, die musst du nur ein bisschen bei der Ehre packen, die wären für dich 90 Minuten hoch und runter gelaufen. Aber du musst sie halt anders anpacken können, du musst Spiele anders, das ist die große Qualität, die man braucht.
Ja, also Fußballpädagogen sollten wir es vielleicht nennen statt Trainer, da schreibt ihr auch in eurem Buch, die Jahrtausendfußballer Marius und Alex werden von 80er und 90er Trainern trainiert, die erstens ganz anders sozialisiert wurden auf dem Fußballplatz, zweitens eine äußerst leistungsbezogene Ausbildung erlebten und drittens nicht automatisch gute Pädagogen und Menschenversteher sind. Abschlusstabelle schlägt Empathie, Meisterschaft schlägt Persönlichkeitsentwicklung. Und das scheint mir nämlich der Nukleus zu sein, neben allen Reformen, Strukturen, Transferstrategien und so weiter. Die Empathie gegenüber den Menschen – ich habe wirklich schon viele Fußballerbiografien gelesen oder Sportlerbiografien, ein paar davon stehen hier hinter mir im Bücherregal – und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie eine Konstante sich durch alles durchzieht für den Sportler oder die Sportlerin. Gibt es eine wichtige Person und das ist der Trainer oder die Trainerin. Und wenn es da nicht funktioniert, dann kann das Karrieren beenden. Wenn es da funktioniert, dann kann das Karrieren fördern und von jetzt auf gleich kann sich alles verändern. Das kann man auch in eurem Buch wunderbar nachlesen. Die kurze Zeit mit Hannes Wolf – sie wird zumindest im Buch ganz positiv beschrieben – dann wurde er wegbefördert, weil er war zu erfolgreich. Und dann kam mir Benjamin Hofmann, ein Trainer, da kommt viel vor in diesem Buch, aber nicht viel in positiven Sinne. Und der Unterschied zwischen beiden – das Taktische, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, das wird auch gar nicht so erwähnt, aber das Empathische ist der Unterschied. Und das bringt nämlich mich zu einem weiteren Punkt, weil das auch – also ich will euch jetzt gar nicht zwingen, dass ihr da jetzt noch mal irgendwie öffentlich Dinge zu sagt, das kann man wirklich sehr gut hier nachlesen und auch in vielen anderen Sportlabiografien – dass Trainer gute Pädagogen sein sollten im Jugendbereich ist eigentlich eine Binse, aber es muss noch mal festgestellt werden. Ich finde, es kommt hier aber noch ein zweiter Aspekt hinzu und da komme ich noch mal auf etwas zurück, was ich vor einer Stunde oder so gesagt habe, der Druck, der im System ist. Denn wir sprechen hier ja auch – also wir sprechen nicht nur über viele Spieler oder junge Menschen, die ihre berufliche Ausbildung hinten anstellen und so weiter, sondern wir sprechen ja auch über Leistungssport. Und was bedeutet Leistungssport? Leistungssport bedeutet Raubbau am eigenen Körper, dem man auch bewusst eingeht. Und ich meine, ihr seid da gute Beispiele für. Ich habe mir versucht, alle Verletzungen zu notieren, die im Buch vorkommen, und ich bin mir sicher, dass ich was vergessen habe. Allein dreimal der Oberschenkel war es bei dir, Malius. Bei Alex habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, was hatten wir alles? Faszienriss am Hüftbeuger, die Rückenmuskeln waren komplett verkrampft, durftest aber wieder zu früh trainieren, hast dann gleich einen Rückschlag danach errichten. Und es gab noch so Dinge wie mit eigentlich dicken Knöcheln zu Ende gespielt und so weiter, weil man will ja auch als Spieler selbst, also da müsste man ja auch geschützt werden von den Pädagogen um einen außen rum. Gleichzeitig wollen die Pädagogen aber ja auch, dass man spielt. Und das würde mich jetzt nämlich noch als einzelner Aspekt interessieren, wenn ihr jetzt zurückblickt auf eure Zeit im Leistungssport, wo ihr eben bis ganz nah an den Profibereich gekommen seid, aber es eben nicht reingeschafft habt. Und wenn ihr euch jetzt anguckt, einfach in welchem körperlichen Zustand ihr seid und durch welche Verletzungen ihr hindurchgespielt habt, wie denkt ihr jetzt über den gesundheitlichen Aspekt der Mühle, die ihr dadurch laufen habt?
Also vorne weg, wenn man natürlich viel Sport treibt und einen Sport betreibt, den es Zweikämpfe gibt und so, der Intensiv ist dann, gehören Verletzungen natürlich dazu. Das Problem ist nur oder was wir ganz oft erlebt haben, war zum Beispiel jetzt so auf so was anzuspielen wie mit Schmerztabletten. Das wird ja auch von Profis oft mal genannt, unter Schmerztabletten spielen mit Tape und so. Da wird ja immer oder wurde ja ganz oft sage ich mal in dieser Männerfußballwelt noch, wenn ich das jetzt mal so in Anführung sprechen sagen darf, bist du eine Pussy oder nicht? Kannst du spielen, nur weil du mal, weil du jetzt umgeknickt bist oder nicht? Und dann ist halt immer die Frage, wie geht ein Trainer wirklich damit um? Wie, wie ernst nimmt der dich? Für wie voll nimmt der dich, dass du deinen eigenen Körper kennst, dass du jetzt vielleicht spielen kannst mal, weil es wirklich nur eine Prellung ist und da kann nix passieren oder du hast wirklich eine Verletzung, wo man einfach mal sagen muss, ja, wenn du könntest du jetzt zwei Schmerz-Habletten reinhauen, tapen und dann spielen, das würde schon irgendwie gehen, nur förderlich ist es nicht. Und das ist auch in der Jugend und das ist wirklich so ganz oft auch ein Problem, dass da immer schon so drauf abgestellt wird, ja du willst auch Profi werden. Dann musst du auch halt mal da durch. Und ich meine, wir sind jetzt, wir haben viele Verletzungen. Ich für mich kann sagen, ich hätte auch ganz, ganz zwei, drei weniger gehabt. Aber es beeinträchtigt mich jetzt in meinem Leben zum Glück nicht total. Ich habe so ein paar Sachen, vor allem mit meinen Leisten, so habe ich so, wenn ich zum Beispiel nachts schlafe und mich immer umdrehe, das ist nicht so ganz optimal immer. Aber es ist jetzt nichts mega dramatisches dabei.
Ja, aber sorry, du bist 23. Ich möchte von einem 23-Jährigen nicht hören, dass er sich nachts nicht umdreht gerne, weil er Leistenprobleme hat.
Ja, das ist jetzt, ja, das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich für manche ziemlich hart an. Wie gesagt, das hat bei mir auch angefangen schon mit 12, 13 und hat sich das so immer ein bisschen durchgezogen. Man lernt damit umzugehen. Es wäre schöner, hätten wir keine Verletzungen gehabt. Es ist auch manchmal einfach ein bisschen zu viel für den Körper, auch für den Körper, der noch wächst, der sich noch weiterentwickelt in den jungen Jahren, der ja eh unter Stress steht, sowohl mental, erstmal vom Kopf her mit dem Druck und dann wirklich auch körperlich. Es ist viel, es ist manchmal definitiv auch zu viel. Und wie ich gerade gesagt habe, ist es nun mal das Problem, wie gehen die Verantwortlichen mit den Spielern um, für wie voll nehmen sie sie, wenn ein Spieler sagt, ich bin jetzt mal wirklich verletzt oder ich bin auch einfach mal wirklich nur körperlich am Ende. Das muss ja nicht immer direkt sich in einer Verletzung sich ausdrücken. Es kann ja auch einfach mal sein, dass wenn man jetzt die ganzen letzten Monate hin und her gependelt ist, gefahren ist, gespielt, dass man einfach mal sagt, ich bin, ich bin platt, kann ich mehr. Das muss ich ja nicht direkt immer im extremen Fall einer Verletzung äußern. Für wie voll wird man dann genommen? Und wie, auf welcher Ebene begegnet man sich da? Und das ist definitiv verbesserungswürdig. Wer hat keine Frage. Da würde ich auch direkt, ich musste gerade schmunzeln, weil er sagt, das beheinträchtigt mich nicht viel im Leben. Marius muss auch schmunzeln. Ich habe jetzt, 1.1. habe ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall bekommen und lag auch zwei Monate extrem flach.
Hast du nicht auch ganz früh im Januar Geburtstag?
Nein, 27. habe ich Geburtstag. Ach so, du warst das, Entschuldigung. Klar, den kann man so kriegen. Ich bin aber ziemlich der Meinung, ich habe eh immer ganz, ganz Probleme im unteren Rücken. Genau da, wo er jetzt sitzt, habe ich, glaube ich, mein kleines Päckchen all zu tragen. Und da muss man einfach ehrlich sein. Und da stehen wir beide auf zu. Und das kommt, glaube ich, in dem Buch dann am Ende ganz gut rüber, warum wir sagen, um jeden Preis vierte Liga, dritte Liga wollen wir nicht. Wir merken jetzt schon, dass der Körper gelitten hat. Dafür sind wir auch gerne bereit. Wir würden es auch immer wieder so machen, weil wir haben Sachen erlebt, die muss man erst mal erleben, die wir erleben durften. Das soll dann aber auch entlohnt werden. Also es klingt dann ganz blöd. Vielleicht klingt das für manche, die können das nicht ganz verstehen. Aber wie haben wir immer gesagt, wir gehen den Weg so, dass wir unseren Körper dafür hergeben, was hätten wir noch länger gespielt, definitiv weiter gemacht hätten. Dann soll sich das auch finanziell so entlohnen, dass ich gerne bereit bin, mal auf Skifahren zu verzichten, dass ich mit meinen Kindern, wenn ich sie mal haben sollte, nicht so umherrennen kann, wie vielleicht manch anderer noch oder mit 30, 35 jetzt nicht so fit bin, wie manch anderer. Und da muss ich ganz klar – auch wieder drehen wir uns wieder um dieses gleiche Thema – da müssen die Verantwortlichen wirklich aktiv sein und eigentlich auch horchen gucken können. Weil, sag mal, im 15-jährigen das erste Mal sich in den Oberschenkel reißt, wär grad besser, wenn du mal ein bisschen länger pausierst. Dieses Kennenlernen mit Verletzungen, man kommt eigentlich als – man kennt keine Verletzungen, man kennt sich als Unkaputtbar. Ich kenn auch die Phasen, wo ich quasi ohne Aufwärm auf den Platz und rumrenne und schieße, wo ich mir heute denke, ey Junge, du musst dich mindestens 45 Minuten warm machen, bevor du ein Pass spielst. Man lernt das ja. Und das wird ja dann auch ganz lustig. U15, Ersichtungsturnier für die Nationalmannschaft bei Westfalen. Ja, ich wär mich auf und werd noch am Platz, am Rücken behandelt, werd ich noch eingeregnet, damit ich wieder auf dem Platz dann fit bin. Ja, Marius mit Fragen, kannst du spielen? Ja, wo ich mal ein Faszienriss hatte, in der U16, wo ich bemerkt, kam der Trainer auf mich zu, wann willst du fit? Wir spielen zwei Wochen gegen Schalke. So nach dem Motto, genau da, wo ich sag, jetzt im Nachhinein, Leute, ihr seid erwachsene Männer oder Frauen, jeder dem, aber natürlich meistens Männer. Ihr sprecht hier gerade mit einem 16-Jährigen, tretet mal einen Schritt zurück, es ist ein U16-Spiel, es ist ein U15-Spiel, es geht um die Entwicklung, um die langjährige Entwicklung. Es ist mal okay, wenn da mal ein Spiel ausfällt. Ja, auch dieses, um jeden Preis. Wir kennen eigentlich keinen Spieler U19, da gibt es ganz wenige, die verletzungsfrei, bis dahin… Gibt's gar nicht, würde ich mal sagen. Echt, bis dahin noch. Also die, die immer gespielt haben. Ja, das ist auch gut. Aber wenn man auch mal sagt, Leute, mach doch mal ein bisschen Belastungssteuerung, dann muss man aber irgendwie über das Thema Erfolg sprechen, ja? Dann ist es, musst du auch mal bereit sein, vielleicht Spieler Nummer 15, 16, 17 spielen zu lassen und nicht deine Top-11 auf den Platz zu schicken, wo der eine die die die Beine schon getapet hat oder mit einem Schmerzabweite spielt, dann verliert man mal schlecht weg. Ja, auch wenn das vielleicht falsch klingt und man sagt, man ist wieder verbeichlich. Aber da hat man eigentlich die Verantwortung, man sagt, Leute, kriegt man wieder ein bisschen Bezug zur Realität, das ist ein U16 Spiel oder U17 Spiel. Es ist schön, wenn wir gewinnen, wenn er auf dem Platz ist, aber es wäre noch besser, wenn er fit bleibt, ja? Also es ist auch ganz oft so, dass man ja guckt, also ich kann mir jetzt niemals vorstellen, dreimal die Woche zu spielen, also über zehn Jahre, wo wir jetzt quasi U17 und U19 Jahre, groß Niveau auf Junioreneben, aber dann noch mal jede Woche Bundesliga spielen, vielleicht Pokal dabei, vielleicht sogar Champions League oder International, also was da abgerufen wird, da war bei mir zum Beispiel ganz viele, die wir kennen, der Körper schon eigentlich so blästiert, dass sie gar nicht, oder wenn damit ganz viel Physio und so weiter da durchkommen, ja also bis zur U19, wenn man dann raus ist, da hat jeder mal eine größere Sache, das heißt die Hüfte kaputt, das heißt mal, das Knie, jeder hat irgendwas, jeder geht hoch in den Fitnessraum und hat sein kleines Päckchen, was er da bearbeitet und da denkt man sich auch so, ja Thema Belastungssteuerung, ja lass sie mal einfach ein bisschen holen, ja also das Belastungssteuerung war eigentlich nicht, da ging es um jeden Preis zu gewinnen, wenn du fit warst und so, auch wenn du halbwegs nur fit warst, wenn du halbwegs nur fit warst und ein wichtiges Spiel war, dann war das halt, wie bei den Profis, wie Stefan gesagt hat, dieses Triple Down, bei den Profis wird es auch gemacht, aber da geht es um 20 Millionen, Ja, das ist ein Thema. Und wenn du vom Viertelfinale ins Halbfinale kommst, in den Champions League, dann geht es um viel Geld. Dann ist es auch okay, wenn der Verantwortliche immer sagt, du, beist du mal auf die 10, wir brauchen das und wir wollen das. Aber in der Jugend, ob ich jetzt Westfalen-Pokalsieger werde, also im extremen Beispiel, das ist ja.
Ja, und gleichzeitig, also die Spielbelastung ist hoch. Ich meine, ihr habt ja noch eine Youth League dann auch gespielt, also dem Champions League-Bondon, wo man, wo man auch, also man ist in so einer ständigen Ambivalenz. Also ihr erzählt ja auch von Turnieren in Dubai und in Russland, die WM mit Lothar Matthäus, der da auch sich ganz vorbildlich verhalten hat gegenüber den, Schutzbefohlenen ist zu viel, aber den Jugendlichen. Lest das Buch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es ist eine der schönen Anekdoten an dieser Stelle. Also eine, die man sich zumindest erinnert. Also auf der einen Seite ist es ja auch toll, weil das ist ja auch etwas, was man zurückbekommt. Ihr gebt sehr viel in diesem jungen Alter und ihr bekommt diese Reisen. Ihr seht auch mehr von der Welt als ganz viele andere Jugendliche. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch wieder ein kleines Mosaiksteinchen, was eben diesen Druck erhöht. Es sind eben noch mehr Spiele. Es sind gerade diese Turniere. Da ist auch immer der Erfolg sehr gut ablesbar. Also ich verstehe das. Ich habe ja selber früher auch Turniere gespielt. Es muss einen Sieger geben, aber vielleicht ist das auch nicht immer der perfekte Ansatz. Vielleicht kann man das auch mal anders gestalten. Also ich war ganz oft beim Junior Cup in Sindelfingen vor Ort. Da ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass sie einen Turnierbaum so gemacht haben, dass jedes Team am Ende die gleiche Anzahl Spieler hat, egal wie schlecht du abgeschnitten hast in der Gruppenphase. So eine kleine Sache, die sie da verändert haben, dass da schon mal ein bisschen der Druck raus ist. Auch wenn man da auch schon gesehen hat, da habe ich auch Verhaltensweisen gesehen von Trainern ihren Teams, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Junge, du bist hier in Sindelfingen. Komm mal runter, auch wenn es vielleicht auf Sport 1 übertragen wird. Aber das ist eben das und das bringt mich zu so einem großen Überpunkt, nämlich die Ambivalenz, die dieses gesamte Thema durchzieht. Man will jungen Menschen ihren Traum nicht nehmen. Man will ihnen eigentlich auch alles zur Verfügung stellen, dass sie es in den Profifußball schaffen. Und wir haben auch auf der anderen Seite und schon darüber beschwert, warum können die alle nichts, die im Profifußball ankommen. Also wir, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, wollen ja auch dann, dass Deutschland auch einen erfolgreichen Fußball spielt. Und auf der anderen Seite wissen wir aber auch alle, die Realität sagt, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, es ist extrem schwierig und man muss vielleicht, man verliert vielleicht mehr auf der Strecke, als es dann letztlich schaffen. Plus, eine Klammer muss ich jetzt noch setzen, das habe ich nämlich gerade noch vergessen, der ganze Bereich des Mädchenfußballs ist in dem Fall noch mal krasser, weil die mit schlechteren Bedingungen spielen und aber verletzungsanfälliger für so richtige Hardcore-Verletzungen wie Kreuzbandrisse sind. Riesiges Thema, sehen wir, es kommt jetzt gerade endlich im Frauenfußball, wird drüber berichtet, weil, also weil leider sich richtig tolle Spielerinnen jetzt vor der WM wieder die Kreuzbände gerissen haben. Aber da geht es ja im Jugendfußball auch schon los, also auch noch ganz wichtiger Aspekt, den man nicht vergessen darf. Aber zurück zu dieser Ambivalenz. Und diese Ambivalenz kann man ja letztlich dann runterbrechen auf 1% schafft es in dem Profi-Fußball, 99% schaffen es nicht. Was machen die 99% danach? Hoffentlich haben sie irgendwie einen Schulabschluss hinbekommen. Jetzt habe ich mit euch zwei dieser 99% hier sitzen, also nicht zwei Prozent, sondern zwei, die innerhalb dieser 99% sind. Wie denkt ihr denn jetzt zurück an diese Zeit, wenn ihr jetzt auch darüber nachdenkt, dass ihr seid mit weitem Abstand die Jüngsten in dieser Runde hier? Ihr habt noch am meisten Leben vor euch. Wie zufrieden seid ihr damit, wie ihr das quasi geschafft habt, das auszutarieren?
Sehr zufrieden tatsächlich. Klar, dieser harte Cut, von dem ich werde meinen Traum nie erreichen, die Erkenntnis dazu bekommen und sich das selber einzugestehen, das war ganz schlimm. Diese letzten Wochen, die ich vor allem in Dortmund und in der U19 hatte, waren schon total hart. Einfach nur Scheiße. Und dieser Prozess bis hin zur Entscheidung, ich höre jetzt auf, das ist jetzt hier gerade ein ganz harter Cut, aber das ist ein Cut, weil es einfach nicht mehr das ist und niemals das werden wird, was ich wollte, das war sehr schwierig, auch sehr anspruchsvoll für den Kopf. Da geht einem natürlich auch viel durch den Kopf. Ist das jetzt schon das Richtige oder ist das ein klassisches Ich gebe jetzt hier gerade ein bisschen zu früh auf vielleicht in dem Moment, aber als ich dann wirklich meinen Vertrag da mal aufgelöst habe und gesagt habe, so jetzt ist das Ende, das war dann total befreiend und quasi ab dem Punkt muss ich echt sagen, an wurde es von Tag zu Tag nur besser. Also da war ich echt jeden Tag oder ich bin jeden Tag immer mehr im Reinen mit mir, dass ich das so entschieden habe und dass ich auch in spiel gucken kann und jetzt im Endeffekt sagen kann, ja okay, ich war nicht gut genug für das, was ich erreichen wollte. Es gab Umstände, die hätten es erleichtern können, es gab leider Umstände, die haben das insgesamt alles erschwert, aber ich kann in spiel gucken und im Großen und Ganzen sagen, okay, für das, was ich erreichen wollte, war ich nicht gut genug. Und die Erkenntnis zu bekommen und zu erhalten hat sehr geholfen. Das hat mir persönlich sehr geholfen, habe ich auch gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht schlimm. So, das Leben geht weiter, ich habe zum Glück mein Abi gemacht, ich kann jetzt danach alles machen, was ich wollte. Und seit dem Tag geht es mir damit sehr gut und ich bin damit, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, sehr zufrieden. Die Entscheidung würde ich, auf die würde ich genauso, genauso wieder treffen. Also bei mir ist es genauso. Bisschen länger gedauert, aber jetzt so im Großen und Ganzen so sagen zu können, man ist sehr zufrieden. Da gibt man so eine ganze Lebensanstellung, sag ich mal, so wie wir jetzt sind, wir sind angekommen, ein paar Daboren zusammen, wir studieren was Gutes, jeweils natürlich der andere. Ich mache jetzt keine Steuerbewertung, aber man fühlt sich, man ist angekommen und auch dieser ganze Prozess und vielleicht auch immer die Frage, ein bisschen weiter zu sagen, wir sind, wir würden es wieder tun, also auch jetzt ich mit meinem Bandscheinvorfall, ich glaube nur mit deinem Leisten und so weiter, man kann alle Sachen nehmen, auch mit dem Scheitern, wenn man es einen Scheitern nennen möchte. Der Weg war genial, ja auch das, was wir versuchen natürlich auch im Buch wiederzugeben, all die schönen Sachen, die waren schon ziemlich, ziemlich geil. Also das muss man erstmal so sagen und auch erleben können und klingt natürlich immer ein bisschen doof, aber wir haben aber gesagt, ey, wir sind 22 und können 250 Seiten füllen, was wir einfach erlebt haben. Und das ist schon, das ist einfach ganz cool, wo man sagt, das möchte man nicht missen und da haben wir auch ganz viel rausgenommen, die wir jetzt halt auch heute nutzen können, also die wir auch einfach ein bisschen ja schon ins normale, ins Berufsleben vielleicht mitnehmen können. Also Beispiel, wir haben es schon mal gehört, dass jemand zu einem sagt, du bist nicht gut genug. Ja, also es reicht nicht, such dir was anderes, ja, wo man vielleicht mal sagen kann, okay, wie geht man mit so was um, was vielleicht in der heutigen Welt auch mit häufigeren Jobwechseln vielleicht zu tun hat. Ja, aber wie geht man mit Niederlagen um, wie geht man damit um, wenn jemand sagt, du geh mal lieber. Auch Entscheidungen treffen, wir sind glaube ich beide ziemlich, ja doch, stolz kann man schon sagen in dem Sinn, dass man aktiv zu sich selber sagen kann, okay, möchtest du das noch oder nicht und aktiv eine Entscheidung zu treffen. Weil ganz viele sind ja auch gut, die sind vielleicht auch angewiesen, weil das Geld ja auch nicht verkehrt ist. Die spielen jetzt vierte, fünfte Liga, sind 23, 24, 25, haben immer noch die Hoffnung, kommen ein gutes Spiel, dann komme ich in die zweite, dann muss ich Scout sitzen und vielleicht schaffe ich noch den Sprung und werde Profi und sickern so langsam dahin und ruht ab wirklich Respekt für jeden, der ein Fernstudium macht oder danach mit 28, 27 sich nochmal auf die Vorlesungsbank irgendwo setzt oder irgendwo eine Ausbildung anfängt. Das muss man erstmal auch machen. Da sind wir stolz, dass wir gesagt haben, also wir waren sehr, sehr weit weg zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir oft gehört haben vom Profi-Fußball, wo wir gesagt haben, da wollen wir hin und da dann sich selber zu sagen, es macht glaube ich gerade mehr Sinn, was anderes zu machen. Das war ganz gut eigentlich und den bereuen wir auch nicht. Ja, es hört sich immer so dramatisch an, wenn man sagt, wir haben uns aktiv damit abgefunden, dass wir gescheitert sind. Das hört sich immer so schlimm an, aber eigentlich ist es das Gegenteil.
Ihr gehört ja jetzt nur zu uns. Also Stefan und ich haben es auch nie in die Bundesliga geschafft. Also ihr gehört zur Mehrheit jetzt.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist ja, wenn man mal ganz endlich ist, ist es auch ein Fall, wir hätten ja weitermachen können. Ja, also oft ist es ja auch in ganz vielen Situationen, da kann man ja vielleicht jeder mal, hat jeder ein Beispiel im Kopf, aber wo man Entscheidungen abgibt, wenn ich jetzt im Studium zum Beispiel, wenn ich die dritte Klausur jetzt vorbei haue, dann ist es so, dann breche ich das Studium ab. Muss ich ja eh abbrechen, beispielsweise so. Als wir hätten ja noch einen Verein bekommen, also dann sei es fünfte Liga oder selbst sechste Liga oder irgendwo, wir wären ja wo untergekommen, hätten wir auch weitermachen können, jetzt probieren wir es. Irgendwann, irgendwann, irgendwann mit 28, ich sage dann irgendwie, komm, bei mir reicht es auch nicht, dann ist Karriereende und dann wird die Entscheidung so ein bisschen abgenommen. Ja, man probiert es immer weiter. Obwohl der Zug, wenn man ganz ehrlich zu sich selber ist, vielleicht schon, ja, abgebogen ist zu der großen Karriere. Klar, es gibt die Spätzünder, aber das ist dann unter dem 1% nochmal dieser 0, 1%ig Anteil, der da so ist. Und das wollen wir mit Entscheidungen treffen, wo wir dann quasi, wir hätten das auch so, ich sage mal, dahin sicken lassen können, so ein bisschen und nun weiterkriegen. Aber da hätte man, da mussten wir ja aktiv nein sagen, weil dann haben wir gesagt, auch zum Berater gehen und sagen, du, such uns keinen neuen Verein, den Eltern Bescheid geben, wir gehen was anderes ein, der Familie das zu sagen. Das ist ja wirklich eine Entscheidung treffen. Das ist nicht mal so eben. Das ist, man muss da quasi aktiv einmal Stopp sagen und der Zug hält, weil der würde sonst einfach weiterholen.
Und weil es jetzt schon gerade angesprochen habt, das ist jetzt ein Aspekt, den haben wir so ein bisschen beiseite liegen lassen, die Peripherie, die ihr auch dann um Jugendspieler wie euch sich aufgebaut hat. Also ihr hattet eben Ausrüsteverträge zum Beispiel. Also zu dem 4-Jahres-Vertrag war damals auch ein Ausrüstevertrag mit, was bedeutet, geh mal hier in den Shop rein und suche für dich und deine Familie, nimm alles mit, was du haben möchtest und das passt dann schon. Und eben auch Berater, die sich ja schon sehr früh melden. Das habt ihr im Buch ja auch beschrieben, dass die sich zum Teil, also die seriöseren melden sich bei den Eltern, gibt aber auch genügend, die einen einfach so über soziale Netzwerke anschreiben und sagen, hey, soll ich dir Tickets für Spiele besorgen und so weiter? Willst du ein neues Paar Fußballschuhe haben und so weiter und so fort? Wie habt ihr denn dieses ganze Drumherum wahrgenommen, was ja auch passiert in einem Moment, wo man das noch nicht reflektieren kann? Also wie soll ein 14- 15-jähriger Junge oder Mädchen das reflektieren, was hier gerade passiert, wenn so viele Leute auf einmal von dir etwas wollen und die auch sagen, du bist toll und ich helfe dir, noch besser zu werden und so weiter und so fort? Wie blickt ihr da jetzt mit ein bisschen Abstand drauf?
Ja, das ist natürlich schon, wenn man das so sagt, wenn ich jetzt mit 23 drüber nachdenke, ich hatte mit 14 Vertrag bei Dortmund und ein Ausrüstvertrag bei Pruma, da sag ich ja jetzt selber schon zu meinem Ich vor den Jahren, das ist ja eigentlich total direlle, totale Parallelwelt. Was mir immer geholfen hat, ist erstmal natürlich, wenn die Eltern einen da immer auf den Boden halten und sagen so, das ist hier alles immer nur halblang, das passt schon alles, aber cool bleiben. Und was mir persönlich am meisten geholfen hat, war, dass es immer weiter ging. Es gab das nächste Spiel, es gab sofort das nächste Training und wieder das nächste Spiel, das nächste Turnier. Also diese Zeit zum Reflektieren, vielleicht ist es sogar auch gut, dass das ein 14-Jähriger gar nicht kann und gar keine Zeit dafür hat, weil der einfach dran bleiben muss. Und man wurde ja dadurch, dass es so ein voller Terminkalender war, immer in seine Welt da reingedrückt.
Also ist die Spielbelastung doch gut.
Ja, also auch mit 14 Jahren ist es einfach gut, wenn du was zu tun hast. Wenn du natürlich jetzt den Vertrag bekommst und hast dann nach drei Wochen Urlaub und kannst drei Wochen darüber nachdenken, wie toll du eigentlich bist, was du jetzt hier erreicht hast, dann wird es natürlich schwierig. Aber in dem Zusammenhang für den Kopf war das für mich total gut, dass es immer weiter ging. Man musste sich ja immer weiter beweisen, es kam wieder das nächste Spiel. Ein Ausrüstervertrag hilft einem dann auch nichts, wenn man dann die nächsten sechs Wochen nur schlecht trainiert und nicht mehr spielt. Da kann man zwar die neuesten Schuhe anhaben, nur wenn man mit den Schuhen nicht auf dem Platz steht, ist es natürlich schwierig. Deswegen war das für mich immer gut, dass ich wusste, es geht weiter und es geht die ganze Zeit weiter. Und es steht ja auch im Buch wirklich toll so drin als Metapher. Das ist ein jahrelanger Tunnelblick. Dieser jahrelange Tunnelblick, der hat mir da immer sehr geholfen.
Von Spiel zu Spiel gedacht, wie die ganz Großen.
Ja, es hört sich immer so zu einer Floskel an, aber das stimmt ja. Ja, vor allem, man guckt ja nicht nur von sich selber, dass man selber von Spiel zu Spiel guckt. Jeder guckt von Spiel zu Spiel. Ja, also das haben wir auch in der Jugend mitbekommen. Da gibt es teilweise Phasen, da bist du quasi raus, auch aus den Sichtungsmaßnahmen. Dann spielst du drei Spiele gut und um einmal bist du wieder ganz oben mit dabei. Das ist ja auch in der Jugend schnell lebendig. Also da kann man drei gute Spiele haben und sagen, boah, was ist das jetzt für einer? Der kickt gerade richtig gut, den müssen wir mal weiter auf den Zettel halten. Und dann kommt der Boomer-Vertrag und dann die nächsten drei Spiele nur Quatsch spielen und arrogant sein und sich ausruhen auf den Norbernenblättern. Dann ist ja auch ganz schön gesagt, was ist das denn für einer? Was hat der denn für einen Vertrag bekommen und was soll das denn? Und dann wird hinterfragt. So und deswegen ist das ganz gut, weil man selber einfach Gas gämt. Man macht weiter. Und ein gutes Umfeld, da hat man Glück mit Eltern und so. Also wir können es gar nicht vorstellen, möchte ich auch gar nicht. Wenn wir da ein bisschen alleine wären, ich glaube, da ist der Drang, auch mal ein bisschen abzuheben, kann schnell passieren, wenn ich in die Schule reingehen würde mit den neuesten Puma-Klamotten und mir neben mir die Mitschüler nerven und ich so, ey, was willst du von mir, guck mal da drüber. So kann auch schnell passieren mit der Pubertät, war zum Glück nicht so.
Und es kann ja auch genau andersherum sein. Also es geht ja nicht nur um Abheben, sondern es kann auch sein, dass man vielleicht in diesem Tunnelblick den eigentlichen Plan A komplett aus dem Blick verliert. Also zu sehr an den Profifußball glaubt und nur als kleine Fußnote, die eigentlich gar keine kleine Fußnote sein sollte. Aber wir sprechen jetzt hier gerade über euren Weg und über unseren Blick auf das Ganze. Laut Studien gibt es rund 15.000 Spieler, die pro Jahr alleine aus Afrika in den europäischen Jugendfußball geholt werden. Das ist nur Afrika pro Jahr 15.000 Spieler. Da gibt es ja auch, da werde ich auch eine Doku verlinken, wo eben auch das Zitatfreund von Professor Dr. Arne Güllich rauskommt. Es gibt quasi noch eine komplett weitere Dimension. Wir reden jetzt hier über Menschen, die von Dresden nach Dortmund gezogen sind, kurz nach Nürnberg. Kann man im Buch alles nachlesen. Das ist aber halt nochmal ein Unterschied, weil man kennt das Land, man hat eine Peripherie, man hat Leute, die einem helfen. Es gibt noch einen kompletten Schwarm an Jugendspielern, die für diesen Traum den Kontinent wechseln und hier komplett alleine sitzen und die dann aber auch einfach fallen gelassen werden, so ähnlich wie ihr manchmal auch aussortiert wurdet. Also es gibt viele Abstellgleismetaphern in eurem Buch. Und für euch war aber immer dann auch ein Netz da, was euch noch helfen konnte. Und ihr habt ja jetzt auch, wenn ihr so einen versöhnlichen Blick auf das habt, dann ist es wunderbar und es ist toll. Aber wir dürfen das eben nicht komplett aus dem Blick verlieren. Es gibt da leider noch viel, viel gravierende Geschichten, wo ja viel schlimmere Dinge noch passieren. Und auch davon, also das ist eben Teil dieses Systems Fußball, dass wir irgendwie auch alle toll finden und wir gucken ja gerne Fußball. Und wir drei, vier, wie sind da vier, fällt mir gerade ein, lieben ja auch den Fußball. Aber es gibt dann noch eine komplett andere Ebene. Und das bringt mich zum allerletzten Thema, mit dem wir dann, auch wenn ich echt noch ewig mit euch weiter reden könnte, aber so langsam will ich euch ja auch in euren Feiertag entlassen. Aber da würde ich dich gerne, Stefan, noch mit reinholen. Nämlich zu der Frage, naja, was machen wir denn jetzt mit den Dingen, die wir jetzt so diskutiert haben? Und du hast ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, wir haben ja auch schon ein bisschen das andiskutiert. Der DFB hat Reformen auf den Weg gebracht, sowohl im Jugendfußball als auch zum Beispiel in der Trainerausbildung. Magst du mal vielleicht kurz deine Gedanken zusammenfassen? Was soll sich denn eigentlich verändern im deutschen Fußball? Und jetzt vor allem dem, was wir hier besprochen haben, wie würdest du das bewerten?
Also was soll sich verändern? Ich finde, der DFB hat auf verschiedensten Ebenen gute Ideen, die er versucht umzusetzen. Da kann man darüber streiten, ob – ich habe es ja vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen – ob von Inyo jetzt das alleinige Spielmodell sein soll für die ganz Kleinen. Das sehe ich auch nicht so, aber zumindest als Zusatzoption ist es absolut gerechtfertigt. Die Wettbewerbsreform, dass quasi die A-Jugend und B-Jugend Bundesliga abgelöst werden durch eine Art Turniermodus, wie er in England gespielt wird, muss man dazu sagen, dass die Jugendmannschaften das nicht kennen, dass man Spiele gegeneinander spielt, die nachher in der Tabelle aufgerechnet werden und dann gibt es einen Meister und einen Absteiger, sondern die verabreden sich am Wochenende zu einem Turnier, der FC Arsenal mit dem FC Chelsea und noch fünf anderen, und dann spielen die da quasi den ganzen Tag Fußball oder vielleicht auf zwei Tage Fußball und dann gehen die wieder auseinander. Also ohne diesen Gewinnendruck, den wir jetzt auch schon oft genug angesprochen haben, da kann man darüber streiten, weil da gibt es natürlich Leute, die sagen ja, aber woher sollen die dann lernen, dann zu gewinnen, wo kommt die Mentalität her und so weiter. Also es gibt Pro und Contra, genauso bei der Trainerausbildung, die jetzt tatsächlich schon reformiert ist seit, glaube ich, zwei Jahren mittlerweile, das haben sie relativ schnell durchgeboxt. Da sind gute Sachen dabei, das wird jetzt noch ein bisschen, also noch deutlich mehr aufgeteilt, als es vorher war. Vorher gab es Grassroots, C-Lizenz, B-Lizenz, DFB Elite, damit man am NLZ trainieren darf und die A-Lizenz und dann natürlich den Fußballlehrer darüber. Jetzt wurde noch mal feiner unterteilt und auch sehr, die Ausbildung wird jetzt ein bisschen spezifischer auch. Also ein großes Problem war tatsächlich, dass man viele A-Lizenz-Trainer hatte, die natürlich in ihrer Ausbildung für Seniorenfußball ausgebildet wurden, die haben aber nachher eine C-Jugend trainiert. Also die Kinder mit völlig falschen Voraussetzungen, mit völlig falschen Erwartungshaltungen auch ran und stülpen wieder dieses Erwachsenen-Denken auf 14-Jährige um. Und das ist natürlich, das geht im seltensten Fall, geht das dann gut. Das Problem bei der neuen Trainerausbildung ist jetzt aber aus meiner Sicht, und das höre ich auch immer wieder jetzt von Leuten, die sich damit beschäftigen oder auch da rein wollen in dieses System, dass die Eintrittsschwelle, die ist jetzt teilweise so hoch, dass sich das keiner mehr sowohl finanziell als auch zeitlich leisten kann. Also wenn ich jetzt eine A-Lizenz machen wollte vor drei Jahren, dann hätte mich das, ich meine, vier bis sechs Wochen Ausbildungszeit gekostet, die ich mir dann halt nehmen muss als berufstätiger Urlaub nehmen. Und so über den Daumen vielleicht 2.000 bis 3.000 Euro, so um den Drehdruck, also schon ordentlich Geld, aber vielleicht übernimmt der Verein das Jahr, zumindest teilweise. Jetzt ist es so, dass man noch mehr Zeit investieren muss, dass der Kurs, ich glaube, 6.000 oder 8.000 Euro kostet. Und vor allen Dingen, dass es so eine Art Credit-Point-System gibt, wo du sehr viel mit deiner Vorleistung, in der Regel als Spieler, dafür einzahlst, damit du überhaupt erst in diesen Kurs kommst, also in diesen Lehrgang kommst. Das heißt, Spieler, die unterhalb der Oberliga gespielt haben, die können sich nicht 20 Punkte im Credit-Point-System an sich gut schreiben lassen, das geht gar nicht. Die haben schon mal einen unglaublich schweren Start, überhaupt diese Grenze zu überschreiten, um in diesen Lehrgang zu kommen. So geht es schon los. Oder Menschen, die kein Sportwissenschaftsschulium haben, so wie ich zum Beispiel. Wenn das einer nicht hat, das würden mir jetzt angerechnet werden, ich glaube mit fünf Punkten oder mit zehn oder noch Zusatzqualifikation. Wenn man das alles nicht hat, dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Also da hat man jetzt quasi drei Faktoren, die dich dermaßen einschränken oder die den Zugang von Normalos dermaßen einschränken, dass die eine B-Plus-Lizenz, wie sie mittlerweile heißt, fürs NRZ oder für ihren Stützpunkt gar nicht mehr machen können. Und das verstehe ich nicht. Also der Kreis an Leuten, die ausgeschlossen werden, hat sich auf diesem Trainer-Level aus meiner Sicht eher vergrößert, als dass er kleiner wird. Und das kann einfach nicht der Sinn der Übung sein. Die anderen Sachen, da kann man darüber diskutieren, da sind bestimmt gute Dinge dabei. Aber das finde ich, das ist nicht so besonders gut gelöst. Und das höre ich auch immer wieder von Leuten, die am Stützpunkt arbeiten, dass das einfach den Nachschub an neuen Trainer dann auch irgendwann erschwert. Was sich noch ändern sollte, also wir haben jetzt oft genug über Ambivalenz gesprochen und über Vor- und Nachteile und Pro- und Kontra. Und genau das ist es halt auch leider. Also es gibt für jeden, für jedes Argument oder für jede Entscheidung gibt es gute Argumente und sehr valide Argumente, aber genauso gibt es sie dagegen auch. Und es wird wahrscheinlich schwierig sein, immer alle Seiten zufrieden stellen zu können. Das wird nicht passen, das werden wir nicht hinkriegen. Egal, wer das versucht jetzt umzusetzen, das wird nicht funktionieren. Aber wenn ich mir was wünschen könnte, dann wäre es tatsächlich so, dass wir in Deutschland aufhören auf diesem hohen Rost zu sitzen, sowohl was das Land als Zeug betrifft, um zu sagen, wir wissen schon wie es läuft, als auch – und das ist wirklich ein wichtiger Punkt, den ich hier gerne anbringen würde – wir müssen auch aufhören als Sportartfußball immer zu denken, wir machen alles super top und wir sind hier die Instanz und alle anderen um uns herum in anderen Sportarten sind voll blind oder halb blind. Das ist dermaßen falsch gedacht, dass es wirklich schon weh tut. Und die paar Trainer, die sich die Mühe machen, mal in andere Sportarten zu gucken oder sich mit Trainern aus anderen Sportarten zu unterhalten, die werden auf Dauer besser werden. Und das müssen die deutschen Trainer für sich selber auch zulassen, dass sie diesen Input von außen sich auch selbst, wenn es ihnen schon nicht vorgelegt wird, selbst holen. Weil so wie das momentan so dieses engstündige und nur auf einer Ebene zu funktionieren, das ist bei Spielern schlecht. Das wird jeder Trainer sagen, was kann der Junge mit einem Zehnjährigen, was macht der für Sport? Der spielt Fußball? Okay, ist gut, der spielt Superfußball. Macht der vielleicht noch was anders? Kann der Skifahren? Kann der Basketball spielen? Kann der Rollschuh laufen? Ist der multisportiv? Das bringt unheimlich viel, weil der ein anderes Bewegungslernen hat, eine andere Motorik entwickeln kann. Der kennt andere Sachen. Der weiß, dass er beim Basketball, wenn er einen Ball in die Hand bekommt, genau noch drei Schritte laufen darf oder stehen bleiben muss. Und da muss eine Aktion erfolgen. Und dieses Über-den-Teller-ran-hinausschauen, das fehlt aus meiner Sicht immer noch. Und das ist so ein softer Skill, da muss man nichts können. Da muss man einfach nur bereit sein, andere Dinge zuzulassen. Das würde ich mir wünschen.
Das ist eigentlich genau das, was wir ja versucht haben. Ich muss einen tollen Zusammenfass wieder, Stefan, weil das war das, was wir versucht haben, mit diesem Teller ran. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig. Es gibt viele Sachen mit Pro und Contra, wo man diskutieren kann. Auf der einen Seite aber das mit dieser Führungsperson, Trainer, dass sich da was ändern sollte, bzw. dass da mal drüber geguckt wird, wie geht man mit Jugendspielern um, wie geht man an die Sache ran. Da kann man glaube ich wenig diskutieren, wenn man sich mit dem Thema auskennt, bzw. das auch mal hinterfragt, dass sich da was ändern sollte. Das stimmt. Und genau wie du sagst, ob das jetzt weniger um Gewinn geht, jetzt mit England, ob man so ein System nimmt oder nicht, oder ob man das ganz anders macht, darum geht es ja uns gar nicht. Oder das wünschen wir uns gar nicht. Was eigentlich der Punkt ist, was toll wäre, ist, wenn man anfängt wieder Sachen zu hinterfragen. Und da sind wir wieder bei diesen Scheuklappen und dieses, das haben wir immer schon gemacht, was wir am Anfang gesagt haben. Dieses vom Ross runtergehende, das trifft es super, dass man sagt, man ein bisschen demütig ist, mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und sagen, wir sind gerade nicht die Spitze, sei es fußballerisch, DFB-mäßig oder auch von der Sportart her. Ja, es geht darum zu diskutieren und selbst wenn man Sachen beibehält, aber sie mal wenigstens hinterfragt, ist es der aktuelle Stand, den wir verfolgen wollen. Da gibt es ganz viele Möglichkeiten, über die man mal diskutieren kann. Du hast Stefan angesprochen, wie man in der Jugend die Spielform betreibt. Ist es sinnvoll, dass man mit zehn anfängt, jeden Tag nur Fußball zu spielen? Ist es gut für die Hauberschenkel? Ist es gut für die Knie? Macht es nicht mal Sinn, was anderes zu machen, andere Bewegungsmuster reinzukriegen? Mal ein bisschen – jeder Fußballer, den man sich anguckt, ist verkürzt hinten. Kann man da was machen? Mal einfach als Idee, mal zu sagen, wo ich zum Beispiel mal drüber gestolpert bin, einfach mal auch als Gedankenexperiment. Keiner wundert sich, dass es einen Torvertrainer gibt. Aber es gibt keinen Verteidigung oder keinen Fäherkettentrainer, es gibt auf einmal einen Einwurftrainer. Mal so was zum Beispiel, mal kleinere Gruppen denken. Mal gucken, wie ist wirklich, weil es da natürlich noch um Athletik geht, wenn man Football-Fan ist, American Football, wie sind die in der Athletik da aufgestellt? Wie kann man da was optimieren? Wie machen die das? Wie sind das andere Sportarten, die vielleicht nicht so die Geldressourcen haben mit anderen Sportarten, wie machen die das? Das ist, glaube ich, genau das, um das jetzt abzufangen, was Stefan gesagt hat, und aufzunehmen. Einfach bereit sein, mal Sachen zu hinterfragen und auch mal neue Dinge aufzunehmen, zu evaluieren. Bringt es was? Bringt es uns was vorwärts? Mal zu diskutieren. Und nicht einfach in den Muster verhalten und verbleiben, die man hat, weil man es immer schon gemacht hat, weil es bequem ist. Man kann ja Sachen wieder verwerfen. Genau wie wenn man sagt, der Utova-Trainer ist super, aber ein Verteidigungstrainer, wenn man die Ressource braucht, braucht man nicht. Kann man ja wieder wegschmeißen, aber mal darüber diskutieren, mal Sachen versuchen, einfach mal in Frage zu stellen. Und das fehlt dann schon. Da muss man dann sagen, klar gibt es dann kein richtig und falsch. Aber man muss dann da rausfinden und gucken, was wollen wir jetzt und dann sind wir wieder bei dem Thema Umsetzen. Weil was wir jetzt entscheiden, haben wir erst in 15 Jahren, 10 Jahren, 20 Jahren. Die jungen Spieler, wenn der DFB jetzt eine Entscheidung trifft, dann freut er sich 2040 über, was weiß ich nicht, was da ist, ob es ein Nationalteam ist oder WM. Da kann er sich dann darüber freuen. Das muss man dann einfach mal entscheiden und dann auch dabei behalten. Einfach mal die Augen aufmachen.
Und weniger Angst vor Fehlern haben. Also das, was man ja auch auf dem Spielfeld, vor allem im Juniorenfußball, auch gerne hätte. Mach auch mal die Sache, die du gerade im Kopf hast, auch wenn sie schief geht. Das kann man auch auf struktureller Ebene sehen. Da braucht man sich ja nur die deutsche Infrastruktur angucken. Als letzte Frage will ich aber nochmal das nutzen, dass ich vermute, dass diese Sendungen ja auch Hörerinnen und Hörer hören oder bei YouTube sehen, die vielleicht jetzt gerade noch in diesem NLZ und Juniorenfußball drinstecken. Gibt es etwas, Marius, Alex, was ihr denjenigen mitgeben wollen würdet?
Auf jeden Fall darf der Spaß niemals verloren gehen. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was wir uns am Ende so ein bisschen auch gedacht haben im Nachhinein. Das ist manchmal, dass man da echt selber ein bisschen zu verkopft war und zu streng mit sich selber und allem. Also sobald es anfängt, dass der Spaß wirklich komplett verloren geht, dann ist das ein ganz falscher Weg. Das hört sich immer so einfach an und man sagt das immer so, verlier den Spaß nicht, aber das ist wirklich ein ganz essenzieller Punkt, dass man sich da manchmal dran besinnt, warum man überhaupt angefangen hat, Fußball zu spielen und warum man das alles macht. Und sonst würde ich einfach sagen, dass echt versuchen zu genießen und das alles aufzusaugen, weil das schon eine besondere, schöne Zeit ist und sich da einfach nicht verschließen vor irgendwas. Das wären so Sachen, die hätte ich, glaube ich, gerne garmals in meiner aktiven Zeit ein bisschen mehr gemacht, mich da ein bisschen mehr drauf besonnen. Ja, weil das hätte ein bisschen geholfen, glaube ich, im Nachhinein, ja. Ja, wir haben über, dass man früh in die Struktur reinkommt, was ja auch gut ist mit Training zum Spiel fahren, zum Turnier fahren und wieder Training. Wenn man ja diesen, wenn man diesen Weg weit geht, ja, über Landesauswahl beispielsweise, und dann rutscht man ja automatisch in diese Strukturen rein. Genau das, was Marius sagt, die Lockerheit beibehalten, den Spaß, warum man das eigentlich überhaupt macht, warum man jeden darauf steht, das ist wichtig. Und eigentlich muss man auch ganz klar sagen, das glaube ich, wenn man so 13, 14 ist oder auch so diesen Weg geht, das möchte man vielleicht nicht hören und auch gar nicht wahrhaben, es kommen Tiefschläge, egal in welcher Form. Man steht mal nicht in der Aufstellung, man hat vielleicht mal eine Verletzung, dass man wenigstens bereit ist und weiß, so was kann kommen. Und dann auch gefestigt versuchen zu sein und nicht in Panik verfallen. Oft ist es auch so, ich habe auch viele gesehen, die mit sich selber dann zu kämpfen hatten, warum funktioniert mein Körper nicht, ja, und sauer auf sich selber wird, warum hält das verdammte Knie nicht. Dass man da ein bisschen zurück stritt und Marius hat das einfach toll gesagt. Fußball ist eine ziemlich geile Sache, aber nicht das Wichtigste. Also, dass man da ein bisschen diese Lockerheit behält. Dann sind wir wieder bei Plan A, den wir jetzt neuerdings Plan A nennen. Die Schulen nicht vergessen, aber da vor allem den Weg auch gehen. Also, wir würden ja wieder gehen. Also, was da auch auf höchstem Niveau, wenn man es schafft, auf seinem höchstem Niveau, Fußball mit Gleichgesinnten, die wirklich – es gibt es geiler als Mannschaftssport, wo man zusammen Siege feiern kann oder auch zusammen verlieren kann, je nachdem. Das lohnt sich und denen auf jeden Fall gehen, aber auch wissen, es gibt noch was anderes.
Ich bin sehr erleichtert, dass hier die 23- und 24-Jährigen sagen, nehmt die Schule ernst. Dann muss es nämlich keiner von uns alten Säcken sagen. Stefan, deine letzten Worte.
Ja, also, es ist, glaube ich, jetzt alles gesagt. Ja, also besser als Alex und Marius, kann ich es jetzt nicht mehr sagen, soll ich auch dazu sagen. Ich habe das nicht erlebt. Die beiden, die wissen, worum es geht, die wissen, was da Phase ist. Die haben alles mitgemacht, von oben bis unten. Und deswegen, ja, wie gesagt, es ist aus meiner Sicht, also wir könnten noch ewig wirklich sehr viel weiter reden. Es gibt noch viele, viele andere Aspekte, die wir auch schon alle heraus versucht haben, auszuarbeiten. Aber das würde mir als Schlusswort jetzt tatsächlich auch schon reihen.
Okay, dann lege ich dir als Schlusswort einfach in den Mund. Jungs und Mädchen da draußen, sporto fit ist der, ill shit. Dann kann man besser durchatmen. Es geht doch nichts um über Menthol auf der Brust. Das habe ich gelernt. Hat einer von uns hier in der Runde irgendwann mal Nasenpflaster getragen? Ich nicht. Ich war so kurz davor, aber ich hatte das Glück, dass es das bei uns halt auf dem Land nicht gab. Aber ich bin ja genau in dieser Phase mit dem Fußball sozialisiert worden. Mit den ganzen Lauteren, die da ihre Nasenpflaster getragen haben. Also ja, ich bin auch froh, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Also ich danke euch dreien sehr. Das war eine sehr interessante Sendung. Ich kann nur noch mal das Buch empfehlen von und über Marius von Cysewski und Alexander Schulte, die Jahrtausendtalente heißt es, wie zwei junge Fußballer ihren großen Traum lebten. 240 Seiten erschienen bei edelsports am 6. Mai. Also wenn ihr es euch jetzt besorgt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann seid ihr mit unter den ersten, die das lesen. Und das muss ja wohl das Ziel sein, immer unter den ersten zu sein. Das haben wir ja heute gelernt. Malius, Alex, ich danke euch beiden sehr für eure Zeit. Und ich hoffe irgendwie, dass wir uns auf jeden Fall nochmal hören im Rasenfunk. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das war hier nur eins von mehreren Tribünengesprächen zu diesem Thema.
Ja, sehr gerne. Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, das nächste Mal gibt es dann auch zwei funktionierende Kopfhörer. Ich verspreche es. Und danke an Stefan Rommel, der Ed Knall-Göber, auf Twitter mit seinem 22. Auftritt im Rasenfunk. Danke dir, lieber Stefan, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte empfehlt diese Folge weiter, empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter und unterstützt den Rasenfunk, denn all das hier gibt es nur, weil ihr es finanziert. Ansonsten gäbe es so ein Medium wie den Rasenfunk nicht. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr auch all die anderen Sendungen, die wir so produzieren. In diesem Sinne, das war Tribünengespräch Nr. 50. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk.